GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS ENDED HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH ONE OF
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. SENATOR
JACKSON IS ATTENDING REMOTELY
TODAY CENTER JACKSON ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. I AM GOOD MORNING
SENATOR HILL AND I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY IN THE OFFICE OF MY STAFF
BRAD HUDSON. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING SENATOR
JACKSON'S NICE TO SEE YOU- AND-
IT IS A REMINDER PLEASE SHOULD
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTER.
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I S. IT EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED- SENATOR
JACKSON THAT YOU USED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO UN MUTE
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN- YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
HEARING ROOM SHE'S TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL ALSO WE DO. ON
pFRONT OF YOU AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. ONE
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS NINE SEVEN FOUR
FIVE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN THAT'S
NINE SEVEN FOUR FIVE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND- FOR OPPOSITION.
PRESS THERE'S ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER.
THIS CAN BE A VERY SHORT WAIT.
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTED AND YOU
ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR. TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY IN THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS OF MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STRIP MINE. SAYS AND OUR
HEARINGS IN IS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE AY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS FOR PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW
USE. OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT TO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. NOW WE HAVE FIFTEEN
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. AB
EIGHT OH FIVE AND- AB FOURTEEN
NINETY TWO WERE REMOVED FROM
MARCH AND UP BY THE AUTHORS AND
CHORE TO COMMENT ON A BE
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO. LET ME SAY
THAT- I WANT TO REALLY COMMEND
THE AUTHOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP
IN THIS ISSUE I I'VE BEEN.
EXTRACTED OUR STAFF IN THE
LABOR COMMITTEE TO WORK WITH
HER OFFICE AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS. TO DEVELOP
LEGISLATION OR OVER THE IN. ON
THIS VERY IN TOPIC THAT SHE IS-
IS A CHAMPION FOR SO. BEFORE WE
HEAR A PRESENTATION ON THE
BILL'S LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO BE
HEARD SENATOR HILL HERE SENATOR
HILL HERE SENATOR MORALE- OUT
HERE GENERAL HERE SAID. SENATOR
JACKSON. SENATOR JACKSON HERE
SENATOR JACKSON HERE SENATOR
MITCHELL. SENATOR PAN HERE
CENTER PAN HERE. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU THE CLIP CHILDREN
NOTRE QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED AND NOW WE WILL
HEAR FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR WE
ARE GOING A LITTLE OUT OF ORDER
THIS MORNING- I HAVE- I WILL BE
PRESENTING THE FIRST- ITEM ON
OUR AGENDA AB ONE NINETY SIX
BUT I WILL HAVE TO LEAVE TO
PRESENT A BILL SHORTLY SO WE
WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER TWO AS
OUR FIRST- ITEM TO BE HEARD
THIS MORNING THAT IS AB THREE
TWENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLANCA RUBIO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB THREE
TWENTY THREE HERE TODAY I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND AGAIN
THINKING THE SENATORS FOR ALLOW
ME TO BRING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE- TODAY. SENATORS MANY
NEWSPAPERS IN CALIFORNIA'S ARE
FAILING THE DEMISE OF
NEWSPAPERS WILL MEAN MANY LOST
JOBS AND WILL LEAVE MANY
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT LOCAL
GENERAL JOURNALISM NATIONWIDE
NEWSROOM EMPLOYEES HAVE TO
CLIMB FROM ONE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN THOUSAND IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT TO SEVENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN- WITH SEVENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED JOBS LOST LAST YEAR
ALONE IN THE BAY AREA WHEN THE
SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE AND
EXAMINER WERE MERGED IN TWO
THOUSAND THERE WERE OVER SIX
HUNDRED REPORTERS. TODAY THE
NUMBER IS ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY. AS WE ALL KNOW
FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACY IS
DEPENDENT ON A WELL FUNCTIONING
CONSTITUENCY. I'M SORRY WELL
INFORMED CONSTITUENCY. AS AN
IMMIGRANT TO THIS COUNTRY THAT
REPRESENTS AN EXTREMELY DIVERSE
SECTION OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
I AM PROTECTED PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
ETHNIC MEDIA. AFRICAN AMERICAN
LATINO ASIAN AND OTHER ETHNIC
NEED NEWSPAPERS COULD BE THE
FIRST ONES TO GO. IN ADDITION
SOME COUNTIES IN THE STATE MAY
BECOME NEWS DESERT WITH NO
PAPER OF RECORD. JUSTIN MY
DISTRICT ALONE I AM AWARE OF AT
LEAST FORTY SIX ETHNIC NEWS
PUBLICATIONS THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES IN MY COMMUNITY. AND
THAT'S IN MY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
AS YOU GUYS SENATORS REPRESENT
TWICE THE AMOUNT THAT I DO SO I
IMAGINE THAT THAT THAT WOULD BE
DOUBLE FOR YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
IN FACT MY FATHER WHO IS NOW
EIGHTY YEARS OLD HAVE ALWAYS
RELIED ON THE OPINI ON AS HIS
PRIMARY SOURCE OF NEWS. FOR
MANY MANY YEARS I REMEMBER AS A
CHILD. PICKING UP THE PAPER FOR
HIM. AND MANY OF OUR ELDERLY
POPULATION ALSO DEPENDS ON
THEIR NEWSPAPERS TO GET THEIR
NEWS. EVERY MORNING. IF THEY-
IF THEY DON'T HAVE THIS-
NEWSPAPERS THESE NEWSPAPERS I
IMAGINE THAT THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO TRANSITION TO GOOGLE TO GET
THEIR NEWS. I THOUGHT THIS
DECLINE IN COMMUNITY NEWS IS
NOT ONLY COSTING US JOBS BUT
IT'S ALSO HARMING BOTH ETHNIC
COMMUNITIES AND SENIORS WHO ARE
ACCUSTOMED TO GETTING NEWS FROM
OUR PHYSICAL PAPERS. NOW WITH
ALL OF THIS CONTEXT GOING ON TO
THE BACKGROUND NEWSPAPERS ARE
FACING AN ADDITIONAL AVERAGE-
INCREASE OF 85% AND
DISTRIBUTION COSTS IF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE DOES NOT
EXTEND. THE EXEMPTION FROM AB
FIVE FOUR NEWS CARRIERS I HAVE
HEARD FROM MANY SMALL
PUBLICATIONS THAT DISCUSS FORCE
PAPERS TO ABANDON THEIR CONTACT
CONTRACT DELIVERY MODEL. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT NEWSPAPERS LOSE TOUCH
WITH GOVERNMENT BUSINESS
EDUCATION AND NEIGHBORS. AGAIN
TO USE MY PARENTS AS AN EXAMPLE
COMMUNITY NEWSPAPERS PLAYED A
HUGE RLE IN KEEPING THE
COMMUNITY OF THE CITY OF BALL
INFORM ON CORRUPTION ISSUES
WERE THAT. ARE WHICH WERE
PLAGUED IN THE CITY HALL AT
THAT TIME AND THAT'S WHEN MY
PARENTS RESIDE. COMMUNITY
NEWSPAPERS. AND ETHNIC
NEWSPAPERS PLAYED A HUGE IN X.
THE- THAT WAS TAKING PLACE
ALLOWING RESIDENTS TO THE
RESIDENTS RESTRUCTURE THE CITY
COUNCIL AND RESTORE PUBLIC
TRUST. SENATORS AND THIS IS WHY
AB THREE TWENTY THREE IS HERE
IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY. FIRST AB
THREE TWENTY THREE WILL EXTEND
THE NEWSPAPER CARE YOU'RE
EXEMPT FROM TO FROM DYNAMAX
TEMPORARILY TO JUNE FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THE
LANGUAGE HERE CONCERNING
NEWSPAPER CARRIERS IS IDENTICAL
TO AB ONE SEVENTY FROM LAST
YEAR WHICH PROVIDED A ONE YEAR
EXEMPTION WE ARE SIMPLY PUSHING.
THIS BACK UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. SECOND THE BOBBY STATE
EIGHT TO GIVE PREFERENCE TO
LOCAL NEWS ORGANIZATIONS
SPECIFICALLY ETHNIC MEDIA AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS. AND
CONTRACTS AND SUBCONTRACTS FOR
MARKETING AND ARE BEACH
ADVERTISING SERVICES. THE
EXEMPTION INCLUDED IN AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE CONSIDERS
THE ECONOMIC HARDSHIP THE
PANDEMIC HAS PLACED ON THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY ON TOP OF AN
ALREADY DIMINISHING CELLS IN
RETURN REVENUES. EQUALLY AS
IMPORTANT THE EXTENSION DOES
NOT ALLOW THE NEWSPAPERS TO
ESCAPE THE CURRENT LIABILITY
AND RESPONSIBILITY TO DELIVERED
DELIVERY DRIVERS UNDER THE
PAROLE OF STANDARD. REFERENCE
GIVEN TO LOCAL MEDIA WILL
BENEFIT BOTH THE COMMUNITY AND
PUBLISHERS ALIKE BY ENSURING
THAT THE PUBLICATIONS ARE
FINANCIALLY SOUND AND CAN EXIST
WELL INTO THE FUTURE. AND THAT
JOBS THESE PUBLICATIONS PROVIDE
CAN ALSO EXIST. AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER I AM AN IMMIGRANT TO
THIS COUNTRY THAT PRINT THAT
REPRESENTS AN EXTREMELY DIVERSE
SECTION OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
I'M PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF ETHNIC
MEDIA BECAUSE I KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING DYNAMIC
MEDIA OPTIONS AVAILABLE IN HOST
AND THE HOST OF LANGUAGES. NOT
EVERYBODY GOES TO THE SAME
PLACE FOR SOURCES OF NEWS AND
INFORMATION AND I AM
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
KEEPING I THINK MAY BE A VIABLE
AND WIDELY AVAILABLE IN
CALIFORNIA. I THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO- WE DO
HAVE- TWO WITNESSES BUT TO DO
THAT JUST WANTED TO- ANNOUNCED
THAT DUE TO THE CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS.
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED IN THIS CASE IT IN
TODAY'S HEARING. FOUR MINUTES
TOTAL TIME- FOR THE SUPPORT AND
FOUR MINUTES FOR OPPOSITION ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME. AFFILIATION AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE MEASURE SO WE
DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- JIM BEARD OF
CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION GENERAL COUNSEL AND
ARTURO CARMONA SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
INTERMEDIA AND THE LAW OPINIONS
TO OF. HOWEVER WOULD LIKE TO GO
FIRST PLEASE BEGIN JIM. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
JIM DO YOU WORK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO AND THE
SENATE COOPER'S FOR AMENDING AB
THREE TWENTY THREE TO SAVE
LOCAL JOURNALISM- MISTER CHAIR
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR TIME
AND YOUR EXPERTISE- IN. HELPING
TO DEVELOP THIS AS WELL. LAST
YEAR I APPEARED BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE IN AND ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT GIVING NEWSPAPERS A ONE
YEAR EXEMPTION OR NEWSPAPER
CARRIERS FROM THE ABC TEST.
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED BY AB FIVE
AND THE DYNAMICS DECISION.
THREE PAPERS INTENDED TO USE
THAT TIME TO SIT DOWN WITH
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS EXPLORE
ALTERNATIVE MODELS OF
DISTRIBUTION TO COMPLY WITH THE
LAW. BEGINNING ON JANUARY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE BEGIN
THAT PROCESS AND THEN COATED
NINETEEN AB AND- REPORTS OF
EVERY SIZE AND TYPE EXPERIENCED
AD REVENUE LOSSES THAT THREATEN
THEIR VERY EXISTENCE. SMALL
MIDSIZE NEWSPAPERS INCLUDING
ETHNIC PUBLICATIONS. TOP 56%
DECREASE IN JUST THREE MONTHS.
DALEY'S 48% DURING THAT TIME
PERIOD. WE THINK THAT DURING
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS SIMILAR.
OUR NUMBERS WILL BE REPORTED.
IN ADDITION EIGHTEEN NEWSPAPERS
HAVE SHUT DOWN THEIR PRINT
OPERATIONS BECAUSE THEY JUST
COULDN'T MAKE ENDS MEET AND ALL
OF THIS HAPPENED AT A TIME WHEN
DEMAND FOR INFORMATION FROM
NEWSPAPERS ABOUT COVERT
NINETEEN IS HIGHER THAN IT HAS
EVER BEEN. WELL DIGITAL
REVENUES GROWING FOR DAILY USE.
PRINT REVENUE IS STILL THEIR
WHITE BLOOD AND IT IS EVEN MORE
ESSENTIAL FOR SMALL TO MIDSIZE
NEWSPAPERS. AB THREE TWENTY
THREE WOULD PROVIDE THE
BREATHING SPACE NECESSARY TO
FOR THESE NEWSPAPERS TO GET
BACK ON THEIR FEET DURING THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. WHICH SOME
PROJECTIONS ESTIMATE WILL TAKE
AS LONG AS FIVE YEARS. THAT
BELIEVE THERE WILL BE
ADDITIONAL NEWSPAPERS THAT WILL
LIKELY DISAPPEAR LEAVING THEIR
COMMUNITIES WITH NO LOCAL
SOURCE OF INFORMATION AND THOSE
THAT DO SURVIVE WILL LIKELY
ELIMINATE HOME DELIVERY TO
RURAL AREAS. ELIMINATING JOBS
SUCH AS JOURNALISTS. IN OTHER
POSITIONS. AB THREE TWENTY
THREE IS ABOUT SAVING LOCAL
JOURNALISM AND FOR ALL THESE
REASONS WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER WORD
NOW MISTER CARMONA. PLEASE IN.
YEAH I MEAN I DON'T MIND YOU'RE
INVITED THERE AND ON BEHALF OF
THE- YOU KNOW NEWSPAPERS AND
NEWS OUTLETS ACROSS. YOU KNOW
ME YOUR COLLABORATIVE. HERE'S
MORE YOU WANT AND THE WOMAN
RUBIO PARTY LEADERS.
UNPRECEDENTED HE MORE WITH NEWS
THE FIRST THING. IT REALLY IS
AND IN THE BACK ON NEW AND.
WELL THERE'S A REAL WHY. A
LANDER OTHERS COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
ARE DEEPLY THE PROJECT NEWS
OUTLETS AND LOCAL AND WE.
CALIFORNIA STATE. MY ARTICLE
RUNNING ONLY PARTICULARLY OUR
COMMUNITY ALL ARE NOT YOU CAN
COMMUNITY I'M PARTIALLY AND
NEEDED ON THAT ONE OF THEIR I'M
CONSTANTLY H. WHAT WE UNITED MY
COMMUNITY OUR YOU TALKING. AND
LET. WILL THEIR THE COMMUNITY
NOT CALLER. THE LEGISLATION NOT
THAT FRIEND. THAT PROGRESSIVE
WHAT TO PROTECT YOUR. NEWS ROOM
ANOTHER. YOU CAN MAKE IT LOOK
COMMUNITY ON THAT EIGHTY THREE
THREE IT CAN REFERENCE THE
NEWSPAPER TRYING TO. THE PEOPLE
HOLDEN MIGHT MEAN THAT 838589%
IT IS NOT YEARS THEY'LL. WE
HEAR IT WRONG WORK ON BEHALF OF
OUR FRONT WILL LISTEN- REALLY
HAPPY FOR YOU TO. I'M NOT NAY
THANK YOU MUCH THANKS YOU VERY
MUCH FOR TO COME ON UP TO NOW
WE WILL GO TO WITNESSES- HERE
IN- ROOM TO FORTY TWO OR THREE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE TWENTY THREE SEEING NO
ONE WE WILL WE ALSO HAVE A ROOM
ONE TWELVE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE C.
NO ONE THERE WE WILL. NOW GO TO
THOSE WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TWENTY THREE WE WILL THEN BEGIN.
CERTAINLY IN GENTLEMEN TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IT IS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWO THREE.
THE MODERATOR HEAD NOTING HERE
AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR NO
ONE IN Q. ADDRESS ONE MORE TIME-AND SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE THERE
PLEASE TO THAT. WE SHOULD JUST
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. CERTAINLY AT
THIS TIME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE TWENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE LINE. I
THINK WE HAVE A FEW QUEUING UP
AT THIS MOMENT. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE THANK YOU.
AND I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY- WE
WILL GO FIRST TWO LINE NUMBER
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
MITCHEL BEER AND I REPRESENT
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BUSINESS
FEDERATION ALSO KNOWN AS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THREE
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU ARE MOVING TO
THE NEXT LINE PLEASE BEAR WITH
ME. L. B. LINE NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BY NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOING TO THE NEXT WITNESS
MODERATOR. THANK YOU MOVING ON.
WE WILL GO TO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
I DO APOLOGIZE FOR THE
DELAY ONE MOMENT.
PINE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FIFTY NINE YOUR OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS MITCHEL BEER
AGAIN I JUST I JUST WANT.
BORDERLINE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS MARYANN
RADIUS IN OUR OUR I WORK IN THE
LONG RUN HUNTING DOGS I'D BE A
LAYOFF. AND CALL THE NINETEEN I
WOULD LIKE TO. SO FOR THE A. B.
MMHM MMHM KNOWLEDGE THE
PREDATORS. CHANGE OUR DOWNFALL
AFTER THAT FLIGHT THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU WORLD BANK YOU NEXT
TO ONE ONE ARE NOT PLEASE GO
OUT. THANK YOU FOR DOING
CALIFORNIA'S BACK CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
YOUR MIND ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO YES I AM ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
AVAILABLE. AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
NARCOTIC OFFICERS. HE THOUGHT-
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
THREE I KNOW THAT THAT.
ASSEMBLY OVERALL I'M FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIVE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PAUL RYAN
ALIGNED ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU WE
WERE TOP ON BEHALF OF ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL SUPPORT.
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWO THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. FOUR NINE ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL.
THREE NINE ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOUR AVAILABLE AFTER
CALIFORNIA .COM OFFICE TO SERVE.
WELL WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF NOT
MAYES RUBIO REFERENCE ALLOW
PREMIUM BOB WHETHER JOURNALISTS
ABOUT THE NO MEMBER OF MY
FAMILY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
WILL TO LINE ONE EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS BEVERLY. I
WOULD LAY OFF FROM AUTOMATIC.
EIGHT THREE TWO ONE SIX BECAUSE
I NEED MY JOB RIGHT WE ARE
HEARING SUPPORT TESTIMONY FOR A
THREE TWENTY THREE SO PLEASE-
WAIT ON THE LINE UNTIL WE GET
TO THAT BILL. NEXT WITNESS.
THANK. THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE
MORE IN Q. OVERLAND ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
REGINA BROWN WILSON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK MEDIA AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE-
MEASURE. YOU THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER LINE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU THE WILL
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION. I DO NOT
SEE ANYONE NOTED AS A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS SO WILL
FIRST GO TO FORTY TWO OR THREE
C. NO ONE AT THE MICROPHONE
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE- WHAT'S
THE REASON TO FORTY. ONE TWELVE
OKAY THAT'S GOOD ROOM ONE
TWELVE C. NO WITNESSES AT ONE
TWELVE LET'S GO TO TELEPHONIC
LINE- MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR. ANY WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO AB THREE TWO THREE. AND GET
ITS NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. AT THIS TIME IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB THREE TWENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONCE AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. IT APPEARS WE DO HAVE AT
LEAST ONE LINE QUEUING UP. ONCE
AGAIN AT THIS TIME IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JILL BERRY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BROADCASTERS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE THOUSAND RADIO
AND TV STATIONS SERVING
CALIFORNIA WE'RE CONFLICTED
WITH THIS BILL BECAUSE WE FULLY
SUPPORT THE NEWSPAPERS AND
THEIR EXTENSION OF THE AB FIVE
EXEMPTION HOWEVER WE BELIEVE
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
ESTABLISHING AN ADVERTISING
PREFERENCE FOR LOCAL NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS MAY BE
MISINTERPRETED. TO APPLY ONLY
TO NEWSPAPERS WHEN IT'S
IMPLEMENTED BY THE STATE WE
WOULD SUGGEST THE AUTHOR EXPAND
THE REFERENCE TO READERS ON
PAGE SEVENTEEN LINE THIRTY TWO
READERS VIEWERS AND LISTENERS
TO CLARIFY THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
THAT IT APPLIED TO ALL LOCAL
NEWS OUTLETS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME I HAVE
KNOWN FOR THEIR IN Q. HM JUST
CHECK ONE MORE TIME. ABSOLUTELY
SO ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
LINES COMING UP. WITH THAT WELL
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND I SEE CENTER
MITCHELL. PLEASE THANK YOU DR
PAN YOU KNOW I WAS OVER ON THE
SENATE FLOOR LOOKING FOR MY
LABOR COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ARE.
WHO WHO ARE THE MORNING I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE FAMILY MEMBER
FOR CARRYING THE BILL I WAS
PRIVILEGED TO CARRY THE BILL
LAST YEAR AND IT'S CLEAR THAT.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH. PUBLICATIONS TO HELP
THEM NAVIGATE KIND OF THE NEW
NORMAL WELL CERTAINLY CALL THE
NINETEEN HAS EXACERBATED THERE
ALREADY- DIFFICULT TRACK. BUT
GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE OF ETHNIC
MEDIA IN THE DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT. BOB FROM THE LOS
ANGELES SENTINEL TO LOPING
YOUNG TO THE KOREAN- DAILIES
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT
COMMUNITIES- CONTINUE HAVE
ACCESS TO TIMELY NEWS THAT'S
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
APPROPRIATE- SO I'M PROUD THAT
YOU'VE- PICKED UP THE- THE
BATON. AND I'M HERE TO
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THE BILL AND
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE THE MOTION
ALL RIGHT SO- THE BILLS BEING
MOVED BY CENTER MITCHELL. THERE
ANY. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT I JUST. US
GENERAL. I ALSO APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD- I
DO REMEMBER SITTING ON THIS
COMMITTEE WHEN MR WHO ARE SPOKE
ON ACTUALLY THAN CENTER
MITCHELL'S BILL- I APPRECIATE
THAT WITH. SENATE JACKSON OUR
GUYS LOOKING AT THEIR HANDS
OKAY. IF YOU DON'T MIND TODAY
I'LL JUST FINISH MINE AND THEN
GO TO YOU OKAY SELVES SINCE ON
ASIA CHARIOTS MARC MY REMARKS-
SO- APPRECIATE IT TILL THAT
HAPPENED IN BETWEEN I DO I DO I
COUNT ON THE- NEWSPAPER
PUBLISHERS TO BE SURE TO
CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION THAT
HE TALKED ABOUT- BECAUSE I.
DON'T THE PURPOSE OF DYNAMAX
THAT DECISION WAS REALLY ABOUT
THE WORKERS AND PROTECTING THE
WORKERS AND WELL CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW- HIGHLY VALUE OUR ETHNIC
MEDIA AND THEIR ROLE SAME TIME
WILL BE SURE WORKERS ARE
PROTECTED AS WELL AND THAT THEY
HAVE THEIR SYSTEMS YOU KNOW THE
BENEFITS THEY GET FROM BEING
EMPLOYEES. SO UNDERSTAND WHY WE
NEED TO DO THIS EXTENSION BUT I
THINK THE GOAL SHOULD STILL BE
IN THE END THAT- IF THEY ARE
EMPLOYEES THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO BE EMPLOYEES AND HAVE THE
BENEFITS OF BEING EMPLOYEES SO-
WITH THAT LET'S NOW MOVE. ON TO
SENATOR JACKSON. JUST CHECKING.
THANK YOU ARE JUST BRIEFLY I
WANT TO. A SECOND- THE COMMENTS
BY SENATOR PAN COBEN IS A
CRISIS BUT IT'S MY HOPE THAT WE
DON'T USE IT AS AN EXCUSE AND
SO- I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE I DO AGREE THAT OUR
LOCAL MEDIA IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT IN TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A WELL
EDUCATED POPULACE IT IS THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
AND OUR NEWS MEDIA HAVE TO
KEEPING YOU- MEETING THAT
EXPECTATION THAT AND THAT
CHALLENGE BUT AS WE GO FORWARD
I AM HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL-
RECOGNIZE- WHAT AN EMPLOYEE IS
PROTECT THOSE EMPLOYEES AND NON
THE LESS CONTINUE PROVIDING
THOSE KINDS OF SERVICES AND
INFORMATION THAT THOUGH WE
EXPECT AND NEED FROM THE MEDIA
GOING FOWARD SO- I DIDN'T JUST
WANT TO SECOND THAT INTO. TO BE
CLEAR THAT MY SUPPORT IS REALLY
BAY UPON THE FACT THAT WE ARE
IN THIS CALL THAT NINETEEN
CRISIS AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
RESOLVE THESE ISSUES GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS SAY
NONE- SIMMER WHICH LIKE THE
CLOTHES YES- THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND THEN
JUST TO CLARIFY UNDER THIS BILL
THEN USERS WILL STILL BE. OUT
WILL STILL NEED TO ABIDE BY THE
BERLE'S STANDARD AND SO MY HOPE
IS TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION
BUT ALSO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE
CAN FIND THAT THAT HAPPY
MEDIUM. UNFORTUNATELY A COVETED
UP AND EVERYBODY'S EYES AND I
THINK THAT WE CAN GIVE THE
PUBLICATIONS THE NEWSPAPER
AGENCIES AN OPPORTUNITY TO. TO
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH THEIR
COMMITMENT THAT THEY ALREADY
DIDN'T ORIGINALLY MADE AND WITH
THAT I WOULD. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH RUBIO SO THE-
THIS IS EIGHTY THREE TWO THREE
IT'S BEEN MOVED BYCENTER
MITCHELL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS- SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS
PLEASE TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES
IN ORDER TO CAST A VOTE SENATOR
HILL. SENATOR MORALE MORALE I
THAN A MORALE HI SENATOR
JACKSON. JACK KEANE HI SENATOR
JACKSON HI SENATOR MITCHELL
MITCHELL AYE CENTER MITCHELL HI
SENATOR PAN AND I CENTER PAN HI.
OKAY SO THE BILL'S FOUR ZERO
WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL AND
SO. NONCENTRAL AS A CHANCE TO
VOTE ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
OWN SAKE OF THAT'S- ALL RIGHT-
THE NEXT ITEM SHOULD BE- ITEM
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY SIX SIX
FOUR BY SUMMER COOPER. DO WE
KNOW IF HE'S ON HIS WAY. OKAY
SO INSURANCE OKAY. IS A SUMMER
BURKE. OBERNOLTE THE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR THAT'S BEEN PULLED
OKAY I THOUGHT I AM PRESENTING
I DON'T KNOW IF IT MESSES UP IN
TERMS OF THE PEOPLE IN ORDER ON
THE LINE BUT I AM PRESENTING
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE AB TWO
SIX FIVE EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
MISS BURKE. HAVE A PRESENT
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE HERE
OKAY IF THAT PLEASES THE ACTING
CHAIR. LET ME- I DON'T KNOW IN
TERMS OF FLYING PEOPLE OUT FOR
THINGS I JUST NEED TO DOUBLE
CHECK WITH OUR STAFF IS JUMPING
AHEAD CAN BE A PROBLEM. I DON'T
TEND. TO THE ITEM TEND TO SIX
FIVE EIGHT BY SUMMER BURKE.
OKAY OKAY I THANK NINE TWENTY
ONE YEAH THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
MICHAEL MARTINEZ FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE IS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE PRIMARY
WITNESS. OKAY IS AND HEN-
SIMILAR LEVIN'S BILL EIGHTY ONE
FOUR FOUR ONE C. AVAILABLE IS
THAT WE'RE STILL HEARING THAT
ONE. THANK YOU HAVE BEEN
TRADING AT A DIFFERENT THAT ARE
LOOKING AT HERE YEAH. I WANTED
FOR ALL MY- FROM WELL LET'S SEE
IF WE CAN GET MAYBE. IF WE TRY
TO DO BOTH SIMULTANEOUSLY. R. I
ALSO DO UP TO MANY PEOPLE
BECAUSE AS SOON AS SUMMER HELL
COMES BACK WILL. YEAH SIMILAR
LEVIN'S AVAILABLE CONSUMER
WITNESS. SO ANY OTHER BILLS
PULLED ASIDE FROM OBERNOLTE AND
IT OKAY RIGHT IS THIS HELLO HI
CENTER LEVINE. WELCOME FULLER
OF REMAINS READY WILL GO OUT
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB FOURTEEN FORTY ONE YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IF
PRESENTATION ON THAT AND TAKE
UP A THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE.
PAGE STRUKHOFF DESTRUCTOR.
SEVEN THIRTY DID YOU DID YOU
JUST WANT TO START AT P. PLEASE
REPEAT WHATTHAT I WILL I'D
DECLINE EVER REPRESENTING
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE AND- TAKE UP
TO A THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE IF
THAT PLEASE ENTER MEANS OKAY SO
I GUESS IT'S SO FAR THE THING
I'M TRYING TO LINE UP THE
WITNESSES SO I DON'T KNOW IF
THE WE HAVE THIRTY ONE SEVENTY
FIVE DO WE HAVE BEEN HERE. I
WILL MEANS IN THE POLICY
COMMITTEE DECLINE PRESENTATION
SEVEN RIGHT NOT GOING TO VOTE
ON IT ARE YOU TRYING TO BILL OR
YES. TELL YOU WHAT DRYING UP HE
WOULD DRAWING FORTY FORTY ONE
AND- OKAY. UNLESS YOU'RE REALLY
EAGER. OKAY I JUST WANT
CONFERENCE. IN A I THOUGHT THE
CURRENT PRESENTATION HEARD. OF
THAT IN THE LUNAR. BUT CENTER
MORE OF DIFFICULT. YEAH FORTY
FORTY ONE THOUSAND OKAY SO YOU
WERE TRYING FOURTEEN FORTY ONE
SO THAT'S BEING WITHDRAWN. OKAY
DO WE HAVE WITNESSES FOR THIRTY
ONE SEVENTY FIVE OR NO-
WITNESSES FOR THIRTY ONE
SENATOR NO WITNESSES OKAY. PART
OF THE PART OF THING WE'RE ALSO
TRYING TO TIME IS- IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW. THE PUBLIC COMING ON
THE LINE AND THEY'RE EXPECTING
IT'S LATER AT THE SAME TIME
THEY SHOULD HAVE. THEY DIDN'T
KNOW YOU PULL THAT THEY SHOULD
NOT YOUR BILL WOULD COME UP
EARLIER ANYWAY SO I THINK WE'RE
OKAY THEN. SO MUCH OF THE ONES
THAT ARE RIGHT IF EVERYONE'S
OKAY THEN WE WILL MOVE ON TO.
I'M SORRY. ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN.
AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE BY
SOME MEMBER LEVINE. ALL RIGHT I
THINK YOU THINK VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION- MISTER TURN
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS TO AB
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE THAT
HAVE BEEN WORKED ON. WITH YOUR
STAFF ENSURED WITH MEMBERS
WHICH WOULD CLARIFY THAT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION AND
RETALIATION TRAINING BE
COMPLETED BY IN EACH ELIGIBLE
MINOR ACCOMPANIED BY A PARENT
OR GUARDIAN PENDING PASSAGE OF
AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE
TODAY THESE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
TAKEN IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR HILL AND HIS STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE I'M VERY SORRY THAT
SENATOR HILL IS IN HERE AS A I
WANT TO THANK HIM OF COURSE FOR
HIS SERVICE TO THE LEGISLATURE.
THROUGH THESE YEARS AND WHAT A
PLEASURE IT HAS BEEN
LEGISLATING WITH HIM AS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED EIGHTY
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE IS A
CLEAN UP BILL FROM MY AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY EIGHT IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
AN AGE ELIGIBLE MINOR AND THEIR
PARENT OR GUARDIAN TO COMPLETE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PREVENTION
AND RETALIATION TRAINING
DEVELOPED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING.
MINERS IN THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY ARE UNIQUELY
VULNERABLE TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
IN THE WORKPLACE THE POWER
DYNAMIC IN THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY MAKES IT ESPECIALLY
DIFFICULT FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE TO IDENTIFY AND REPORT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN FEAR THAT
IT WILL COMPROMISE THEIR
ABILITY. TO WORK EVERY
WORKPLACE SHOULD BE FREE FROM
SEXUAL HARASSMENT INTIMIDATION
AND RETALIATION AB THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE- WILL PROMOTE AGE
APPROPRIATE DISCUSSIONS AMONG
MINERS AND THEIR PARENTS OR
GUARDIANS ABOUT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION AND
CREATE A SAFER WORKPLACE FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MEMBER- AS YOU MENTIONED
THERE'S NO LEAD WITNESS ON THIS
SO- LET'S GO ON TO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WILL FOR
START WITH FORTY TWO OR THREE
C. NINE HERE LET'S MOVE. TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. THE THERE
LET'S MOVE TO THE- TELEPHONE
LINE. PLEASE THE LINE. FOR
PEOPLE WHO WISH TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE. THANK YOU LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN AT THIS TIME IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN WE ASK YOU TO PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE AT THIS TIME. IT
APPEARS WILL HAVE AT LEAST ONE
LINE ONE MOMENT PLEASE GIVE. IT
WILL FIRST GO TO THE LINE OF
ONE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO I'M
SORRY MY NAME IS BERNIE THAT.
THE SHOP STEWARD AT THE OAKLEY
AREA. GLYCOLIC AND I'M NOT ON
THE EVIL LORD OF LOCAL. HE NINE
YEAR. I AM FOR AB. THIRTY ALL
RIGHT WELL WE'LL BE HEARING
THAT LATER ON WE ARE ON AB
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE SO-
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB. THREE ONE SEVEN FIVE. ONCE
AGAIN TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ANDTHEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AT THIS TIME WE ARE WHAT
WE DO HAVE LINE FIFTY QUEUED UP
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU. POLITIES I
WAS A TRYING WE HAVE KNOWN HERO
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU NOW LET'S
MOVE ON THEN TO OPPOSITION TO
AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE WILL
BEGIN IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
SINGING ON THE MICROPHONE AT.
THEN ROOM FORTY TWO THREE LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE LET'S
MOVE ON TO TELEPHONIC LINES
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR PEOPLE WISHING TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE ONE
SEVEN FIVE. AGAIN THIS IS ON
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE ONE
SEVEN FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OKAYIF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE WE
INVITE YOU TO PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUING UP. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT LET'S BRING THIS BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SENATE
MITCHELL. THANK YOU AND WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBER FOR HIS
CONTINUING WORK IN THIS AREA I
KNOW YOU'RE ON CONSENT SO
PLEASE. PARDON ME FOR HAVING TO
PULL BUT I JUST WANTED TO RAISE
AN ISSUE. ON THAT IF IT WERE ON
CONSENT I WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT. JUST
AS THE RULE THAT A POINT OF
REFERENCE INFORMATION OUT IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BOTH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LET LEVINE AND I
INTRODUCED AND PASSED TWO
SEPARATE BILLS FOCUSED ON
ENSURING EMPLOYERS. PROVIDED
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PREVENTION
PROGRAMS. WITH THE INTENTION OF
EMPLOYEES WILL BE TEN TO THE
MAKING SURE EMPLOYEES COULD GET
ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION THEY
NEEDED. TO CURTAIL UNWANTED.
AND INAPPROPRIATE SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT. WELL THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT TRAINING
HAS NOT BEEN EASY FOR ALL
EMPLOYERS WE BOTH AGREE THAT
IT'S ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY. I
KNOW THAT THE FAMILY MEMBERS
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE
TO THE BILL BEFORE US. HOWEVER
I DO WANT TO RAISE IT SOME
CONCERNS WITH SOME OF THE
FOUNDATIONS. BUILT BY AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY EIGHT IS PREVIOUS
BILL THAT ARE TIED TO THE
CURRENT BILL BEFORE US. UNDER
CURRENT STATUTE. AGE ELIGIBLE
MINORS ARE DEFINED AS. FOURTEEN
TO SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS. WHICH
MEANS UNDER CURRENT LAW
CHILDREN TO. CAME. FOURTEEN
YEAR. AND OLDER DO ACCESS. TO
SEXUAL HER. PREVENTION
UNFORTUNATELY THAT LEAVES
CHILDREN BELOW THE AGE OF
FOURTEEN WITHOUT ACCESS TO THE
SAME PREVENTION TRAINING
PROGRAMS. OLDER MINORS ARE
REQUIRED TO RECEIVE. THAT'S
IMPORTANT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
BECAUSE AGAIN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I CO AUTHORED ALONG
WITH OUR FORMER COLLEAGUE
SENATOR LARA SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY FIVE WHICH IS A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT INDUSTRY.
PROHIBIT ANY MINOR UNDER THE
AGE OF TO WAIVE THEM RIGHTS
WITHOUT THE ADVICE OF AN
ATTORNEY THE POINT I'M TRYING
TO MAKE IT AS YOU KNOW HOW WE
ARE DEFINING KIND OF AGE OF
MATURITY WHEN YOU FUNDAMENTALLY
UNDERSTAND YOUR RIGHTS. WELL
AGAIN THAT BILL PERTAINS TO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SPACE IT'S
ANOTHER REMINDER THAT WE MUST
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PROTECT
OUR CHILDREN AT EVERY AGE AND
STAGE IN THEIR LIFE AND WHETHER
THEY'RE INTERFACING WITH THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM OR
THEY'RE- THEY'RE YOUNG ACTORS
IT'S EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE. AGES AND STAGES OF
MATURITY SO I DID SUPPORT
TWENTY THREE THIRTY THAT THE
TIME IT BUT IT'S BECOME CLEAR
WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF ALL
THESE BILLS AND ESPECIALLY
COMING OUT OF THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT THAT NOT ALL CHILD IS
IMMUNE TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND ALL ACTORS REGARDLESS OF
AGE SHOULD AT LEAST KNOW THEIR
RIGHTS SO I JUST WANTED TO
RAISE A THAT ISSUE GOING ON THE
PREVIOUS BILL- YOU SET THAT AGE
RANGE THE MIDDLE MADE FROM
FOURTEEN. AND HOPE THAT THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY HAVE ON GOING TO.
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S JUST. WE
ARE LEAVING MANY CHILDREN VOTE.
AND ADDRESS. FAR TOO MANY IF WE
LOOK BACK AT SOME OF THE CASES
THAT HAVE COME BEFORE US. NOT
BEFORE US WOULD HAVE BECOME
PUBLIC ALL THE YOUNG WOMEN ON
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES THE- JIM
THIS- SO MANY YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN WHO HAVE COME. MAY THERE
OWN SEXUAL ABUSE OR MISCONDUCT
PUBLIC WE KNOW THAT FOURTEEN IS
NOT A MAGICAL AGE AND SO THAT'S
WHY I WANTED TO RAISE THE
ISSUE- AND HOPEFULLY ENCOURAGE
YOU. OUR COLLECTIVE TO PERHAPS
COME BACK IN FUTURE YEARS AND
ADDRESS THAT AGE I KNOW THE
POINT OF THIS BILL IS FIGURING
OUT WHO'S ALLOWED TO DO THE
TRAINING PARENTS HAVE TO BE
ENGAGE I GET THAT. BUT I THINK
THAT WE ARE. NOT LEAVE AT BEST
IT WILL SOON FOURTEEN AT THE
APPROPRIATE AGE TO REQUIRE THIS
KIND OF TRAINING TO EMPOWER
CHILDREN TO KNOW THEIR RIGHTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO JUST EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE TO YOU- FOR PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE DETAILS HERE-
WE BUMPED INTO EACH OTHER- WEEK
OR SO AGO IN THE GARAGE AND WE
DON'T HAVE A CHANCE TO CONNECT-
BUT WHAT I WANTED TO SAY TO YOU
THEN. WAS ON HOW CREATIVE I WAS
OF- YOUR PRESENCE IN THE- THE
OVERSIGHT HEARING ON
CORRECTIONS THAT TOOK PLACE
DURING THE PANDEMIC- AND SO
YOUR ATTENTION TO DETAIL AND
PURSUING- THINGS OVER TIME- IS
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS MUCH STRONGER FOR- AND- WITH
REFERENCE TO THIS ISSUE. WE'VE
BOTH BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS THIS BILL IS-
BILL NUMBER I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY SINCE I FIRST INTRODUCED
THE FIRST VERSION. I BELIEVE IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT WAS NOT
SUCCESSFUL UNTIL THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT PUSH THIS UP. IN THE
MINDS OF- THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEES AND SO FORTH SO- YES
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO I
BELIEVE THERE IS ANOTHER BILL
COMING UP LATER. ON THE AGENDA
THAT ALSO ADDRESSES THIS AND-
AND SO- OUR WORK IS CUT OUT FOR
US THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR VERY KIND WORDS
AND I WOULD JUST HOPE THAT AS
FUTURE GENERATIONS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT. NOT ONLY
AGE APPROPRIATE TRAINING BUT
BEING REALISTIC AT WHAT AGE
THIS TRAINING MUCH START
FOURTEEN EIGHTH GRADERS FOR MY
HOMEBUILDING IN FAR TOO LATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ONE OF.
RIGHT I JUST ALSO JUST WANT TO
BRIEFLY SAY YES CERTAINLY- AT
FIRST I WANT THANK YOU SIMILAR
LEAN FOR YOUR WORK AND THEN- ON
ON THIS ISSUE- I DO AGREE WITH
CENTER MITCHELL AND I KNOW THAT
YOU DO AS WELL- YOU KNOW FROM A
DEVELOPMENTAL STANDPOINT. THAT
PHYSICAL PUBERTY FOR GIRLS
ACTUALLY START CAN START EARLY
AS EIGHT. WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
THAT WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE
ELEMENTAL UNDERSTANDING AS WELL
AND AGE APPROPRIATE BUT THERE
ARE WAYS TO- YOU KNOW ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES AN AGE APPROPRIATE
WAY FOR YOUNGER CHILDREN AND I
KNOW YOU'RE ALSO DRESSING YOU
KNOW EDUCATING THEIR PARENTS AS
WELL- SO I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
AND LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
CONTINUED WORK IN THIS AREA AND
THIS ISSUE- BUT AS REGARDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR PAN
AND AS WE LOOK AT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CHILDREN I THINK
THAT WE ALSO NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT TO THOSE WHO
PREY ON CHILDREN REGARDLESS OF
THEIR DEVELOPMENT AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT- WE WE'VE GOT-
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON SO THANK
YOU. I THANK. YOU A SENATOR
JACKSON. THANK YOU I KNOW THAT.
IS GETTING A LITTLE EXPANDED
AND- I THINK IT SHOULD SHOULD
BE WE KNOW THAT THIS INDUSTRY
IS NOTORIOUS. WHETHER IT'S
CHILDREN OR ADULTS. AND YOU
KNOW THERE ARE SO MANY HIGHLY
PUBLICIZED INCIDENTS AND I'M
SURE THERE ARE SO MANY MORE
THAN AREN'T. I THINK IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON US NOT ONLY TO
EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN AND THEIR
PARENTS WHO ARE FREQUENTLY ON
SET WITH THEM AS THEIR
GUARDIANS BUT I THINK WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE. THAT THE
PERPETRATORS ARE WELL AWARE
THAT THERE ARE A CRIMINAL AND
CIVIL CONSEQUENCES TO THIS
BEHAVIOR. BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO CATCH IT
ALL THESE YOUNGSTERS ARE ALMOST
BY DEFINITION A VERY VULNERABLE
THEIR CHILDREN- AND- I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THIS
BE WE KEEP THE- OF THE KLIEG
LIGHTS IF YOU WILL- IN VERY
SHARP- DIRECTION- ON THIS
INDUSTRY BECAUSE OF JUST THE
INHERENT. NATURE OF ITS HISTORY
AND THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THIS
KIND OF ABUSE- BASED UPON THE
IMBALANCE OF POWER. IN
OPPORTUNITY THAT EXISTS SO- I
ALSO THANK YOU FOR THIS AND
AGREE WITH THE SENATOR MITCHELL
THAT. REALLY THE VULNERABILITY
IS SOMETHING THAT. OCCURS EVEN
AT YOUNGER AGES BUT AND BUT
THIS IS A WHOLE ISSUE- I HATE
TO SELECT THIS INDUSTRY BUT WE
DO KNOW THAT HISTORICALLY IT
HAS A VERY MURKY PAST- AND
WE'VE SEEN INSTANCES VERY
RECENTLY WITH A- SORT OF THE
QUOTE UNQUOTE GLAMOUR FOLKS WHO
HAVE ENGAGED IN THIS KIND OF
BEHAVIOR WITH CHILDREN. I IT
REALLY IS AN AREA WHERE WE HAVE
TO DO- AND BE VERY AGGRESSIVE
IN OUR PROTECTION OF THIS FEW
OF THE ISSUES AND ALSO PEOPLE
IN THE INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE SO
THANK YOU. AGAIN FOR DOING THIS
AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON.
OKAY THANK YOU ARE THERE IN THE
OF THE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. OKAY SAYING NONE US
EMERALDS LEVINE WHICH LIKE THE
CLOTHES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR. THAT DIAL AND THE DISK.
AND YOUR TIME TO THIS AND AGAIN
MY GRATITUDE TO- THE CHAIR AND
HIS STAFF WHO HELPED US-
SHEPHERD THIS BILL TO THIS
POINT. I'M GRATEFUL FOR IT I
SPENT CLASS WHEN I VOTE. OKAY
THANK YOU SO THIS IS EIGHTY
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR JACKSON-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS ANDERSONYOU'RE
TAKING AMENDMENTS IN
APPROPRIATIONS SO IT'S TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS. SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS
PLEASE TURN YOUR MICROPHONES IN
ORDER RECORDED VOTE SENATOR
HILL. SENATOR MORALE. SENATOR
JACKSON. JACKSON ALL RIGHT
SENATOR JACKSON HI SENATOR
MITCHELL MITCHELL ARE CENTER
MITCHELL HI CENTER PAN HI
SENATOR PAN HI OKAY TO BILLS
CURRENTLY THREE ZERO WILL PUT
THE BILL ON CALL FOR THE
MISSING MEMBER AND DIRECTING
YOU HAVE TO THAT SELF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR TURN NUMBERS HE-
OKAY. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
AUTHORS HERE. BOEHNER HOPE OUR
FACES AVAILABLE. HER BILLS
PULLED OKAY SORRY I DON'T HAVE
THE MOST RECENT FULL BLAST.
OKAY SO NEXT WOULD BE ITEM
NUMBER SIX RODRIGUEZ. HEY LET'S
SEE. AND YOUR HEALTH NOT
YOURSELF. S. R. SHOULD. SHOULD
I TAKE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
YEAH RIGHT OKAY SO LET'S START
AS OF SEPT THIRTY PLEASE READ
THE BILLS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR I DON'T HAVE THE FULL
LIST IN FRONT OF ME. THE
CONSENT CALENDARS A. B. THREE
THREE SIX NINE. OKAY SORT OF
ALL RIGHT TO JUST HAVE ONE DONE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR TO EIGHTY
THREE THREE SIX NINE AND THAT
IS SAY DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
MITCHELL- SECURITIES CALL THE
ROLL FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO CAST A
VOTE SENATOR HILL. SENATOR
MORALE BROWN WHY IN OUR MORALE
HI SENATOR JACKSON. JACKSON HI
SENATOR JACKSON HI SENATOR
MITCHELL IT'S A LAN CENTER
MITCHELL HI CENTER PAN HI
CENTER PAN HI. OKAY SO THAT
BILLS CURRENTLY FOUR ZERO
PROTECT ON CALL ARE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ON CALL. ALL RIGHT. SO
I SEE RODRIGUEZ HAS A COUPLE
BILLS SINCE- CHAIR I UNDERSTAND
I'M ALSO PRESENTING A BILL FOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER- YES THIS
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN. PUERTO
ARE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AND I
UNDERSTAND PER MY STAFF OF THAT
SEES AMERICA CAR RIGHT HERE.
ALL RIGHT- ALL RIGHT SIR AND
ACTUALLY SILVA KARA TO ARE YOU
PRESENTING. I'VE FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE CORRECT I'D
LOVE TO BUT NO YOU HAVE TO HAVE
YOUR OWN THAT'S RIGHT OKAY
LET'S LET'S GO AHEAD AND- SEE
ABOUT DOING YOURS FIRST SO-
UNTIL I CHECKED WE HAVE THE
WITNESSES AVAILABLE. SO THE
TEN EIGHTY TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT. DO WE HAVE ARE THE
WITNESSES AVAILABLE FOR THIS
BILL. SO I CHECK AND CONFIRM
THAT IT'S ITEM NUMBER. TEN
EIGHTY TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
BY SUMMER KALRA. THANK YOU. I'M
LOOKING OVER SANDERS. I'M OF
HAVE A WRONG BEHIND NUMBER TOLD
US NINE YEAH THE OKAY MINE CHEN
LOOKS LIKE IT'S OFF YOUR-
THAT'S. OKAY ON I JUST WANT
WILL CHECK ON THIS FOLLOWING MY
ITEM NUMBER BECAUSE THAT'S OUR
NUMBER NINE THE NUMBER OKAY SO
WE BOTH TYLER IMAGE ON OKAY ALL
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT EXCELLENT SO
LET'S THANK YOU. LET'S MOVE ON
THEN. ITEM NUMBER. I PROBABLY
FOR ANYONE WHO SO NOW ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB FIVE EIGHTY
PRICE MIRACLE. AND THIS IS ON
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM AND
PROGRAMS AND TRAINING COSTS.
SOME MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BE AN- YES. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SHARES AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH
WHAT THE COST FROM PLAYER
MANDATED TRAINING PROGRAMS
CONSTITUTE AS A NECESSARY
EXPENDITURE FOR DIRECT PATIENT
CARE WORKERS AND JOB APPLICANTS
THIS BILL WILL PROHIBIT HEALTH
CARE EMPLOYERS FROM REQUIRING
DIRECT PATIENT CARE WORKERS AND
JOB APPLICANTS TO COVER THE
COST WILL REIMBURSE THE
EMPLOYER FOR ANY EMPLOYER
MANDATED TRAININGS ARE PROGRAMS.
THIS BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE
HOSPITALS TO PAY FOR ANY
LICENSING OR CERTIFICATION
NECESSARY TO LEGALLY PRACTICE
IN THE SPECIFIC EMPLOYEE
CLASSIFICATION. I LEARNED THAT
SOME HEALTH CARE EMPLOYERS HAVE
REQUIRE JOB APPLICANTS TO
PARTICIPATE IN EMPLOYER
REQUIRED TRAININGS AS A
CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT. HOLDEN
THE WORKER OR APPLICANT
FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR ANY
EMPLOYER REQUIRED TRAININGS BY
OBGYN TO SIGN AN AGREEMENT TO
WORK FOR THE HOSPITAL FOR A
DESIRED TIME OR REIMBURSE. THE
EMPLOYER THEY LEAVE BEFORE THE
SPECIFIED TIMES AND ACCEPT IS
ACTUALLY UNACCEPTABLE THE PLACE
ISN'T ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL
BURDEN. FOR NURSES SEEKING
EMPLOYMENT. AS WE KNOW
CALIFORNIA HAS A GROWING
NURSING SHORTAGE AND THIS
PANDEMIC WILL ONLY EXACERBATE
THE SITUATION AND THE NEED TO
RECRUIT MORE HEALTHCARE
WORKERS. AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
IT WOULD SIMPLY CLARIFIED THAT
EMPLOYER MANDATED TRAININGS
CONSTITUTE AS A NECESSARY
EXPENDITURE. PROHIBITING HEALTH
CARE EMPLOYERS FROM COMPELLING
DIRECT PATIENT CARE WORKERS AND
JOB APPLICANTS TO PAY FOR
EMPLOYER MANDATED TRAININGS OR
PROGRAMS. BUT WITH ME TODAY A
PROVIDING A TESTIMONY TO OUR
JACKSON CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
AND MISTAKEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMBER LET'S NOW MOVE TO THE
WITNESSES AND- WE HAVE A TOTAL
OF FOUR MINUTES. OF TESTIMONY
BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU- I WILL
GIVE IT TWO MINUTE WARNING FOR
THE FIRST ONE IF WE GET TWO
MINUTES JUST SO YOU KNOW YOU'RE
TRYING TO GO INTO THE FIRST
TIME- WILL BEGIN WITH. JACKSON
FOR THE NURSES FOLLOWED BY MIX
STAGGER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION SO LET'S.
BEGIN WITH THE TAYLOR JACKSON
PLEASE. HERE NUMBER ASKING GOOD
MORNING TAYLOR THAT WOULD COVER
NURSES. WE ARE FONG OF THE
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT.
NEIGHBORHOOD REQUIRE EMPLOY
PAID CAR NOTHING FOR WORKERS TO
PERFORM THEIR JOB OR COSTS
INCURRED BECAUSE THEY FOLLOW
THE DIRECTIONS OF THEIR
EMPLOYER. THE COURTS HAVE RULED
IT INCLUDES EMPLOYER REQUIRED
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS OR
TRAINING. I'M THE OPPOSITE AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
ASSEMBLY EXTENDED PROTECTION TO
JOB APLICANTS. TO ENSURE THEY
ARE PROTECTED IN THE SAME WAY
THE LAW ALREADY PROTECTS
EMPLOYEES. IN A HAVE BEEN
FIRSTHAND OR EMPLOYER COMPOSING
THESE TALK ON JOB APPLICANTS-
CURRENT LAW. YLIDES ARE
CHOOSING TO TRACK JOB
APPLICANTS CONTRACT SHOULD
BEGIN THE FUTURE EMPLOYEE
RESPONSIBLE FOR COSTS. THE
COURT ALREADY TEAMS BELONG TO
THE EMPLOYER. IT IS NOT THE
EMPLOYEE'S RESPONSIBILITY TO
PAY FOR IT IT SHOULD BE THE
POTENTIAL EMPLOYEES
RESPONSIBILITY. EITHER REPORTER
ARE CURRENTLY. FOR THE CALL OF
THEIR CENTERS WHICH I THINK PER.
FOR THEM TO LEGALLY FOR THAT'S
WHAT THE VICTIMS COSTS. FOR
NURSING NAMES ARE THEATER
BACHELOR DEGREE. IN THERE AND
LOOK LIKE PEOPLE BAND AND THE
BELUM CARE COOLEY. ROCK IT
LOOKS DOES HE- WE ARE
CONTINUING WORK WITH DEPARTMENT
INDUSTRIAL ROCK RELATIONS IN
STATE CALLED. TO FURTHER THE
LANGUAGE AND WE SHOULD BE
REACHING REGULAR YEAH. THE BILL
INSURANCE BEFORE WORKERS ACTING
BECOME A- THERE NOT INTO THE
FOR CAR. THE COURT IN THE- HAVE
ALREADY. SHOULD PEOPLE BY THE
IN. TRYING CLOSE THE BAD ACTORS
ARE YOU. A NURSES ARE I ON EACH
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT THAT.
THANK YOU NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO
MISTAKE. THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FOR. HEY YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBER MUCH WITH THE K. LABOR
FOR ALL IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
WOULD ALIGN OURSELVES WITH
COMMENTS THE AND PREVIOUS
WITNESS. THIS REALLY IS ONLY
THAT IF TO CLOSE BUSINESS KIND
OF A TIME ON PRINCE IN BOTH THE
LABOR CODE INTO PROBLEM LAW
THAT IF AN EMPLOYER REQUIRES
YOU RECEIVE US THE FIFTH TYPE
TRAINING SPECIFIC TO WORK DONE
BY THE EMPLOYER. A YEAR UNDER
THE CONTROL OF EMPLOYER FOR THE
AND YOU BE. FOR THAT THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY THAT THE WORKER
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO ASSUME THE
COST THEMSELVES AND TO DO SO TO
REQUIRE THEM TO RECEIVE THAT
KIND OF EMPLOYER SPECIFIC
TRAINING AND NOT PAY THEM FOR
IT IS REALLY A KIND OF WAIT
STAFF AND OBVIOUSLY THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T SUPPORT
AND WE DON'T THINK SHOULD
CONTINUE. I THINK THIS BILL
DOES A GREAT JOB OF CLOSING
THAT LOOPHOLE IN A FAIR AND
RESPONSIBLE AND ANALYZED AND
MEASURED WAY WE URGE YOUR.
SUPPORT THANK. OKAY VERY MUCH
WITH THAT LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
OTHER TESTS. IN SO. OF AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT AND
THIS NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY WILL BEGIN AND-
THIS ROOM ONE THIRTY SEEN ON
THE MICROPHONE LET'S MOVE TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. C. KNOWN IN
ONE TWELVE- WILL MOVE TO THE
TELEPHONIC LINE SO MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
PEOPLE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT. WILL FIRST GO TO
THE LINE ONE FOUR NINE ONE
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU RENEE BAYARDO YEAH
YOU CALIFORNIANS COURT THANK
YOU. AN EXCELLENT TO LINE FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
SHARE MEMBERS MATT BROWN ON THE
AFTER THE ENGINEERS AND
SCIENTISTS IN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND IF THERE ARE ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
KNOWN FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR- NOW WILL MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT- THERE'S NO FORMAL
LEAD OPPOSITION SO WILL BEGIN
AND HERE IN BROOME FORTY.
THIRTY SCENE NO ONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM LET'S MOVE ON TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. SO YOU KNOW
WHAT THIS IS IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELEPHONIC LINE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES. FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU AN OUT
THIS TIME IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. IT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT. WE DO HAVE AT
LEAST ONE NINE KILLING UP ONE
MOMENT THANK YOU.
ONE ONE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BERMAN FIFTY
DIFFERENT OPPOSITION YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LIVING
ANSWER ANY OTHER OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FIVE
ANNIE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANKS VERY MUCH- NOW LET'S
MOVE TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS UNDER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. OKAY
SEEN NONE- RECALL RIGHT THIS
CERTAINLY IS A COMMON SENSE IN
MY MIND- BILL AND CERTAINLY
IT'S- APPROPRIATE THAT- THAT.
PLEASE NOT HAVE TO BEAR THE
COST OF TRAINING THAT'S
REQUIRED FOR THE JOB THAT'S NOT
RELATED TO THAT REALLY FRANKLY
ISN'T. TO HAVE ANY DIRECT GAIN
FOR THEMSELVES- OUTSIDE OF
THEIR FUNCTIONING IN THE JOB.
SO WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THINK OF ALL THE
DEPARTMENT PAS- CENTER JACKSON
NEXT YEAR HAND UP NOW. I'M
SORRY I'M A LITTLE SLOW ON THE
TREE CARE I KEEP. HAVING
TROUBLE FINDING THEM REYES
HAND- IT'S JUST A ONE ONE
QUESTION I CERTAINLY SUPPORT
THIS- IT WAS. BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION THAT- THERE MIGHT BE
A BENEFIT TO A LITTLE GREATER
CLARITY. FOR EXAMPLE IF IT
SHOWS THAT YOU NEED TO BE-
WORDS ED CAPABLE OF YOU KNOW I.
UNDERSTAND A PARTICULAR TYPE OF
COMPUTER PROGRAMS. RELATIVELY
COMMON UP WITH THAT ALSO BE
INCLUDED UNDER- A TRAINING THAT
WOULD THEN HAVE TO BE PAID FOR
BY THE EMPLOYER IN OUR COMPUTER
CERTIFICATION FOR EXAMPLE ON A-
WORD CERTIFIED OR WHATEVER OR
WE TALKING ABOUT THINGS THAT
FOCUS VERY SPECIFICALLY. ON THE
NATURE OF. THE WORK THAT A
NURSE FOR SOME MEDICAL TRAINEE
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO HAVE THAT
IS DIFFERENT THAN GENERAL
TRAINING. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION OF THE SENATOR- YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY I THINK THAT
TOOK FOCUS HERE REALLY IS ON
THE EMPLOYER MANDATES A
TRAINING OF A TRAINING PROGRAM
OR SOMETHING SPECIFIC TO. THE
WORK THAT'S BEING ASKED OF
THESE TO RED RIVER DIRECT CARE
PERSONNEL SO- IF THERE IS SOME
KIND OF COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY
THAT IS BEING. ASKED OF A OF
THE APPLICANT AND THEN AND THEN
IN THAT CASE IT WOULD APPLY IF
IT'S IF IT'S SPECIFIC TO THE
JOB THAT IS BEING- ASKED OF THE
OF THE DIRECT PATIENT CARE
WORKER BUT I THINK YOUR POINT
IF IT'S A MUCH MORE GENERAL
KNOWLEDGE KIND OF ISSUE OF
IMAGINE. THAT THAT WOULD BE-
YOU KNOW A PART OF THE
INTERPRETATION WHETHER IT
REALLY IS SPECIFIC TO THAT JOB
OR NOT BUT IT REALLY IT RELLY
COMES DOWN TO- IF THAT BECAUSE
NOWADAYS THERE VERY WELL MAY BE
SOME KIND OF TECHNOLOGY OR
SOFTWARE WITHOUT YOU THAT MAY
BE LOST- THAT THAT WOULD
QUALIFY AS UNNECESSARY
EXPENDITURE BUT TO YOUR POINT.
I THINK THAT- YOU KNOW IT WOULD
IT WOULD BE TRAINING THAT'S
BEING ASKED OF BY THE EMPLOYER
THAT IS REQUIRED OF THE WORKER
IN ORDER TO DO. THAT JOB OR BE
HIRED FOR THAT JOB. OF MY OWN
SUGGESTION IS IF YOU WERE GET A-
IT DOESN'T IN ANYWAY IN. MY
INTIMACY. FOR THIS MEASURE I
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE- IF
THERE COULD BE SOME CLARITY ON
THAT I THINK IT MIGHT HELP.
GOING FORWARD WHERE THERE MIGHT
BE A DISPUTE BETWEEN THE
EMPLOYER AND THE EMPLOYEE SO
MAYBE A LITTLE TWEAKING OF THE
LANGUAGE GOING FORWARD. I JUST
A SUGGESTION ARE CRITICAL MY
GOD HAPPY TO LOOK AT THAT AND
WORK WITH THE SPONSORS AND WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF HERE
AS WELL AS IT. IS WELL AS IT-
AS THE BILL HOPEFULLY MOVES
FORWARD WE CAN WORK WITH YOU
KNOW. APPROPRIATE SENATE
COMMITTEES STAFF AND TAKE YOUR
STRESS ON THE- MONEY. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIGHT THERE ARE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SAY NONE OF WHICH ARE LIKE THE
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK A FEW I
DON'T THINK YOU'RE RIGHT THANK.
YOU I DO NEED TO HAVE A MOTION.
THERE'S A MOTION. OKAY TO MOVED
VICE MITCH. ALL RIGHT SO AGAIN
THIS IS AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT THAT'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER MITCHELL THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO CAST A
VOTE. CENTER HILL. SENATOR
MOREAU BROWNELL. CENTER MORALE.
NO CENTER JACKSON. JACKSON ALL
RIGHT SENATOR JACKSON HI
SENATOR MITCHELL. MITCHELL ON
WHY MITCHELL HI SENATOR HILL
BUT USUALLY CENTERS CENTER PAN
HI CENTER PAN FIVE. SO THE
BILLS CURRENTLY THREE ONE WILL
PUT THE BILL ON CALL FOR THE
MISSING MEMBER WELL ACTUALLY
YOU KNOW WHAT SHOULD I JUST GO
AHEAD AND IT SAYS REPORTER THIS
IS WHERE ON ITEM NUMBER NINE
EIGHTY TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
BY SUMMER KALRA- ARE YOU
PREPARED TO VOTE ON THIS OR
SHOULD WE JUST MOVE ON. AT YOUR
AVAILABILITY AT. DID YOU CALL
THE ROLL THE ACTUALLY WE'RE
JUST WE JUST ABOUT THE FEDERAL
BUT THE WALK INS ARE ACTUALLY
GOING TO HEAR A LOT. THE BILL
IS AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT.
FILE NUMBER IS NINE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. I
WILL CALL THE ABSENT MANNERED
MEMBERS. PLEASE SPEAK INTO YOUR
MICROPHONE SENATOR HILL. HILL
HI SENATOR HILL HI EXCEPT THOSE
OUT FOR ONE. RIGHT NOW NO
PASSED THE GAVEL BACK TO CENTER
HELP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WE WILL MOVE TO. UPDATE YOUR SO
WE HAVE CALLING JUSTICE.
FOR
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT PLEASE
TELL ME WHICH BILLS HAVE BEEN
PULLED WALL THEY SETTLE UP
THEIR- BILLS HAVE BEEN PULLED
FROM AGENDA. IF YOU MARRY WITH
THE PERMISSION OF AN THROUGH
THE CHAIR IS THINKING ABOUT-
STAFF SENATE LABOR COMMITTEE
THE BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN PULLED.
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR AB. EIGHT ZERO FIVE. FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE. FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
A. B. FOURTEEN NINETY TWO. AT
THIS POINT THAT IS ALL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE DALLAS FOR
YOU SENATOR HILL THE- DEBATE
SELF ALTOGETHER AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK I'M HERE
FOR YOU SIR. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU TO SENATOR PAN FOR
HIS ALWAYS COULD- LEADERSHIP
AND HE SAID A LOT OF CHEERING
PRACTICE OF THE SENIOR FOR
SURE- SO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALL
OVER WHAT WILL NOW MOVE TO YOUR
AB THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR. I
TO PRESENT AB THREE COULD BE
THE TO SIXTY I DO WANNA THANK
YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF I
KNOW A LOT OF TIME AND ENERGY.
HAS BEEN PUT INTO- INTO HAVING
THIS BILL A BILL TO BE
PRESENTED TODAY AND I
APPRECIATE THAT- SB THIRTY
SIXTEEN PROVIDES CRITICAL
PROTECTIONS FOR CALIFORNIA
WORKERS HAVE BEEN LAID OFF TO
THE COVER NINETEEN CRISIS. BY
ENSURING THAT THEY CAN RETURN
TO THEIR HOMES ONCE THEY BECOME
AVAILABLE AGAIN. IN THE PAST
SEVERAL MONTHS INDUSTRY SUCH AS
HOTELS AIRPORT HOSPITALITY
OPERATIONS EVENT CENTERS AND
BUILDING SERVICES A LEAD OFF
ONE THIRD OR MORE OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES. WORKERS IN THESE
INDUSTRIES ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND IMMIGRANTS
WHO ARE ALREADY AMONG THE
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THESE WORKERS NEED
ASSURANCE THAT THEIR JOBS WILL
BE MADE AVAILABLE TO THEM IF
AND WHEN BUSINESSES REOPENED
AND THAT PANDEMIC RELATEDLY
ALSO NOT USED AS AN EXCUSE TO
ENGAGE IN PREJUDICIAL
UNWARRANTED TERMINATIONS. RIGHT
A RECALL AND RETENTION WILL
HELP TO ENSURE THAT LAID OFF
WORKERS WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY GETTING BACK THEIR
SAME JOB WAS SIR PLAYER BEGINS
WE HIRING IT IS TRULY A JOB
SAVER. THIS IS NOT ONLY
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT WORKERS
FROM DISCRIMINATION BUT IS ALSO
CRITICAL TO THE STATE'S COMIC
RECOVERY. THESE DISPLACED
WORKERS AUTHORED BECAUSE SOME
COMPLETELY BEYOND THEIR
CONTROL. NOT BECAUSE OF POOR
PERFORMANCE OR DISCIPLINE.
THESE WORKERS ARE NOT CREATE
THIS CRISIS THE TO BE ABLE TO
GO BACK THEIR JOBS IN THE
CRISIS IS ENDED AND BE PART OF
OUR STATE'S ECONOMIC. RECOVERY
NOW GOT THE MAP OF THE CAN BE
ABOUT OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO A
NUMBER OF THEM AND- WILL BE
CERTAIN AND HOPE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK- WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
BILL AS CONTINUES TO MOVE
FORWARD. I'VE GIVEN YES I BOTH.
THE TOP FIVE DO YOU HAVE FOX TO
CALL THE FEDERATION AND WE HAVE
TO WORK AGAIN LATER AS A RESULT
THIS TIME BECAUSE AS WELL. OUR
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
AND GIVEN THE TIME I WOULD LIKE
TO YIELD MY TIME TO THAT THE
WORKERS WHO ARE HERE TO TESTIFY
AND AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
AND THEN WE WILL GO TO. WE HAVE
TO WORKERS MICHELE- ZUMBACH
SAYS IT IS A COP. IN MONIQUE
RODRIGUEZ PLEASE. PLEASE
PROCEED PEOPLE BEGIN WHEN IT
GETS. MR KEREN MAY MY NAME IS
SACRIFICE NOT EASILY I AM.
THANK YOU THE. SPEAKING OF THE
PORT OF AB. THIRTY TWO. I WOULD
SERVER AT SHERATON SAN DIEGO
FOR THE FOUR YEARS
UNFORTUNATELY THAT CHANGE ON
JULY ONE TWENTY ONE I RECEIVED
A PHONE CALL FROM SEVENTY H. R.
STAND AS THAT COLD. MY JOB
AGAIN I ASKED WHAT WHAT MY
FORTY YEARS OF SONORA WHAT
CONSIDERED IN THERE DECISION TO
REHIRE AND AGAIN AND AGAIN THEY
R. MANAGER COULD ONLY TELL ME I
KNOW. AS YOU CAN THAT MADE ME
FEEL REALLY THE I HAD TO
DEDICATED THEIR- OF SERVICE TO
SHARED MIGHT BE I'D WHEN I NEED
A JOB THEM. PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC BY BEEN PLACED ON.
HOLD FOR OUR- IN BOTH MANY.
I'VE BEEN WAITING DOUBLE REPLY.
BUT DUE TO HOT. WHICH TO. FROM.
NINE CANCELING DELAYED.
ALTHOUGH MY THIRD WHICH WE-
SCHEDULED. NOW THAT THE CHURCH.
THEY ALL THAT IT THIS POINT JSL
THE CURRENT OF. A COKE DID NOT
GO. RIGHT YOUR THE ONE THEY
WORK LATE IN A POP. I AM A TOP
YOUR ON THE TIME. I'M OLD WOMAN
ON THAT LIST NIGHT WAS A ONLY
ONE GO ON WAY. THE NEXT LIST OF
THEIR ABLE. WORKERS SUCH AS
MYSELF AND PAUL CALLED OUR
RIGHT TO JOIN A YOUNG LAST YEAR
I WAS IN BY IN IT FOR OR GOOD
CAMPAIGN AT AND DIEGO. HOTEL
MANAGEMENT OUT ALL IN ORDER TO
BROWN. PREVENT US FROM
UNIONIZED. AND WE WIND IT FELT
LIKE ANSWER TO ALL OF OUR I
AFTER YEARS OF OLDER CHANGES
FINALLY LIKE WE WERE GOING HAVE
BROWN DROPS. WE HOPEFULLY AN
END TO YEARS OF BAD TREAT
TOWARDS BACK. TOWARDS THE HOUSE
YOU STAFF IN THE DISH. BEFORE
COLBERT NINE HERE WE WERE IN
PROCESS THAT NEGOTIATING THAT
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T BRIGHT NOT
ONE WORD AND ONE GET MY
BACKPACK. WE NEED A BEAT TWO
SIXTY BECAUSE AT MYSELF WHO
HAVE DEDICATED THEIR WHOLE
CAREER TO PLACES THE SHERATON
SAN DIEGO DESERVE THE CHANCE TO
BACK A JOB THEY LOCKED YOU KNOW
PAUL OF THEIR OWN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND MISS RODRIGUEZ
YOU WILL HAVE ONE MINUTE TO. OF
TIME AND I WILL ADD TO ABOUT
THIRTY SECONDS TO THE
OPPOSITION IS WEALTH TO GIVE
YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO. TO MAKE
YOUR COMMENTS THIS ORDER
BECAUSE. YES HI GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS MONA LISA RODRIGUEZ-
I WORK AT THE CARE NOW WE- IN
RANCHO. VERDES FORCING YEARS
BUT THE WHOLE AND I RUN A- THE
TURNOUT ISN'T LUXURY HOLD ON
BUDGET. THE WE- AND LOW IT
PRIDE. WILL DEPEND ON FORCED
THE HOTEL CLOSE. THE HOTEL PUT
ME ON. LAYOFF ARE OF NO. IN MAY.
THE IN FOR. AND MANY OF MY CALL.
THAT WE WERE. TERMINATED WITH
NO BRIGHT RETURN. TO THE HOTEL
WHEN IT WE OPEN. THE HOTEL.
GROWTH THAT BIG. THAT THEY-
WOULDN'T STOP PAINFUL MIKE YOU
SURE. COVERAGE A COUPLE OF
WEEKS LATER AFTER BASED. UP OF
THEIR. I. CARE OF MY KIDS AND
MY MOM I HAVE TO DECIDE BETWEEN
FOOD AND BRENT CRUDE AND
MEDICAL MEDICINE EVEN WORE IT.
UNEMPLOYMENT I NEED TO GO GET
FOOD FROM SALVATION ARMY.
CHURCH THIS RODRIGUEZ IF YOU
RIGHT IN THE- FROM SCHOOL SORRY
SO I WAS GOING TO SAY MS
RODRIGUEZ UNFAMILIAR TIME IS
ELAPSED AND- IS UP IF YOU'D
LIKE TO MAKE A JUST A FINAL
THOUGHT THAT WOULD BE
APPRECIATED. A CLOSING COMMENT
PLEASE TAKE. YES AND I LOVE MY
PUT PUT SO MUCH PUBLIC CARE IN.
TO PLEASE HELP THE THOUSANDS OF
WORKERS LIKE HE FIRED DURING A
GUN. BY SUPPORTING AB THREE TWO
ONE SIX THANK YOU MISS
RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU FOR JOINING
THE TELL YOU WHAT WITH THIS THE
WELCOME THANK YOU NOW WE WILL
GO TO WITNESSES IN A ROOM A
FORTY TWO OH THREE IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN. GOOD MORNING WELL. HEY
YEAH CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE HERE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT TEAM NO ONE WE WANNA GO
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE THERE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEN NO ONE WE
MOVED TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF AB THIRTY TWO SIX. THANK AND
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JAZZY GROW ON
THE HAPPENED YET THE W. WESTERN
STATE COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANKS WE
GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI JESSICA STENDER ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES AND THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA BOTH PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
WE GO TO LINE FIFTY SIX GONNA.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATT
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF UNITE HERE
WHO ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS AND
SPELL CLOSE THE TEAMSTERS A FEW
MACHINE AND THE U. W. A. IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU WITH ROTE. NEXT WE HAVE
HEARD IN THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHAT NUMBER NUMBER
EIGHTEEN YEAH YEAH THANK YOU
BUT I CANNOT STAND UP FOR YOU
FINALLY ADMITTING THEY BILL YOU
THINK YOU COULD RETIRE MORE
CONNECTIVITY THAT ANY ALLY HOME.
EARLY I DON'T I THINK I HAD A
BY THAT YOU LOOK AT THE VALUE
TIME THE IN ONLY IT WAS THAT HE-
IMPACT IN CONTRA THANK YOU IT
WAS THANK YOU VERY MUCH LOOKING
IN THE MIDDLE COMES UP ALREADY.
YOUR NAME AFFILIATE AND- YOUR
POSITION ON BILL'S THANK YOU
FOR MOVE ON MODERATOR. THANK
YOU WE GO TO LINE THIRTY FIVE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL I AM
THIRTY FIVE YEARS IS OPEN RIGHT
SENT TO BROWN BOOK ON OF CALICO
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ARE AND-
THANK YOU. NOW WE GOT TO LINE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT
ALL FROM THE HELP OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND THE COURT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NIGHTLINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS KEVIN
GIRLFRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION- CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. AN
EXTRA LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU RENE BARTOLI ARE YOU
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT. AN
ACCIDENTAL NINE ONE HUNDRED
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK
AND TRANSPORT. THANK YOU MY ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY OKAY BUT IT. HOWEVER
THE BANK WITHOUT MEANT. BUT
THAT THAT I NEVER THOUGHT OF
FUNDED BY LAW THEN THERE. I
WANT. TO GET. YOU NEED THAT
THANK YOU SIR I'M SORRY VIEW
ARE YOU IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR PLEASE MOVE ON THANK.
THANK YOU WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HE HARD ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA POINT
WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO BE ASIAN
BRONCOS SPONSORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ZERO YES RIGHT STRONG
SUPPORTER NAY BEETLE ONLY TWO
SIXTEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU IN OUR NEXT LINE IS
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JENNEKE AREA
YOU HAVE THE LEGAL AID AT WORK
WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT LINE IS ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR HOME
WITH WORKING PARTNERSHIPS USA
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU AN OUTLINE
ONE ZERO FIVE ONE HUNDRED FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATIE WATER
SMITH WITH THE CALIFORNIA WORK
AND FAMILY COLLECTION WE ARE
PROGRESS ON THERE'S AN ORANGE
PARK THANK YOU. WE NOW HAVE ONE
ONE HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BRANDING IN ASIA
EUROPE AND THE ASIA STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANNEX'S LINE
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE EIGHT FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ANOTHER LINE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PINE AMENITIES ARE GAME OR
TECHNOLOGIEN FAMILY CALIFORNIA
MEMBER OF LOCAL NINETY FOUR
LAST THIRTY YEARS AND I SUPPORT
BILL AB THREE TWO ONE SIX THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IN WITHOUT LINE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
SIX ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN CHRIS PATRICK RANDALL
THERE AND READ MISSILES YES
REPRESENTING THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE GO TO ONE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
SARAH PEARSON I'M A BARTENDER
AT CACHE CREEK CASINO AND A
MEMBER OF UNITE HERE LOCAL
FORTY NINE AND I AT THE BREAK
AB THREE TWO ONE SIX. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
KNOW BY NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. QUIDAM YOU'RE RIGHT
YOU'RE A MODERATE WE SUPPORT
OUR AB THREE TWO ONE SIX THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOW LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR ONE
THREE FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GO
AHEAD. OKAY MY NAME IS BERNICE
GUY- WITH UNITE HERE LOCAL
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY AND I AM IN
SUPPORT- A. B. THREE TWO ONE
SIX. THANK YOU ENOUGH LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS HEATHER
KENNISON AND I WOULD BE.
BANQUET BARTENDER CALLING
HUNTING AND I THE COURT. YOU
WANT THANK BECAUSE I WAS WANT
MY JOB BACK. THANK YOU. NEXT UP
WE HAVE LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE SEVEN TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE WILL MOVE TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN ONE ONE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS THERE ANY OTHER LEAD I WAS
LAID OFF FROM AN UNMARKED AT
THE CONVENTION CENTER I
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY THIRTY
TO SIXTEEN BECAUSE I NEED MY
JOB BACK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE HAVE LINE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
THAT MUCH ON OFFENSE AND WE DID
NOT FEEL WELCOME HE- ONE THANK
YOU FOR OF AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE HAVELINE ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU ONE EIGHT FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO
LINE FIFTY FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PINE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE'LL CONTINUE TO LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE ONE
SIX THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES I'M A PRODUCT ON LANDING
PASADENA. STRONGLY SUPPORTED-
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN WE DON'T
WANNA CHECK WE WANT OUR JOBS
BACK. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT LINE
OF LINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FORTY A. LINE IS
OPEN. WILL CONTINUE TO LINE
FORTY TWO FOUR TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME ONLY TO KEEP
US I'M CALLING- WITH UNITE HERE
LOCAL ELEVEN I'M A FORMER
RESTAURANT BY WORKER AT THE
HEIGHT IN LONG BEACH AND I AM
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
TWO. SIXTEEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT WE GO TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. LELAND
HEAD OF THE EIGHTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS SAN MATTEO LABOR
COUNSEL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU JULIE. THANKS WE HAVE
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS TO FIND OUT
pBEING A MOBILE HOME PARK ON
THE- BACK OF THE NOW WITH FIRED
I AM FROM SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
FOUR ONE THINKS BECAUSE I NEED
MY JOB BACK. IF YOU. WE GO NOW
TO ONE UNDER AND FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS CAN BE
LIMPING. I'M IN THE PORT OF.
EIGHTY THREE TWO ONE SIX I'M AT
HMS HOST NEXT YEAR ONE NINETEEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ENOUGH WE
NOW HAVE LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD MORNING- MY NAME IS SOME
OF THE MARTINUS FORMER
EMPLOYEE. ASSEMBLY TONE.
ALLOWED HIM HANDLING PASADENA
AND I'M VOTING ON AB THREE TWO
ONE SIX IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOUR JOB. AND THE
NEXT LINE IS ONE EIGHT NINE ONE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND YOUR CARD IN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
TWO SIXTEEN I THANK YOUNG.
THANK YOU ONE ONE HUNDRED AND
ONE ONE A ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE ONE ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE WILL CONTINUE TO LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY ONE NINE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SIMONE VIDEO I WORK FOR
THE LANGHAM HUNTINGTON I WAS
LAID OFF AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. THREE TWO ONE
SIX- I WOULD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MOVED. WE HAVE NINE ONE
NINE ONE. ONE NINETY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S KENNY
LEE A RISING AND THEN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FOR NEXT LINE IS ONE NINETY
THREE ONE NINE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TO TURN
MEMBERS ENJOY A ROBERT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS MILITARISM. WELL YES HELLO
WE HEAR YOU. ARE YOU IN SUPPORT
A. R. MY NAME AND I TRUST SO-
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
ASSEMBLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTEEN. THANK YOU DOLLAR TOOL
BOX. THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT AND WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME ACTUALLY GO
TO LINE ONE NINE EIGHT. ONE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHAT ONE NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I WILL CONTINUE TO
LINE TWO ZERO FOUR TWO ZERO FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO HUNDRED
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CONTINUE
TO LINE SEVENTY FOUR SEVEN FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVENTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALL
CONTINUING TO LINE TWO ZERO
SEVEN TWO HUNDRED SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE TWO ZERO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE ZERO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
VAN DEMANDING CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE HEAR YOU GO AHEAD. OKAY
MY NAME IS BRANDON AND DAN AND
I'M AN ESTHETICIAN AT THE
CLERMONT SPELMAN'S FONG I'M A
MEMBER OF LOCAL UNITE HERE
LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE NEXT THING HERE WE HAVE
LINE ONE THREE EIGHT ONE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
LEARN THIS FROM ABOUT AS AND I
WORKED AT THE ANIMATIONS OR
THANK YOU. I KNOW LINE ONE
TWELVE ONE ONE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE ONE TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WELL DONE OUTLINED
ONE EIGHTY ONE EIGHT ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND WE GET
FERNANDES UNITE HERE SILICON
VALLEY THIS TRUNK SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE ARE NOW
ONLINE TWO ZERO TWO TWO HUNDRED
AND TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
ZERO TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO LINE ONE SIX
EIGHT THREE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOME
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO INCLUDE A
PASSWORD DILLON. YEAH ONE SIX
THREE LINE IS OPEN ARE YOU IN
SUPPORT. OF THE- PLEASE MOVE ON.
LATER NEXT WE HAVE LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN ONE ONE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CHRIS SUPPORT UNITE
HERE LOCAL ELEVEN AND I AM
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU WE ARE NOW ONLINE
SEVENTY FIVE SEVEN FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BUT NOT LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN ONE
SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE ONE SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOR ME TO LINE SIXTY ONE
SIX ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK WE
WILL GO TO LINE FORTY EIGHT
FOUR EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PUT ME TO LINE FIFTY FIVE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIVE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
THANKS WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY
FOUR SEVEN FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE PROBLEM NINE SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. PROCEED
TO LINE NINETY THREE NINE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I REQUEST AND
NOW LIVES WILL BE THANKFUL FOR-
EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHTY SIXTEEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT HEADLINE TWO ONE FOUR TWO
ONE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS KEVIN OUT OF AND- I WAS
FIRED FROM THE LINE AND I'LL
TELL IN PASADENA. I SUPPORT AB.
THREE TWO ONE SIX BECAUSE I
NEED MY JOB BACK YOU CAN LOOK.
AND NOW LINE TWO ZERO TWO TWO
ZERO TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO
ZERO TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. CONTINUING TO LINE ONE
NINE EIGHT ONE HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE NINE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CONTINUING TO LINE FIFTY FIVE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT THIS
TIME IS THERE ANY FURTHER IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWO ONE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE DO
HAVE NINE TWO ONE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. STE HELLO. HELLO MEACHER
A- ARE YOU IN SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATION. PLEASE NOTE ONE
MODERATOR YOU CAN HEAR ME. IF
WE HEAR YOU YEAH I HAD I THINK
THE ONE. OKAY MY NAME IS OUT MY
NAME IS HELPFUL XCELLENT YEAH
I'M USED TO WORK FOR MONTAGE-
THAT WILL NOT REGION FOR MORE
KNOWLEDGE- MORE NATURAL BEACH-
ENDED UP GOING- JUST SUPPORT-
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTEEN. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
TESTIFYING TODAY. THE MOVING TO
LINE ONE EIGHT FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD
IS OPEN. CAN YOU MEAN TO LINE
ONE SEVEN TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SEVEN TO IT YES GO AHEAD.
AT THE DEATH FROM THERE EACH
SALINE DRIP THE SAMPLE OF
CONNIE STRONG SUPPORT. YEAH.
NEXT IN LINE TWO ZERO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
ROLANDO CASTELLON THE FORMER
EMPLOYEE OF THE LANGHAM
HUNTINGTON PASADENA I AM A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIRTY TWO
SIX. THANK YOU. NINE ONE ONE
TWO ONE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RECEIVE. ONE TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CONTINUING TO LINE ONE
SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE SEVEN
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOING ON
THE LINE FORTY EIGHT FOUR EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GETTING TO LINE TWO ZERO TWO
TWO ZERO TO REALIGN IS OPEN.
PEOPLE CALLING IN FOR THE BILL
WHAT IS. TWO ZERO TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'LL TELL PEOPLE. THANK
YOU ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PORTABILITY. WELL AND
OPENED LAST. ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN SHE- ASK EVERYONE TO
PLEASE YOU TELL HIM OR HER
PHONES UNTIL YOU ARE PROMPTED
BY THE MODERATOR AND THEN
PLEASE LISTEN TO YOUR THROUGH
YOUR PHONE NOT YOUR COMPUTER.
PLEASE GO AHEAD MODERATOR. YES
LINE TWO ONE FOUR YEAR OLD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES WE DO WELCOME.
OKAY MY NAME IS CHETNA ARAMBULA
I WAS FIRED MALANGA AND HI
SPEED UP I SUPPORT THIRTY TWO
ONE SIX BECAUSE I NEED YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. THE
WITNESS PLEASE. OUR NEXT LINE
IS TWO ONE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GALLAGHER HI MY NAME IS
ANGELICA I WORKING IN THE
MORNING REPORT HERE I AM
SUPPORT- THAT ABC THREE TWO ONE
SIX AND I NEED MY- WAR I GOT
BACK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHRISTENING
TIELINE TWO SEVENTEEN TWO ONE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO
ONE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD IT.
THANK YOU SEE IT YES. MY NAME
IS MATT HAUSER FINANCE ARAMBULA
IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE LOCAL
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY I'M STRONGLY
SUPPORT A. B. THIRTY TO SIXTY
THE CONVENIENCE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY AND I
JUST WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE TO
PLEASE LISTEN ON YOUR TELEPHONE
NOT ON THE COMPUTER THAT YOU'RE
WATCHING THIS BECAUSE YOU WILL
NOT HEAR IT IN A TIMELY MANNER
SO PLEASE LISTEN ON THE
TELEPHONE AND MODERATOR. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME MISTER ANYMORE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWO ONE
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. NINE ONE ONE TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE HEAR YOU
PLEASED BUT TESTIFIED. COLLEGES
LINE DROPS WE CONTINUE TO LINE
ONE EIGHT FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CONTINUE TO LINE SIXTY SIX THAT
IS SIX SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO VERY MAY YES WE DO. HELLO
YES PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER ROOM IN YOUR-
TO ALLOW RIVAL FOR FACE IN THE
AREA THESE WHY DO.
UNDERSTATEMENT ALLOW OTHER THAN
MET THE MULTIPLE BAY DOUBLE UP
WAY IF THE LEG YOU IN SUPPORT
OF ALMOST ALL OVER. A LITTLE
BIT BUT THEY GET THE MINUTE
MODERATOR PLEASE MOVE ON. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR THANK YOU WE GO TO
LINE SEVENTY FIVE SEVEN FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
PLEASE YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
HEAR YOU PLEASE TELL US YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND IGLESIAS I
WORK AT THE CLAREMONT HOTEL FOR
THIRTY YEARS- THE MEMBER OF A
LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
PLEASE. SUPPORT. THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT. THANKS WE
APPLY IT TO ZERO SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO ZERO SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WILL BE TEN NINE
ONE ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE ZERO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND MOVING TO LINE ONE EIGHT
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
WILLING TO CALIFORNIA STATE
DIRECTOR OF MISSIONAL ABLE TO
AND SUPPORTOF AB THREE TWO ONE
SIX THANK YOU FOR YOUR. THANK
YOU AN OUTLINE TWO ZERO FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWO ZERO
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ARE
MOVING ON- POLITY THERE'S KNOWN
FURTHER IN Q. DESERVE. PLEASE
SERVE AS ONE MORE TIME. IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE EARLY AND
YOUR IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWO
ONE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE GO TO
LINE TWO ZERO TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TWO ZERO TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WILL BE TO LINE SIXTY
ONE SIX ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIND SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BOEING TWO ONE TWO ZERO
SEVEN TWO ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE'RE GOING TO LINE
ONE TWELVE ONE ONE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ONE TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ORANGE LINE ONE EIGHT FOUR ONE
EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHEN A FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUILDING TIELINE TWO ZERO FOUR
TWO ZERO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TWO ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOING ON IF THERE ARE ANY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TWO ONE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT. WE GO TO LINE TWO
NINETEEN TWO ONE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. COULD NOT BE FOUND HERE
LOCAL ELEVEN BUT THAT IS ABOUT
THE SAME FOLKS ON THE LINE
THAT. ARE UNABLE- FROM THE
SPANISH BETWEEN THEN AND
FINANCIALLY BUT ALSO WORKERS-
AN ORANGE COUNTY WHO LOST THEIR
JOBS IN SUPPORT. OF THEIR ON
EVEN TRYING TO TRYING TO TURN.
IT ON THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANK
YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE SEVEN
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE SEVEN SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND AT THIS TIME
VERY GOOD THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO RECORD FROM THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS TO HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION THAT WE HAVE TODAY
AND I WE HAVE TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES AND EPIC.
EPIC CAL CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND JOHN CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
HOTEL AND LODGING ASSOCIATION
GENTLEMAN YOU WILL HAVE A FOUR
AND A HALF MINUTES TOTAL TIME
BETWEEN YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS BUT HAVING COME OUT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN.
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE AND YOU MISTER CHAIR
ON THE RECENT AMENDMENTS TO
NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
BUT WE STOP SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH THE WRITER RECALL
WORKER RETENTION PROVISIONS OF
THE STOCK. FIRST THE RECALL
PROVISIONS ARE SIMPLY
UNWORKABLE AND WILL SLOW DOWN
BUSINESS RE OPENING AND WORKERS
GETTING BACK TO WORK AT THE
WORST POSSIBLE TIME. AMONG
OTHER THINGS THE B. THIRTY TO
SIXTY REQUIRES COVERED
EMPLOYERS OFFER TO RECALL LAID
OFF WORKERS BY SENIORITY. IT TO
PROVIDES A COMPLETE TEN
BUSINESS DAYS TO RESPOND BEFORE
THEY CAN MOVE TO OFFER THE
POSITION TO THE NEXT MOST
SENIOR EMPLOYEE. THAT IS
COMPLETELY UNWORKABLE AND WOULD
TAKE WEEKS MONTHS OR YEARS FOR
THE EMPLOYER TO REOPEN.
DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF THE
BUSINESS. ARDLEY A POLICY THAT
SUPPORTS BUSINESSES RE OPENING
A WORKERS GETTING BACK TO WORK.
IN ADDITION AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN REQUIRES EMPLOYERS TO
OFFER POSITIONS NOT ONLY TO THE
EMPLOYEE WHO PREVIOUSLY HELD
THE POSITION. BUT TO ANY
EMPLOYEE WHO WAS QUOTE. IT IS
OR CAN BE QUALIFIED FOR THE JOB
WITH TREATING. THIS COULD
LITERALLY BE EVERY WORKER THIS
WILL ONLY SERVE TO BOG DOWN THE
PROCESS AND GROWING BUSINESS
THREE OPENING TO A HALT AT THE
WORST POSSIBLE TIME. SECOND
THESE BILLS. USE OF ONE PARTY
LIABILITY THAT WILL CRIPPLE
BUSINESSES. I JUST GOT THE BILL
DOUBLES AS A COMPLEX AND
UNWORKABLE REHIRE PROCESS. TO
MAKE MATTERS WORSE ANY
VIOLATION OF THAT COMPLEX
PROCESS. THIRD AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN RAISES SIGNIFICANT
LEGAL AND CONSTITUTIONAL
CONCERNS WE APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF THE ANALYSIS FROM
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
BUT WE DO THINK THERE ARE
SERIOUS CONTRACT CLAUSE ISSUES
RAISED WITH THIS PROPOSAL. WHEN
I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT. THAT
SOME EMPLOYERS HAVE LAID OFF
WORKERS IN PROVIDED SEVERANCE
PAYMENTS AS PART OF A SIGNED
AGREEMENT WITH THE EMPLOYEES.
THIS BILL IS NOTACKNOWLEDGE
THOSE CASES AND RAISES THE
POTENTIAL THAT THAT'S RIGHT TO
RECALL WOULD BE ARGUE TO
ABROGATE THE SEVERANCE
AGREEMENTS. WHICH IS ALSO A
VIOLATION OF THE CONTRACT
CLAUSE. FINALLY IN PARTICULAR
THE WORKER RETENTION ASPECT OF
THIS BILL IS NOT ANYTHING NEW.
AS PART OF A LONGSTANDING LABOR
PRIORITY. OF THE KNOWLEDGE IS
NOT SERVING NUMEROUS
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS AROUND.
OVER THE YEARS. MOST NOTABLY AB
THIRTY. THREE ARE YOU TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. AND THE LIST
OF COVERED INDUSTRIES IN THIS
BILL MAKES CLEAR TO US THAT
THIS PROPOSAL IS AIMED
PRIMARILY AT PRESERVING YOUR-
GOT IT. HI UNION. STREET. APRIL
QUIET IS THE CLASSROOM WHERE
TO. A MUCH OF WORK. THAT MAY BE
A POLICY TO COMMITTEE SO. BUT
IF SO WE THINK WOULD SHOULD BE
TRYING. ABOUT WHAT GOING ON.
FOR THESE REASONS WE- THE
THIRTY TWO. AND THAT'S FOR YOUR
NOTEBOOK THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS IN OFFICE. MITCHUM
MEMBERS CALLED ON BEHALF OF THE
HOTEL LODGING. TO LODGING IN IS
A SPECIAL HARD HIT THIS
PANDEMIC MORE THAN A THOUSAND
HOTELS HAVE CLOSED FOR SOME OR
ALL OF THE LAST FOUR MONTHS.
THOSE IN A REMAINED OPEN HAVE
OPERATED AT MAYBE 20% CAPACITY
AND THE RESULTS HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATING MORE THAN NINETY
THOUSAND HOTEL WORKERS HAVE
BEEN LAID OFF OR FURLOUGHED. OF
COURSE THESE HOTEL OWNERS STILL
HAVE TO PAY EXPENSES SUCH AS
MORTGAGES AND PROPERTY TAXES.
BUT TO ALL THIS THE INDUSTRY
HAS STEPPED UP. THOSE BETTER.
HAVE HOUSE. WORKERS LIKE POLICE
FIRE DOCTORS NURSES. THEY HAVE
INSTITUTED CLEANING PROTOCOLS
AND EXCEED CDC REQUIREMENTS AND
AT THEIR HOUSE THE HOMELESS
WITH OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND
HOTEL AND MOTEL ROOMS STATEWIDE
BEING MADE AVAILABLE FOR THAT
PURPOSE. EVERYONE WANTS THESE
HOTELS TO OPEN UP AND BRING
BACK THEIR EMPLOYEES. BUT AB
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN WILL MAKE WE
OPENING HOTELS COSTLY TIME
CONSUMING AND SUBJECT TO AN
ALREADY AND SUBJECT THEM TO-
THE- AND ALREADY SUFFERING
LODGING INDUSTRY. TO A SLEW OF
LAWSUITS. THE TIME MONEY SPENT
BY HOTELS TRYING TO COMPLY WITH
THIS WILL DELAY THE REHIRING OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO RETURN
TO WORK AGAIN THIS INDUSTRY IS
HURTING PLEASE VOTE NOW. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR TO CALDWELL
WE WILL NOW GO TO THIS
OPPOSITION WITNESSES THAT WOULD
WISH TO TESTIFY WITH THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL- ANYONE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SEEING NO ONE
LOOKING AT ROOM ONE TWELVE IS
THERE ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISHING TO SPEAK. NO ONE IS
THERE WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
THE TELECONFERENCE RIPPERS
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPTLY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AT
THIS TIME IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE WILL
GO TO NINE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS BILL GIBBONS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
LINE IS ONCE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING KATIE
CAMPAIGN WITH A CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NOW LINE
TWO TWO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR NUMBER IS NOT A QUITTER
BUT THE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION AND ALSO IN
OPPOSITION IN THE LINER COOPER
COMMENTATOR. THAT THE CHAMBER
THANK YOU YEAH. AND WE WENT OUT
TO LINE ONE SIX SIX ONE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
AT YOUR CARE NUMBERS CHECKING
SMELTZER ON BEHALF OF PRISM THE
PUBLIC RISK INNOVATION
SOLUTIONS AND MANAGEMENT IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. LEVINE
TO LINE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIND EIGHT EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION TO AB THREE TWO
ONE SIX. WHEN YOU'RE COMING TO
THE CHAMBER THANK YOU IF YOU.
THERE ANY FURTHER LINE UP IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN THREE TWO ONE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. BUT THIS TIME WE HAVE
KNOWN FOR THEIR QUEUING UP
THANK YOU MODERATOR APPRECIATE
THE GOOD WORK TODAY SO W'VE
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
MEMBERS AND I SEE SENATOR
JACKSON. HAS A QUESTION OR
COMMENT CENTER JACKSON. WE SEE
YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER CHAIR- I
AM A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL AND I DON'T.
PRINCIPALLY CO AUTHOR HOLD
WATER BILLS THIS IS. A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
HIS PASSIONATE COMMITMENT TO
OUR WORKERS- I WAS STRUCK BY
THE FACT THAT THE OPPOSITION
WAS ARTICULATE AND GLAMPING AND
I CLEARLY HEADED SAW. IDMS
DOWN- MANY OF WHICH I THINK ARE
SPACIOUS BUT NONETHELESS-
PERHAPS PERSUASIVE ALTHOUGH I
DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD BE. AND
I WAS STRUCK BY THE PEOPLE WHO
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT. THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE MANY OF THEM
IMMIGRANTS THEY DON'T SPEAK.
ENGLISH THEY'RE HARD WORKING
FOLKS MANY OF THEM HAVE WORKED
FOR YEARS FOR THESE VARIOUS
COMPANIES- THEY DO- BUILDING
MAINTENANCE AND SECURITY AND
MANY OF THEM ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY. THE WOMEN
IMMIGRANT AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND THIS DOES IS GIVE THEM
FIRST DIBS AT RETURNING TO
THEIR JOBS. THESE BUSINESSES
REOPEN AND SHOULD NEW
BUSINESSES ATTACK OVER IN THEIR
PLACE AND IF THE CHAMBER WISHES
US TO BE TRANSPARENT AND HONEST
LOOK HE SAID PART OF THE REASON
THEY'RE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL IS
BECAUSE THEY'D LIKE TO DO SOME
UNION BUSTING- AND- I THINK
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT
THE- REASON. THAT HAVE THIS
BILL. IN THE FIRST PLACE THESE
ARE PEOPLE WHO JUST SIMPLY WANT
THEIR OBS BACK THEY WEREN'T
FIRED BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T GOOD
AT THEIR JOBS THEY LOST THEIR
JOBS BECAUSE OF THIS PANDEMIC.
AND THEY WOULD LIKE TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE FIRST DIBS AND
GETTING THEIR JOBS. OUT WHEN
AND IF THESE COMPANIES DESPITE
TO REOPEN AND FRANKLY MOST OF
THEM WILL HAVE TEN DAYS OR MORE%
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO RAMP UP- TO BE ABLE TO.
COMPLY WITH EXISTING LAWS MAYBE
A NEW PROTOCOL CONTROL FOUR
CHARGE I FIND THOSE ARE. BE
LESS THAN COMPELLING. YOU KNOW
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT I THINK
THAT WE LOOK TO THE PEOPLE
BUSINESS CAN'T EXIST WITHOUT
THE PEOPLE WHO DO THE WORK AND-
IT'S REALLY- IT'S JUST NOT
ENOUGH TO OFFER UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE WE WANT CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE JOBLESS TO THE EXTENT
WERE ABLE TO GET BACK TO WORK
WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT AND I
BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT I WOULD DO
FOR A SIGNATURE SEGMENT THE-
NATION FRANKLY AND THIS. SOME
PIECES OF THE BILL HAS TAKEN ON
THE END OF BELIEVE UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY CHECKED. SURE
IS THE RESULT OF THIS CALL
PANDEMIC. WHERE PARENTS
SUPPOSED TO DO THE KIDS ARE
HOME I IN MANY INSTANCES
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE TO CARE FOR
THEM ARE THEY- WHAT DO WE DO
LET SIX YEAROLD STAY HOME
ALONE- BECAUSE PARENTS HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN A JOB AND CARING
FOR THEIR CHILDREN I THINK THIS
IS A- VERY POOR. CHOICE IN A
HOBSON'S CHOICE THAT. DOES NOT
SPEAK WELL ABOUT WHAT WE AS A
SOCIETY. HAVE DONE IN
PRIORITIZING WHAT'S IN LIFE.
THAT BEING SAID- THE- THE BILL
ALSO. I THINK IT REMOVES THE
EXTENDED REASONS FOR USING
LEAVE A JURY THE DAY TOMORROW
HE I ALSO WORK DID LEDGES. TO
EXPAND LEAVE DURING THE SCHOOL
CLOSURES ALSO FACED AN UPHILL
BATTLE AND FRANKLY I'M
CONCERNED THAT WE COULD AND-
LEGISLATORS. WILL PUT ANY. LATE
GOING WAS SCHOOL. STATE BURNING
I AM VERY SURE CHILD CARE
ISSUES THEY'RE REAL THIS IS NOT
GOING AWAY AND YET ARE THIS NO
DAY. WE SHOULD TAKE A PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO GET THEIR JOBS BACK-
INTERESTED TO ME IS SO CONTRARY
TO THE PRINCIPLES OF. A TRYING
TO GIVE EVERYBODY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED I'M I'VE
ALSO HEARD THE OPPOSITION SAY
THEY DON'T LIKE A PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION THIS IS BINDLE
STANDING A CHAMBER TALKING AND
I THINK IT'S HIGH TIME WE CALL
THIS THING OUT STRIP PRIVATE BY
OF ACTION IS ALSO DENYING FULL
ACCESS THE COURT BECAUSE
JUSTICE AWAY. COMMITTEE NOPE
RIGHT AT ALL AND I DON'T KNOW
YOU BUT I CERTAINLY DON'T
BELIEVE WE SHOULD BE ASKING
GOOD LEGEND TO LIST WE DON'T
GUARANTEE FAIRNESS AND JUSTICE
FOR THE PEOPLE SEEKING. OUR
PRESS FOR STATE. NOTION THAT
THEY'LL LOSE LAW MY RESPONSE IS
IF YOU FALL ALTHOUGH ARE YOU
NOT GOING TO GO SUED. I MEAN
LET'S FACE IT THIS JUST MY THAT
IS NEVER BEEN A DEMONSTRATED TO
BE ACT BUT IT'S A GOOD. POINT
IN IT'S ONE THAT SCARES PEOPLE
AND I'M I'M SO DISAPPOINTED
THAT WE DON'T CONSIDER THE FACT
THAT WHEN PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO ENFORCEMENT INTO
REMEDIES. AND THERE'S NO THAN
WORK OUR BASICALLY WORTHLESS
SO- ALSO NEED TO WORK TO POINT
TO IN THE IN OUR- FROM PAGE
SIX. IT TALKS ABOUT WHAT THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT- WOULD BE CALLED
UPON TO DO- IT PROVIDES THAT
REMEDIES FOR VIOLATIONS. OF THE-
COLLUDED FOLLOWING HIRING IN
REINSTATEMENT BECAUSE FRANKLY
THAT'S WHAT THESE GUYS WANT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SUE THEY
WANT TO GET BACK TO WORK AND
THEY ARE THE DATE ALSO CALLS
FOR SOME COMPENSATION FOR THOSE
DAYS THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO GET
BACK TO WORK THERE WERE NO
CRIMINAL IN THIS LEDGER. SOBER
UP IF THE EMPLOYEE HAS TO SUE
AND IS THE PROPELLING CARTAGE
BE TITLED WOULD TURN FEES.
RIGHT TOURNEY'S WON'T TAKE CASE.
IF EIGHT IF THEY'RE DOING A
PROBLEM. I IN THE CENTER OF
COURSE FROM FROM OUR CORPORATE
AMERICA'S WILL OR SHOULD WORK
FOR FREE BUT SHE ALSO THESE BIG
CORPORATIONS ONE BIG FAT
PAYCHECKS BUT THEY WANT THOSE
WHO ARE PROTECTING THE LITTLE
GUY. TO DO IT GO IN FIRST. A
THE THANKS LARGELY. THE SAN
SHOULD COMMITTEE WHICH I'M
HONORED TO SHARE I BILL IT'S-
UP IN PAGES NINE OF THE AND NOW.
I DON'T OR ANY ISSUES THAT ARE.
IF THEY DON'T LIKE. THE LAW OF
THE THING THAT THEY'RE SHOULD
BE VIOLATED THEY KNOW WHERE THE
CORE. ROOMS ARE THAT I WANT TO
WORK AT TO MOVE THE BILL I WANT
SEE IF WE COULD TO GIVE SIX
SERIOUS THOUGHT CAN. TO THOSE
WORKING. OUT THERE. GET THEIR.
BACK WHO ARE DESPERATE TO BE
ABLE TO PAY THEIR RAY AND SHE
THEIR TO. AND HELP THEM THAT
WILL BE A TO. FLOOR AND YOU
HAVE. AND SAFE AND THAT'S BUT
THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO DO ONE.
AREA OUR ECONOMY AND I IT MUCH.
AND WITH THAT- AGAIN WILL MOVE
THE BILL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FROM NIKE'S INTERJECTION OTHER
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THE CENTER PANEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A CENTER
KERR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND- IN EUROPE DURING
THIS COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
WERE STILL IN THE MIDDLE OF IT
YES MANY PEOPLE SUFFERING
BUSINESSES ARE SUFFERING
WORKERS ARE SUFFERING AND- I
APPRECIATE THAT THEY TALKED
ABOUT. NOW THAT THE OPPONENTS
TALKED ABOUT THE YOUNG THE
TRAVEL INDUSTRY KNOW THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY IS
SUFFERING GREATLY. AND SO ARE
ALL THE WORKERS AS WELL AND IF
WE REALLY APPROACH THIS IN A
SENSE OF THAT WE ALL NEED TO
PULL TOGETHER. I CERTAINLY HOPE
THE END OF THIS BILL AS PART OF
THIS IS THAT WE ALL NEED TO
WORKING TOGETHER THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN WORKING FOR YOU
SHOULD HELP GET THEIR JOBS BACK
IF YOU'RE ABLE TO OPEN. AND I'M
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT SO
THE SALUTE LET'S THINK ABOUT
HOW WHAT WE CAN DO TO MAINTAIN
AT LEAST SOME. MODICUM OF
STABILITY DURING A FAIRLY
CHAOTIC TIME WITH THIS PANDEMIC
AND PANDEMICS OR SIMPLY CHAOTIC.
I DO I THINK WE HAD SOME GOOD
DISCUSSION OF THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS- IT THERE ARE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL BUT
ALSO JUST TO CLARIFY THAT WHEN
YOU'RE CALLING PEOPLE BACK OF
COURSE THE JOBS THAT THEY ARE.
YOU KNOW QUALIFY FOR THE DAY
FUNDS SO THAT WE DON'T KNOW WE
DON'T WANT IT HOUSEKEEPER
TRYING TO BE AN ACCOUNTANT OR
ACCOUNT TRYING TO BE A SO. AND
I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE WORKING ON
SOME OF THOSE LANGUAGES-
REGARDING YOU KNOW TERMS OF
THIS BILL I UNDERSTAND JUST
LIMITED THE TIME OF KOVITZ
WHAT'S NINE. BY BUT IT'S A ALSO
THE OTHER PIECES THAT. YOU AND
I KNOW TALKED ALSO SURE THAT WE
WANT THE MECHANISMS TO REALLY
TRY TO GET THE WORKERS- YOU
KNOW BACK TO THEIR JOBS THAT
IS. THE SOONEST POSSIBLE WHEN
THOSE JOBS ARE AVAILABLE. SO
I'M NOT WHETHER TIED UP IN THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER AND THE
COURTS. NO I PERSONALLY- AND
MAYBE DIFFER FROM CENTER
JACKSON I'M YEAH HOUSE USUALLY
SOMEWHAT SKEPTICAL ABOUT TRYING
TO EXPAND RIDER REPORTS OF
ACTIONS. SO DO YOU FEEL WE NEED
TO A MECHANISM. THAT WOULD HELP
YES THE WORK BACK TO THE JOB AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE AND- YOU KNOW
THINGS ARE SORT OF BACKED UP IN
MANY DIFFERENT PLACES SO
WHATEVER WE CAN TRY TO DO BUT
THOSE MECHANISM THERE GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE WORKER AND
THE EMPLOYER TO WORK TOGETHER
TO GET RESPECT BY. TAKING FROM
THE- THERE REALLY TRULY
COMMITTED THIS IDEA OF RANGER
WORKERS. AND SO IT I REALLY
THANK YOU FOR DOING THE BILL
AND- APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN'S FIFTEEN NO OTHER COMMENTS
OF. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALLER. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN I
REALLY WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
THAT CALLED IN A LOT OF PEOPLE
A LOT OF WORKERS A LOT OF
WORKERS THAT ARE NOT WORKING
RIGHT NOW. BUT TOOK THE TIME TO
DO THAT- THIS BILL HAS COME A
LONG WAY AS WE FIRST LEARNED.
ABOUT THE EXCEL RIGHT IS PART
OF THE VIRUS YOU MEET SAW THE
TIME AND THE BILL AND ON OUR
ECONOMY BUSH'S WORK FOR
SOMEBODY NOT YEARS THAT ARE
EXISTING JOB PROTECTIONS ARE
INADEQUATE TO PROTECT PRESERVE
WORKERS WHO FACE COMMENTED A
CHALLENGES COMMON COLD INJURY
IS JUST WHAT WE ALL JUST GO
THROUGH- WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH.
TO PROTECT OUR WORKERS I WANT
TO THANK CENTER JACKSON FOR
YEARS THINKING ABOUT FAMILIES
NOW WE CAN PROTECT AND CARE FOR
OUR FAMILIES NOT JUST DURING
THIS CALL THE CRISIS BUT IN
GENERAL WE DON'T DO ENOUGH
ISSUES RECOGNIZE THAT AND AGAIN
TODAY. FURTHERMORE AND I PUT
THAT. WE KNEW IT THE CURRENT
LAW A NOTE. FOR THE NAY PROTECT.
NEEDED TO COME BACK DEPEND
ECONOMIC AND WORKPLACE IMPACTS.
OUR APPROACHES ONE TO ENSURE
THAT WE DID NOT HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO RETURN TO THE
LEGISLATURE. TO PUT IN PLACE
UNIFORMED DESPERATE JOB
PROTECTIONS. THIS BILL STARTED
OUT AS A CODE NINETEEN LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT RESPONSE BILL.
WAS CRAFTED TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF WORKING FAMILIES WHICH
INCLUDED JOB TO LEAVE. TO
ADDRESS SPECIFIC CARE ISSUES
ARISING FROM PANDEMIC. PAID
SICK LEAVE TO ALLOW WORKERS
CONTRACTED OVER TO STAY HOME.
AND RELAXING MEDICAL SERVICE
CERTIFICATION. WE TO PROCURE ON
TO CIRCUMSTANCES. WORKERS FACE.
IT TOO HAS CAST ITS TOLL UPON
THIS BILL ALONG THE WAY IT HAD
TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT CONCESSIONS
TO ASSURE PASSAGE INTO THE BILL
HEARD ALL OF THESE PROVISIONS
BY THAT I JUST MENTIONED AND
CUT FROM THIS BILL AND I. JOIN
IN AND DOES CENTER JACKSON'S
DISAPPOINTMENT IN THAT FACT. WE
HAVE TO ACT ON WHAT IS IN THE
BILL TODAY WHICH WILL GO A LONG
WAY TO ENSURING THAT WORKERS
CAN RETURN TO WORK SEAMLESSLY
WITHOUT ANY HESITATION. AND YOU
KNOW TO THE TO THE OF
PROPOSITIONS POINTS IF I COULD
IS A TRUST THOSE. I AM
COMMITTED TO AMENDING THE BILL
TO ALLOW FOR SIMULTANEOUS
CONDITIONAL OFFERS WHICH ALLOW
EMPLOYERS TO EXTEND OFFERS TO
MULTIPLE EMPLOYEES THE SAME
TIME. THAT'LL HELP GET WORKERS
BACK. TO WORK AS WELL AS ALLOW
THESE BUSINESSES REOPEN MORE
QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY. TO THE
COMMENT FROM THE CHAMBER ABOUT
THIS JUST ABOUT PROTECTING
UNION JOBS YOU KNOW THE REALITY
IS I SAID THIS BILLS ALWAYS
ABOUT WORK PROTECTIONS
RESPONSE-GOVERNORS EIGHTEEN WE
HAD ON PAID LEAVE PROTECTIONS
WE HAD BASICALLY BEEN THE BILL
FROM DAY ONE THE CHAMBER TO
OPPOSE EVERY SINGLE PROVISION
NOW THAT THIS IS ALL THAT WE
HAVE OF BOB LET US BE
TRANSPARENT I WAS REALLY GOING
ON HERE AND THAT IS THE CHAMBER
DOES WANT ANY ASPECT OF THIS
BILL AND NEVER HAS. AND NOW
THAT WE DO HAVE THIS ONE
REMAINING ITEM OF I TO RECALL
AND WRITE A RETENTION LEFT
THEY'RE NOW SAYING IT'S A BILL
TO PROTECT UNION ALTHOUGH THESE
PROVISIONS APPLY TO ALL WORKERS
NOT JUST THOSE WHO ARE
REPRESENTED BY A UNION BUT
AGAIN I THINK LET'S BE CLEAR
ABOUT HOW WE GOT HERE. AND
WHAT'S HAPPENED A ALONG THE
WAY- AND YOU KNOW THE WRITER
RECALL RIGHT A RETENTION IS
NOTHING NEW SANTA MONICA BY
RETENTION LOS TWO THOUSAND ONE
THAT IT'S INSPIRED BY RETENTION
A LOT FROM DC IN THE NINETIES
LA A LONG BEACH A PASSABLE
ORDINANCES WELL- FIFTEEN THE
LEADERSHIP. OF A DISTINGUISHED
JOINT AUTHORS THIS BILL.
ASSEMBLY GONZALEZ FLETCHER
PASSWORD RETENTION OFFER
GROCERY WORKERS WHICH IS NEARLY%
IDENTICAL TO THE RECORD
RETENTION PROVISIONS IN THIS
BILL. SO THE LAW WILL SURVIVE
THE GO CHALLENGE. ARGUING THAT
THERE'S A VIOLATION THE
CONTRAST BECAUSE- IF THE IF THE
STATE HAS A SIGNIFICANT
LEGITIMATE PURPOSE BEHIND A LOT
WHICH WE DO. WHICH IS REMEDYING
ABROAD AND GENERAL SOCIAL
ECONOMIC PROBLEMS SO IN OTHER
WORDS THE COURTS WILL DIFFER.
FROM LEGISLATIVE JUDGMENT IF
THERE'S A RATIONAL BASIS FOR
ECONOMIC OR SOCIAL REGULATION
AND THIS CASE IS NO QUESTIONS A
RATIONAL BASIS. FOR THESE
WORKER PROTECTIONS. AND FINALLY
ON THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
ON THAT ISSUE IT IS AN ACCESS
TO JUSTICE ISSUE. FOR US TO
GIVE SOMEONE A RIGHT AND NOT
ALLOW THEM TO ENFORCE IT IS
TANTAMOUNT TO GETTING NO RIGHT
AT ALL. THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF WORKERS WILL
BENEFIT MAYBE THIRTY TO SIXTEEN
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS
WOMEN AND LOW WAGE WORKERS.
REMOVING THE BY RIGHT OF ACTION
POTENTIALLY SYSTEMS AND
INSTITUTIONS. THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY
DISADVANTAGES FOLKS. FOR THE
MORE LIVING ENFORCEABLE
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE WOULD BE
UNBEARABLE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE IS
BACKLOADED. WAGE CLAIMS. AS WE
WAGE CLAIM FROM THE FILING TO
HEARING IS TO HUNDRED AND
NINETY. DAYS WORKERS NEED
ACCESS TO JUST. AND THAT'S WHAT.
ONE THE PRIVATE I WRITE ABOUT
LIMITED. BECAUSE THEY KNOW WE
DON'T KNOW THE WITHOUT A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION THE
ABILITY OF WORKERS TO ENFORCE.
THEIR RIGHTS IS IN REALITY NON
EXISTENT. AND SO YOU KNOW
PLEASE KNOW THAT I'M WITH
BERMAN COMMITTED ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH IN THE
PAST. POSSIBLE WAYS TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS THAT STILL PROTECT
WORKERS AT A DOCTOR PUMPED THE-
CONCERNS. OF THE PAST INSTANCE
EARNS REGARDING THE DEFINITION
JOHN HAWKINS ON WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THAT AS
WELL OUR ECONOMY CANNOT RECOVER
WITHOUT ITS WORKERS ARE ITS
LIFEBLOOD LISTEN TO THE PEOPLE
CLOSEST TO THE PAIN TO
DETERMINE THE SOLUTION THAT
BEST BELIEVES THAT PAIN. WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA- AS YOU KNOW I'VE
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL AND
SPECIFICALLY THE PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION PART HEARD COMMENTS
ABOUT IT AND I STILL BELIEVE-THAT THE ENFORCEMENT BY THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT IS IN WOULD BE
SUFFICIENT. I DO THINK THIS
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION AND
THIS PARTICULAR CASE OPENS THE
DOOR TO THE UNNECESSARY LIVING
CAN ABUSE FOR THAT REASON I
WILL BE VOTE. ON THIS BILL
TODAY. FROM JACKSON. OF PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS PLEASED
ON YOUR MY SONORA CAST VOTE
CENTER HILL NO SENATOR HILL NO
SENATOR MORALE. SENATOR JACKSON
JACKSON HI SENATOR JACKSON HI
SENATOR MITCHELL MITCHELL ALL
RIGHT SENATOR MITCHELL HI
CENTER PAM HI CENTER PAN HI. I
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL ON CALL
FOR THE ACTION MEMBER AND-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH KALRA SURE
IS IT. MISTER COOPER WE HAVE
ABOUT FIFTEEN MINUTES DRIVING
BEFORE COCKETTES STARCH BUT WE
WILL TAKE YOUR BILL TO
CONCLUSION- AND APPRECIATE YOUR
BEING HERE TODAY AND HOPEFULLY
WE CAN GET THROUGH IT IN A
TIMELY MANNER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE V.
ITEM THREE I'M SORRY BE SIX
SIXTY FOUR. PLEASE FOR STEVEN
CHOI COOPER FRAZIER THE TEARS
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH ME TO
HAVE THIS BILL SB SIX SIX FORCE
CRAFTED TO ADDRESS THE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS THAT COVER
NINETEENTH. AT SEVEN OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS. FIREFIGHTERS
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND PEACE
OFFICERS. LITERALLY THOUSANDS
THESE FIRST RESPONDERS HAVE
BEEN AFFECTED IN QUARANTINE DO
THIS PANDEMIC AND SADLY MANY OF
LOS OUR LIFE'S. PROFESSIONAL
PUBLIC SERVANTS ARE DIFFERENT.
THEY'VE ALL TAKEN PROFESSIONAL
AND LEGALS THAT NOT ONLY
REQUIRE THEM TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE. DURING A CRISIS. BOB
PRICE COULD GIVE ME LIKE THIS
REPLY TO IT AND DANGER AND OR-
TO FACE IT HEAD ON. THEIR PLACE
IN THE CITY. THERE WAS THE
REQUIRED TO ENFORCE STAY IN
PLACE. BUSINESS SHUTDOWNS IN
OVERRUN WORKPLACES WITH
HUNDREDS OF AFFECTED PATIENTS.
THEY DO SO WILLINGLY EVEN AT
THE RISK OF THEIR OWN PERSONAL
SAFETY. THEY'RE ALSO DIFFERENT
BECAUSE DURING A CRISIS OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS DON'T GET TO
CHOOSE THEIR ASSIGNMENTS. THE
STAFFING SHORTAGES DUE TO
INJURY INFECTION STORE
EMPLOYEES ARE MOVED AROUND WHAT
DATA DESK THE NEXT IN THE FIELD
OR IN THE ICU FACING THE DANGER
HEAD ON. AND THEN WE SERGEANTS
AT THE PRE WORK FORCE CAN
SIMPLY JUST BE REPLACED IT
TAKES MONTHS AND EVEN YEARS OF
TRAINING AND EVALUATION TO GET
RESOURCES PARTNERS CAN LEGALLY
SERVE. BENEFITS ARE COMMON BUT
NOT RARE MAY HAPPEN AGAIN AND
WE MUST TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO NOT ONLY PROTECT OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS BUT NOW TO PREPARE
FOR THE FUTURE PROTECT PROTECT
THOSE CALLED TO SERVE. SB SIX
SIX FOR A SPECIFIC NARAL TO
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE IN WHICH A
STATE OF EMERGENCY IS DECLARED
IN CALIFORNIA. PLEASE ENTER.
WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS WILL BE
IN PLACE BEFORE NOT AFTER THE
CRISIS HITS OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS. AB SIX SIX FOUR BY
THE LEGISLATURE A CHANCE TO
CRAFT POLICY TODAY FOR THE
FUTURE THAT WHAT IS TO
EMERGENCY IS DECLARED. THEY
ILL HAVE A SAY A PROTECTING
OUR HEALTH CARE WORKERS
FIREFIGHTERS AND POLICE
OFFICERS. THE CRISIS BEFORE US
NOW THAT WE MUST DO MORE TODAY
TO ADDRESS FUTURE PANDEMICS
WERE NOT CAUGHT OFF GUARD
AGAIN. HI MY STAFF CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF ON ANY
CLARIFICATIONS THE FOR THE
PROPOSED. THIS BILL TODAY I
HAVE BRIAN WRITES PRESIDENT THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS THE SHIPPING
CONTAINER JACKSON THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU CAN REMEMBER COOPER
REGISTRATION PLEASE PROCEED
WELCOME. WELCOME AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BRIAN RICE
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
SIX SIX FOUR I LIKE TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LEANING ON SUCH
IMPORTANT ISSUES NOT ONLY TO
CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS BUT ALL
FRONT LINE WORKERS DURING THE
PAST TO MAKE. ALSO I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR WHO
KNOWS FIRSTHAND THE DANGERS
THAT ARE MEMBERS BASED ON THE
JOB AND FOR WORKING SO CLOSELY
WITH US SB SIX SIX FOUR WILL
CREATE A REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION
FOR KOBE NINETEEN AND OTHER
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE BRING OUR
BY WANT PORTION OFFICERS AND
OTHER HEALTH WORKERS. CRITICAL
POINT PROFESSIONALS ARE AT
GREAT RATES. OF EXPOSURE TO THE
DEADLY CORONA. CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THE SPENDING MAKE
PROVIDING LIFESAVING MEDICAL
CARE AND TRANSPORTATION. OF
CALIFORNIA'S SICKEST AND MOST
VULNERABLE PATIENTS IN A VERY
UNPREDICTABLE ENVIRONMENT. IN
THIS BATTLE THE MEN AND WOMEN
IN THE FIRE SERVICE WORK HAND
IN HAND. WITH OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS ON THE FRONTLINE- AS
FRONTLINE HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
LIKE OUR FIREFIGHTERS ARE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS CONFRONT A
DANGER. THAT MOST OF US RUN
FROM. THE END FIREFIGHTERS AND
DOCTORS AND- WORKERS ARE
EXPOSURES ARE VERY UNIQUE.
GAINES AND DIFFERENT IN THAT
HIGHER HERE'S- THE- FIELD AND A
LOT OF UNKNOWNS. AND ARE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS IN THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM WORK WITH
PEOPLE CONTINUOUSLY IN THAT
DOES. GET PAID WHEN THEY GO OUT.
WHAT IN THERE IN THE TRENCHES
FIGHTING FOR OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS FIREFIGHTERS WHEN THEY
GET COLD AND FIGHT FOR THEIR
LIVES. HUNDREDS OF CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS AND TESTED
POSITIVE. MANY BEEN
HOSPITALIZED RECENTLY
TRAGICALLY WE LOST OUR BROTHER
FIREFIGHTER PARAMEDIC CLOSING.
CREDITS LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT
BECAUSE THEY DIED OF BUT BUT
NOW. IS WAS THE JOB RELATED MY
TO DO DEATH. MA'AM IN THE FIRE
SERVICE ALONG WITH A FRONT LINE
WORKERS NEED PROTECTION OF THE
WORK COMP AND PER. FOR DISEASE
THAT THEY ARE EXPOSED TO DAILY
THROUGH THEIR WORK. WITH THIS
COURT WITHOUT THE SCORE
PROTECTION FAMILY FACE THE
TERRIFYING PROSPECT OF LOSING A
LOVED ONE TO THE DISEASE. AND
THE ADDED BURDEN OF BEING LEFT
WITHOUT THE ONE THAT SUPPORTS
THEM WHETHER IT'S A
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE OR GLOBAL
PANDEMIC FRONTLINE PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND HEALTH CARE WORKERS
SUIT UP AND WE SHOW UP WE OWE
IT TO THESE MEN AND WOMEN. BUT
THE FRONT LINE TO PROTECT THEM
FOR THE DANGERS- BUT BASIC BIG
BASS PROTECTING ALL OF US IF
CALIFORNIANS. YEAH AND- I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. MY TESTIMONY
WITH URGING YOUR SUPPORT. FOR
EIGHTY SIX SIX FOUR AND I WILL
CLOSE MY TESTIMONY. IN MEMORY
OF LOS ANGELES FIRE DEPARTMENT
FIREFIGHTER JOSE PEREZ. IS
WHITE AND THREE CHILDREN WHO
DIED ON JULY TWENTY FIFTH FROM
KOBE NINETEEN CONTRACT ABOUT
THE JOB AND WHO WILL BE LAID TO
REST IN BERRY- ON SATURDAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS YOU
HAVE ONE MINUTE EIGHT SECONDS
REMAINING. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
AND WITH THE IN A WE ARE COUPON
THE MAYBE SIX SIX FOUR FROM THE
END FIRST RESPONDERS NEED A
WORKERS COMPENSATION
PRESUMPTION OF GOLDEN NINETEEN
CALIFORNIA. YEAH YOU. GOOD NEWS
CHECK YESTERDAY ALL APARTMENTS
HAVE REPORTED TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR CONFIRMED POSITIVE
NINETEEN HE SAID THAT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN DEATHS
STATEWIDE FOR THE NINETEEN OF
THE GLOBAL HEALTH CRISIS BUT IT
IS ALSO A DALY AND PERSONAL
TRAGEDY FOR FRONT LINE WORKERS
ALMOST THE WORLD CHILDREN CAN
PLAY FIRST RESPONDERS ARE
ENTERING THE FRONT LINE PUTTING
THEMSELVES IN HARM'S WAY TO
CARE FOR THE DAY THEY DESERVE
BASIC. PROTECTION AND SECURITY
NOW. AB FOUR THE VITAL EVERY
DAY ARE GETTING INTO ACTIVE
FIGHT WORKERS IN THE AND HEALTH
PARTNERS. EMPLOYERS ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO LOWER
THEIR LIABILITY EVEN WANT TO
PROTECT THEIR WORKERS IN MORTAL
DANGER. EMPLOYERS ARE ACTIVELY
ENCOURAGING OUR NURSES COULD
NOT APPLY FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND COMING UP WITH
THE MOST ELABORATE REASONS
CANNOT PROVIDE BASIC BENEFIT
THEY ARE ENTITLED TO. WE NOT
GONNA HAVE THE BABY TO PROTECT
OUR FRONT LINE WORKERS WHO RUN
TOWARDS DANGER EVERY DAY RATHER
THAN AWAY FROM IT. THE WORKERS
COVERED UNDER THIS BILL ARE
MEETING THE DAILY CHALLENGES AT
PANDEMIC BUT THEY CANNOT DO IT
ALONE FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON A. EXPORT TO THAT THANK YOU
MR ACTION WE WILL NOW GO TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WHO ARE
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE SEE
NO ONE WILL MOVE TO. ROOM ONE
TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE THAT NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TAKE.
SIXTY FOUR WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE THOSE DIVISIONAL. MEETING
THE FIVE BE THE TELE. SERVICE
MODERATE WOULD YOU BE PROPERTY
INDIVIDUAL WAITING TO FIND SOME.
OF AB SIX SIXTY FOUR PLEASE.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. FIRST WE WILL GO
TO NINE ONE SIX SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU MISTER SURE MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IN SPORTS THANK YOU. AN
EXCELLENT LINE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEIR NUMBERS
DADDY GREAT WELL IF YOU HAD TO
BE W. WESTERN STATE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A
LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS NOW
BROUGHT ON THE AFTER THE
TEAMSTERS AND ENGINEERS AND
SCIENTISTS OF CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU TO ROADS. BUT I PLAN TO
THIRTY EIGHT TO CREATE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
AFRIKA VARGAS AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FIREFIGHTERS
ASSOCIATION SIXTEEN THOUSAND
FIREFIGHTERS STRONG BOTH CAREER
AND VOLUNTEER A CO SPONSOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALLIED ONE
FOUR NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU RENEE BAYARDO WITH AS
YOU ARE YOU CALIFORNIANS
TRANSPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SEVEN ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER TRIMMERS PATRICK
GRANDPARENT READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AN ALLIED
TWO FOUR FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS JOE LEVEL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION LOS
MEMBERS OF THE NINETEEN ONE
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY FOUR
THANK YOU MISTER LEVEL. TIELINE
TWO FOUR SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REALLY A GREAT THING WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
FOUR ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
CAN MEMBERS MATTHEW SO I RULING
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE
ASSOCIATION THE LOS ANGELES
DEPUTY SHERIFFS AND THE LOS
ANGELES PROBATION OFFICER UNION
ASKING LOCAL SIXTY FIVE ALL IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE
TWO FOUR ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
ERIN READ REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROLMEN CAL. TO EIGHT
EIGHT ONE AND PORAC ALL PROUD
TO BE CO SPONSORS YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER REED. HELLO TO
THE SIX PLEASE CALL. TWO THREE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AT THIS
TIME IS THERE ANY FURTHER LINES
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX SIX FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WELL TRIED LINE TWO
THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
AM VERY I YES MY NAME IS DOCTOR
CABALLOS- AT UCLA AND A MEMBER
OF THE ESSAY YOU CAN EVEN TURN
OF EVENTS THAT WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH OUR NURSES ARE THAT ARE-
OF COURSE IN THE PORT. OF THIS
BILL IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
WORKERS COMPENSATION DAHLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AFTER
NUMBER LOG DURING RIDLEY PENNED.
THANK IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX SIX FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE KNOWN FOR
THE QUEUING UP VERY GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES STRAIGHT
LINE BORDERS CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES IN THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. AND RONNIE BIRD TO
GO CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION- MISFORTUNES PLEASE.
YOUR FOUR MINUTES TOTAL BETWEEN
YOU. THANK YOU I THINK FORGET
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY BUT SINCERE AFFECT
THE AUTHORITY AND SUBJECT
MATTER WE ARE CLOSE TO EIGHTY
SIX SIXTY FOUR WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR THE SUBSTANTIVE
CONVERSATIONS THAT EVAN HAD
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE TO
DATE WE APPRECIATE THE
REQUIREMENTS BY THAT BUT
PRODUCTION WOULD BE REBUTTABLE
HOWEVER ALL PRESUMPTION EVEN
ABOUT OF ALL ESTABLISH AND
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE BAR FOR
EMPLOYERS TO CREATE A NEGATIVE.
THAT ELEMENT IS NOT WORK
RELATED THE JAVA AND OTHERS
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT
COMMITTEE CHAIRS AND CONSULTANT
BUT HE'S AN ATTORNEY AND A
BROAD RANGE OF STAKEHOLDERS FOR
MONTHS SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE AS
A COMPREHENSIVE VEHICLE THE HOW
TO FIND THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND ADDRESS
LIMITED ONGOING. CORRECT
PRESUMPTION. IN FACT THREE DOES
IT WE HAVE WORKED INCLUDE.
LANGUAGE FOR CODING PRESENTS.
THE COVERAGE CLASSIC THAT THANK
YOUNG. THAT HAVE WORK COMP AND
THEY FOR THAT. QUALITY HERE IT.
THAT DEALT WITH THE BY THE
COMMITTEE BACK IN MAY. THEY
SELL SIGNIFICANTLY COMPLICATE
AND NUMBER COMPLEX ISSUE WHAT
KIND. THE STORY AND COULD
EFFORT. BY PROPOSED FURTHER
BENNETT THAT FAR EXCEED THE
NORMAL OF WORK COMPANY DOES.
RATHER EXPENSIVE BILL HOW AN
URGENT CRIED WE NOT BELIEVE
THAT THAT THAT THAT IS A QUICK
MEET THE DEMAND OF NOT
STATUTORY AND- LIKE HOUSING AND
KEEPING RECORDS REMEMBER AND
MATTER OF. L. A. THE ONLY TO
JERRY THAT PUBLIC HEALTH AND I
THE IMPORT TRUTH. ABOUT
SITUATION AND THAT IS ALL THAT
WHEN ARE SCARCE AND DEMAND HI
WE ENCOURAGE DIAZ A CAN THE
OTHER FORMS THE CO THAT THANK
LEAVE AND THEN IT THAT ARE WILL
PROVIDE BY AND- INSIDE OUTSIDE
THE WORKERS COMP AND BUT THAT.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PERSON EXPANDED FUNCTIONAL
AVAIL FOR THE WHO NEED IT. YOU
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUING
IMPORTANT CONVERSELY ON AND
PROCEDURE IN FOR COCA. BUT
OPPOSED AB SIXTY FOUR AT THE
TIME. THANK YOU. GOOD THANK THE
WEEK PLEASE AND THEN- WE WILL
HAVE TO RESEARCH UNFORTUNATELY
BEFORE WE FINISH THIS.
RETICULAR ITEM I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT BUT PREDICT WITNESS PLEASE
YOU HAVE A. WE HAVE ABOUT TWO
MINUTES LEFT. THANK YOU AND
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- RIDER TO GO HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION. FOR SMALL
ONE ECHO MANY THE COMMENTS MADE
BY MY COLLEAGUE CREEK FORGES.
LANE AND HER TESTIMONY. AS WE
SHARE MANY OF THOSE CONCERNS-
NOW ON THE APPLE MORE THAN. THE
FOUR HUNDRED HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA MUCH OF THE SITES
THAT PATIENT AND WORKER SAFETY.
IS OUR TOP PRIORITY- WHICH IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE. IN THIS
PANDEMIC. IN THIS HOSPITAL HAVE
ALREADY BEEN ACCEPTING WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS. FOR
INJURIES RELATED TO A COLD A
POSITIVE DIAGNOSIS. IN ADDITION
TO PROVIDING A HOST OF OTHER
BENEFITS EMPLOYEES TO SUPPORT
THEM. CARING FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS. FOR THE
MORE HOSPITALS ARE UNIQUELY
AWARE OF JUST HOW
UNPRECEDENTED. DISCOVER
NINETEEN HAD DEMOCRATS AND-
THEREFORE WE RECOGNIZED THE
UNPRECEDENTED STEP THE GOVERNOR
TOOK BACK IN MARCH. YOUR
EXECUTIVE. ORDER TO PROVIDE A
TIME LIMITED. COVEK SPECIFIC.
PRODUCTION FOR ANY WORKER WHO
HAD TO REPORT FOR WORK DURING
THE STATE WIDE STAY AT HOME
ORDER. WE APPRECIATE THE
OUTSIDE OF THE EFFORTS OF THE
AUTHOR TO ADDRESS SOME OF OUR
ISSUE- BUT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS ON THE FOLLOWING.
NUMBER ONE GET THE CLEAR THE
INTENT TO PAY FOR HOUSING
LIVING EXPENSES AND PAY
QUARANTINE LEAVE. IN THE EVENT
OF AN EXPOSURE WHICH WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION OF THE
SYSTEM AND IT REMAINED UNCLEAR
AND WHO WILL PAY OUR HELLO B.
B. B. PAY FOR. CLEANING CONCERN
THAT THIS WILL BE BORNE
SQUARELY BY THE EMPLOYER. CAN
TO INCREASE THE PRISM IMPROPER.
AND BIANCA BIDDING ANY. TO THAT
IS THE SUBJECT OF THE STATE OF.
WHICH DOESN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
pAVAILABILITY OF VACCINATION AND
OTHER PROTOCOLS THAT CAN BE
TAKEN TO PROTECT WORKERS.
NUMBER THREE THE HOSPITAL
ALREADY REQUIRED TO PROVIDE P.
PETER ITS WORKERS. ET
CONFLICTING REQUIREMENTS TO
REIMBURSE EMPLOYEES FOR THEIR
OWN PP. OR ITEM ANCILLARY TO PP
WHICH MAY NOT MEET OUR
INSPECTION CONTROL STANDARD.
WHAT FINALLY IT PROVIDE. THE
PRESUMPTION FOR DIRECT PATIENT
CARE EMPLOYEES AND IN THE CARE
HOW. EVEN A HOSPITAL NOT
TREATING ANY COVER OR OF THE
STATE IS NOT INTERACTING WITH
CO THAT PATIENT ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE PER OF PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
HOSPITALS SMALL AND LARGE ARE
SELF INSURED FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION WHICH MEANS THESE
COSTS WILL HAVE A DIRECT AND
IMMEDIATE IMPACT ON PATIENT
CARE. TO BE CLEAR. WE SUPPORT
EFFORT INTO. BUYING TO MAKE
SURE OUR WORK FORCE AND THEIR
FAMILIES SEVERAL BUS ACCESS TO
CARE INCLUDING CLINGS TO THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM.
WHILE WE WERE WE WHILE WE
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL- WE
DO LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND ADDRESSING.
OUR ONGOING CONCERNS SHOULD THE
BILL MAKE IT OUT OF COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE WILL
UNFORTUNATELY BE RECESSING- AND
WILL RECONVENE- AS SOON AS THE-
CAUCUS IS COMPLETE. AND WE WILL
THEN HEAR FROM THE OTHER
OPPOSITION WITNESSES TO EIGHTY
SIX SIXTY FOUR. MISTER COOPER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR AND-
ALLOWING US AN INDULGING US IN
THIS. CENTER WE'RE IN RECESS.
WE WILL BEGIN WITH OPPOSITION
IN ONE MINUTE. BACK ACTIVE
MEDINA. OKAY THAT. I'M SORRY.
YEAH. IF IT. THE LOCAL. YEAH.
HELLO. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
WE ARE RECONVENING THE SENATE
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE FOR AUGUST
ELEVENTH AND WE WILL CONTINUE
FROM WHERE WE LEFT OFF WE ARE
NOW AND ITEM THREE EIGHTY SIX
SIXTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER WE HAVE HEARD SUPPORT WE
HAVE HEARD THE LEAD WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION AND NOW WE WILL
GO TO THOSE WHO INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY OPPOSITION
TO A. B. SIX SIXTY FOUR WHO ARE
ON THE TOP CONFERENCE LINE AND
SERVICE MODERATOR YOU'LL PLEASE
PROMPT THE END WAS WAITING TO.
OPPOSITION PEACE SIXTY FOUR
FLIP THEN WE WILL BEGIN. SB SIX
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE WILL
START WITH LINE TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. BUT WE GOT OUT TO LINE TWO
FIVE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO. THANK YOU S. AND WE HAVE
NINE TO FIVE EIGHT PLEASE CALL.
SENATORS BUT I THINK OUT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA OF AND
RESPECTFUL. THANK YOU. IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE SPEAK AND
POSITION OF AB SIX FOUR PRESSED
AND THEN ZERO AND THIS TIME. WE
HAVE FOR THEIR QUEUING UP. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MONTEREY
THREE THE GOOD WORK THIS AFTER.
TO ANOTHER HEARD FROM SUPPORT
AN OP WITNESSES WE WILL BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- I. SEE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS COMING
FROM MEMBERS- IN I MAKE BEFORE
YOU CLOSE- JIM I JUST WANTED
TO. TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS AND FOR BRINGING IN
SPONSORING THIS THIS THIS SHOW
TO THE COMMITTEE AND- N. FOR
WORKING WITH US IN THE REFINING
THIS TO MAKE IT- I THINK OF A
BETTER BILL- THERE CERTAINLY
JUST AS IN ALL OF THESE IS MORE
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
ESPECIALLY IN THIS SPACE THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- AND I
SUPPORT THE- THE MEASURE TODAY.
CERTAINLY TOOK TO KEEP IT
MOVING BUT PLEASE IF YOU WOULD
KEEP US. ABREAST OF ANY CHANGES
IN PART OF THE CONVERSATION AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD SO WITH
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
HER EYES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HELP MISTER CHAIR IN YOUR
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE STAFFER
HELPING ALSO. ANDERSON THREE I
HAVE A GOOD DAY YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THAT IS. THERE A
MOTION. CENTER MAY. OR SOME OF.
WE HAVE A- FOR BUDGET. ACTION
DO NOT A FLY OR A HAND SHOWS
SENATE MITCHELL WE HAVE A- THIS
IS DUE. TO APPROPRIATE WITH
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON THAT HELLO. THE MOTION IS TO
A- ABILITY AB SIX SIX FOUR I'D
NUMBER MAY PLEASE TURN ON YOUR-
IN ORDER TO RECORD VOTE.
SENATOR HILL HI CENTER HILL HI
CENTER MORALE. SO JACKSON.
JACKSON HI SENATOR JACK HI
SENATOR MITCHELL MITCHELL II
SENATOR MITCHELL HI SENATOR PAN.
THE BILL HAS FOUR FOR THREE
BOETSCH- AND WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
VERY MUCH COOPER. WE WILL NOW
GO. VERY GOOD MISTER KALRA HE
WILL BE PRESENT IN. FOR ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE. WELCOME AGAIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THE
RISEN AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
FIVE ABOUT HALF MY COLLEAGUES A
MEMBER O. DONNELL FOR AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE DEFINES UP
PUBLIC WORKS- FOR THE PURPOSE
OF PAYING PREVAILING WAGES TO
INCLUDE CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY
PROJECTS TO RECEIVE FUNDING
THROUGH CONDUIT REVENUE BONDS
CONNOR REVENUE BONDS ARE A TYPE
OF FINANCING HAS BY A PUBLIC
ENTITY THE STATE ACTUALLY LOSES
REVENUE ON THESE BONDS AS
INVESTORS DO NOT PAY TAXES. IN
TURN THE BORROWER RESERVE
RECEIVED LOWER INTEREST RATES
UNDER EXISTING LAW CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITIES ARE FUNDED BY
STATE EDUCATION BONDS ARE
REQUIRED TO COME TO COMPLY WITH
PREVAILING WAGE AND HIGHER
CONSTRUCTION STANDARDS UNDER
THE FIELD ACT PROJECTS THAT ARE
FUNDED WITH CONDUIT REVENUE
BONDS ARE NOT THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT WORKERS ON SCHOOL
FACILITIES PROJECTS ARE SKILLED.
AND QUALIFIED. UNDER THIS PANDA
ISN'T. MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER
THE WORKING FOR RECEIVE LIVING
WAGE. AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
FIVE SPONSOR BY THE STATE
BUILDING TRADE COUNCIL AND
THERE'S- ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
THE OF MR O'DONNELL. TESTIFYING
TO JEREMY SMITH BUT THE STATE
BILL BECAUSE TRADES. WHO WAS A
THE ROOM. BEFORE THE BIRTH. I
BELIEVE. HELLO IS. WE SHOULD
MAKE SMITH ARE YOU ON THE PHONE
LINE BY SOME. NOT HEARING WHAT
WE DO IS GO TO SUPPORT AND WE
WILL BRING A IN WHEN HE ENTERED
YOU ARRIVE SO WE WILL NOW LOOK
TO ELSE YOU CAN ROOM FORTY TWO
TH WISHING SPEAK AND- OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE SHE
KNOWN WE WANNA GO TO. ROOM ONE
TWELVE ONE IN ONE TWELVE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE SEEN NO ONE WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE THE SERVICE IN A
WITNESSES WISHING TO SUPPORT
MODERN PLEASE PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE. PLEASE THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO KEEP UP
TO BE CANCELED OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE WILL GO FIRST TO LINE TWO
SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ABOUT ON
THE AFTER THE- AND- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO ROB. NINE TO SAY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO
SEVEN FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT
THIS TIME IF THERE ARE ANY
OTHER LINES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SIX FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
TWO SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MATT
KREMIN COUNTY OUT CAL MEDICAL
ABOUT ENGINEER WE ARE STOCKS.
THANK YOU. SPEEDLINE TWO SEVEN
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M NOT
NINE TWO SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH I WAS NOT
GIVEN A NUMBER OF MY LINE. YES
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH MODERATE A GAP SURE
MEMBERS COLOR IN CALLING ON THE
BECAUSE STATE AT THIS OF ELECT
WORKER CALIFORNIA STATE
PINETREE. WESTERN STATE COUNCIL
OF SHEET METAL A LOT OF THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION ELEVATOR
AND READ OUR PRESS ON THE BOOKS
THOUSAND SIX THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A PART OF THE COMPUTER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU HAVE LINE
TO SET EIGHT PLEASE GO. DANIEL
B. TERRORISM OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS OF DISTRICT NOT
AND- THANK YOU. PINE TWO EIGHT
ZERO TWO GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR IN MY- MIKE
REPRESENTING INTER YEAH OF AND
TRADES WHICH WITH THAT THE
TRADES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MUCH. THANK YOU AGAIN
IF THERE IS ANYONE TO IN
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SIX FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE ARE KNOWN FOR
THEIR QUEUING UP. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK-
MISTER SMITH IS. AVAILABLE ON
LINE NOT IN PERSON- AS OUR
WITNESS. TO MISTER SMITH ARE
YOU ARE YOU AVAILABLE AND YOU
WOULD HAVE FOUR MINUTES. I
THINK HE'S TRYING TO GET. ON
RIGHT NOW. YEAH I HAVE SEEN HIM
ON THE- TV BARBERRY WILL WILL
GO TO OPPOSITE AND WE WILL GIVE
THAT. ALRIGHT. MODERATOR IS A
FOR YOU TO SEE IF CAN FIND HIM
ON THE LAW. CERTAINLY I WE
DON'T HAVE A REDDISH VOTER ME
SMITH YOU ARE THE LINE YOU CAN
I DO YOURSELF BUT STAR AND THEN.
IF YOU WERE ALRIGHT ONE MOMENT
I BELIEVE WE MAY HAVE BEEN HERE
VERY GOOD. THE SYSTEM MEDICARE
LINE IS OPEN. I DON'T THINK.
MISTER SMITH IS THAT YOU. I DO
APOLOGIZE YES SIR WE DO HAVE IS
LINE NOW PLEASE GO AHEAD MR
SMITH. THANK YOU FOR SHARING. I
FOR NOT BEING IN PERSON I WS.
UNDER THE IMPRESSION IT WOULD
BE. NOTICE THAT THE YESTERDAY
BY PAUL. I AM GERMAN COMMITTEE
ON BEHALF OF STATE WILL BE
ENTRANCE TRADES COUNCIL AUGUST
EIGHTY QUITE. FIVE I LIKE TO
THINK MISTER FIRST FULL AND
TAKING OVER MR DONALD A YOU
CAN'T BE THERE. ARE THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE CHARTER SCHOOL
THAT PUBLIC SUBSIDY. THIS WILL
TRACK THE MOST COMPETENT
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
TO BUILD THE SCHOOLS. THE
LEGISLATURE ALREADY DID THIS
FOR ACUTE CARE HOSPITAL DUTY
CONDO ON. EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN. HOW DO A BUNDLE
OF CHARTER SCHOOLS TO UTILIZE
THE MUNICIPAL BOND MARKET TO
BUY BONDS TO FINANCE
CONSTRUCTION. ALLOWING THEM TO
SAVE MONEY IN INTEREST PAYMENTS.
YOU LIVE IN THE TAXPAYERS BY
READING ON THE MUNICIPAL BOND
MARKET WE BELIEVE THAT THE
TAXPAYER INVESTMENT IN A
PRIVATE PROJECT. THE ANALYSIS
DOES A GOOD JOB TWENTY. HOW
THIS PROCESS WORKS AND THAT IT
MAKES SENSE TO ENSURE THAT ANY
WORK BEING PAID FOR BY PROCEEDS
FROM CONDUIT BOND SHOULD
THEREFORE GO TOWARD PROVIDING A
LIVING WAGE. WITH BENEFITS WERE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS BUILDING
THE PROJECT THAT THE BOND FUND
AND THEIR FAMILIES. UNDERBELLY
WHICH PROVIDES TAKE HOME PAY
THAT HAS LITTLE CLASS. DOUBLE
HEALTH AND WELFARE FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IN A
PENSION. FOR THE WORKERS WHO
OFTEN HAVE TO RETIRE EARLIER
THAN MOST BECAUSE OF THE- HOW
HARD THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
IS THIS IS A BILL THAT. SERVER
THE TYPE OF ECONOMIC STIMULUS.
BY ENSURING THAT CHARTER
SCHOOLS PROVIDE CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS WITH MIDDLE CLASS
WAGES- THAT WILL HELP THEM
WHETHER THE CURRENT RECESSION
SHOULD THE CHARTER SCHOOL
INDUSTRY VOLUNTARILY DECIDE TO
PURSUE FUNDING. FELL WITHIN AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE. WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT BY USING
HIGHLY SKILLED INDIAN WORKERS
ON THESE PROJECTS. CHARTER
SCHOOL DEVELOPERS WILL ACTUALLY
SAVE MONEY BY HAVING THEIR
PROJECT FINISHED ON TIME. AND
UNDER BUDGET WHAT'S YOUR CHANGE
ORDERS OR CONSTRUCTION DELAYS
CONSTRUCT WORKERS THE WAGE
GRADUATES. OF THE PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM. YEAH HIGH SKILL INCOME.
BELPER MONEY ON BACK. FINALLY
BELIEVE THAT A TAXPAYER DOLLARS
OR A PUBLIC BENEFIT GOES TO
BUILD ANYTHING THAT'S RECESSION
WHEN EVERY DOLLAR OF TAXPAYER
MONEY TO BE SPENT WISELY THAT
TAXPAYERS WOULD WANT TO KNOW
THAT CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ARE
EIGHT MIDDLE CLASS WAGES BUT-
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHERE I ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER
SMITH WE WILL NOW. GO TO THOSE
IN OPPOSITION I SEE NO LEAD.
OPPOSITION SPEAKER SO WE WILL
NOW GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE
RESEARCHER YES. STRUCTURE I'M
SO SORRY YES I AM CARLOS FORGET
YOUR ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION I
AM THE LEAD OPPOSITION AND I'M
SORRY I DID NOT HAVE YOU HERE
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR- REMINDING
US OF THAT. SO PLEASED TO
PROCEED YOU HAVE FOUR MINUTES.
A NOT A WORRY THANK YOU. ON
BEHALF OF- CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION- I'M HERE
TO SERVE AS LEAD OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE.
WHILE FEET YET THEY GENERALLY
SUPPORT THE PROPONENT STATED
INTENT THAT CHARTER SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION FUNDING BE MADE
MORE SUSTAINABLE WE DISAGREE
THAT AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE
WILL ACHIEVE THAT INTENT- AND-
I'M LIKE DISTRICTS CHARTER
SCHOOL DEBT SERVICE PAYMENTS
ARE WITHDRAWN FROM THE SAME
FUND USED TO PAY FOR. CRITICAL
STUDENT SERVICES AND TEACHER
SALARIES GIVEN THE STATE'S
CHALLENGING TECHNICAL OUTLOOK
FURTHER ENCROACHMENT ON THE
ALREADY STRAINED OUT. BUDGET
THE PUBLIC'S IT ADVISED AT THIS
TIME. FURTHER FOR CLOSING ON
COST EFFECTIVE ACCESS TO OUR
FACILITIES PROGRAM OF LAST
RESORT FOR CHARTERS AT A TIME
WHEN ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE
GRAPPLING WITH NECESSARY SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS. WILL
ONLY SERVE TO APPLY EVEN
GREATER PRESSURE ON SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO MAKE EQUITABLE
SPACE AVAILABLE AS CHARTERS ARE
REQUIRED- TO HAVE ACCESS TO
UNDER PROP THIRTY NINE. WE'RE
ALREADY SEEING CALLS TO IMPOSE
THE MORATORIUM ON PROP THIRTY
NINE LEASES AND EVEN EVICTING
EXISTING CHARTER SCHOOLS FROM
DISTRICT THE SAUDIS TO
ACCOMMODATE NEW SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS. AND
SINCE SO FEW LOCAL BONDS GRANT
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO CHARTERS.
AND THE MODERNIZE STATE BOND.
PROGRAM FAILED TO THIS MARCH.
AND WE SUPPORTED. PROGRAM LIKE
THE KIND OF WHAT ACT. ACT AS A
PRESSURING VALVE ON. CAMPUS
THAT CURRENTLY HOUSE BOTH
DISTRICT AND CHARTER SCHOOLS.
WE ALSO WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THE CONDUIT BOND PROGRAM DOES
NOT INVOLVE PUBLIC FUNDS. AS
THE PROPONENTS HAVE STATED. AND
AS CLARIFIED IN GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S VETO MESSAGE ON
IDENTICAL LANGUAGE LAST YEAR.%
THE STATE ABSORBS NO RISK
BECAUSE THE STATE TREASURER'S
INTERCEPT PACKAGES AND CAPTURES
A RECIPIENT SCHOOL ANNUAL
APPORTIONMENT AUTOMATICALLY. IF
THIS PROGRAM IS COST
PROHIBITIVE WE DO WORRY THAT
SOME CHARTER SCHOOLS HE TO
FINANCE THE PROJECT ON THE
PRIVATE MARKET WITHOUT THE SAME
RIGOROUS PUBLIC VETTING. AND
DUE DILIGENCE PROCESS THAT THE
SFA REQUIRES WHICH PROTECTS
AGAINST CONFLICT OF INTEREST
ISSUES AND ENSURES THE
RECIPIENT SCHOOL IS
SUSTAINABLE. FINALLY GSA WAS
PROUD TO ENGAGE WITH THE AUTHOR
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
LAST YEAR IN HELPING ENACTED
HISTORIC OVERHAUL TO THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS ACT. YES HE IS
HOPEFUL THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL ALLOW SOME TIME FOR
CHARTERS TO FOCUS ON
IMPLEMENTING AB FIFTEEN OH
FIVE. BEFORE LEGISLATING YOUR
REQUIREMENTS ON CHARTER
SCHOOLS. AFTER THESE RECENT CDS.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE IS TO KNOW
ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WE NOW GO TO WITNESSES WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE WHO ARE
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY TWO
OR THREES SEE NO ONE WILL NOW
GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE IS THERE
ANYONE THERE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION SEE NO ONE. THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFYVIA THE TELECONFERENCE ERVAS
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROMPT. THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE PLEASE.
RELATED A GENTLEMAN IF HE WAS
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE WILL GO TO LINE TWO
SEVEN FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER LINES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
KNOWN FOR THEIR QUEUING UP.
THANK YOU MODERATOR THAN WE
WILL WE'VE HEARD THOSE IN
SUPPORT AND THOSE IN OPPOSITION
WE WILL BRING IT NOW BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR-
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE A BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOWN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR STRICTLY ASPEN HAVE A-
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BRING IT BACK TO THE BILL WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR PAN-
IN THIS IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF WITH A
CONSULTANT PLEASE CIRCLE THE
ROLE. FOR MEMBERS PLEASE TURN
ON AND SPEAK INTO YOUR
MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO CAST A
VOTE SENATOR HILL HI. SENATOR
HILL HI SENATOR MORALE. SENATOR
JACKSON. JACKSON HI SENATOR
JACKSON HI SENATOR MITCHELL
MITCHELL AYE SENATOR MITCHELL
HI CENTER PAN HI CENTER PAN BY.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES BUT
WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU HI I DO
NOT SEE ANOTHER MEMBER HERE SO
I THINK. I'M SURE YOU'LL BE
HAPPY TO GO VERY GOOD THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE
PLEASE PROCEED YOU CAN DO FROM
THERE IF YOU'D LIKE. HE DON'T
HAVE TO MOVE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT BYE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE IS
SPONSORED BY INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
WOULD PROTECT DOMESTIC WORKERS
FROM BEING FORCED TO WORK IN
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS SUCH AS
THOSE CAUSED BY WILDFIRES
SPECIFICALLY AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT WOULD EXTEND
EXISTING PROTECTIONS AGAINST
EMPLOYER RETALIATION FOR
EMPLOYEES TO REFUSE TO WORK AND
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS DO.
CONDITIONS TO DOMESTIC WORKERS.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT ALSO
STATES THAT AFTER RECEIVING
NOTICE OF EVACUATION A PERSON
SHALL BE GUILTY OF A
MISDEMEANOR THAT THEY NOT ONLY
DIRECTED EMPLOYEE TO ENTER OR
REMAIN IN AN AREA CALLED DO THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY THREATS. THIS
BILL IS NECESSARY NOW MORE THAN
EVER BEFORE TO AVOID SITUATIONS
SIMILAR TO THOSE WE HAVE
WITNESSED IN PAST YEARS WERE
DOMESTIC WORKERS WERE SEEN
HEADING TOWARDS THE EVACUATED
HOMES URROUNDED IN CLOUDS OF
TOXIC SMOKE FROM WILDFIRES. IN
ONE INSTANCE A WORKER WAS
DIRECTED TO REMAIN INTHE HOME
IN ORDER TO PROTECT IT. THAT
WORKER THEN BECAME TRAPPED
INSIDE THE DANGEROUS AREA FOR
OVER A WEEK. SOME OF THE
WORKERS INTERVIEWED IN THE NEW
STORY STATED THAT THEY FEARED
RETALIATION IF THEY DIDN'T SHOW
UP FOR WORK DESPITE THE
HAZARDOUS. CONDITIONS THIS
MEASURE WOULD ALLEVIATE THAT
FEAR AND CREATE FAIRNESS AND
EQUITY IN THE WORKPLACE BY
PROVIDING PROTECTION FROM
EMPLOYER RETALIATION FOR
REFUSING TO WORK IN HAZARDOUS
CONDITIONS. FURTHERMORE THERE
IS NOTHING IN CURRENT
CALIFORNIA LABOR CODE THAT
CLEARLY AND EXPRESSLY PREVENTS
A DOMESTIC WORKER FROM ORDERING
A DOMESTIC WORKER TO REMAIN IN
A MANDATORY EVACUATION ZONE
SKEWS ME AT DOMESTIC EMPLOER
FROM ORDERING A DOMESTIC
WORKER. THIS ISSUE WAS
HIGHLIGHTED CURRENTLY BY THE
PRESENCE OF COVERT NINETEEN
UNDER CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE
SECTION FOUR NINE POINT FIVE OF
A CALAMITY CREATES AN IMMEDIATE
MENACE TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS ARE GIVEN
THE AUTHORITY TO CLOSE THE AREA
WHEN THE MINNIS EXISTS. THE
FOOTBALL GAME PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER WERE TO DO SO IN THIS
BILL WOULD PROTECT DOMESTIC
WORKERS FROM BEING COMPELLED TO
ENTER SUCH AREAS. FOR AGAINST
FOR REFUSING TO WORK IN
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS IT'S
ALREADY ESTABLISHED IN THE
LABOR CODE FOR MANY WORKERS AND
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT THIS
PROTECTION IS ALSO MADE
AVAILABLE. TO DOMESTIC WORKERS.
DOMESTIC WORKERS ARE AN
INTEGRAL PART OF OUR LIVES AND
ARE WORTHY OF THE VERY SAME
PROTECTIONS WE PROVIDED. TO
EVERY OTHER CALIFORNIA WORKER.
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH ME TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF THE PHONE IS
MICHAEL MARTINEZ REPRESENTING
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
MISTER MARTINEZ WELCOME. YES
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR CHERRY HILL AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL
MARTINEZ SENIOR DEPUTY
COMMISSIONERS TESTIFYING
VIRTUALLY ALL ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. THANK
U. S. SENATOR MITCHELL FOR
PRESENTING THIS MEASURE TODAY
HERE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
WOMAN BURKE. COMMISSIONER LOTTE
IS THE PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS
MEASURE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
THE COMMITTEE SPOKE SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE. FOR SURE A LOT OF
SPONSORING THIS IMPORTANT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND LABOR
PROTECTION MEASURE BECAUSE HE
WANTS FAIRNESS AND EQUITY IN
THE WORKPLACE FOR THESE HARD
WORKING INDIVIDUALS. MANY OF
WHOM ARE IMMIGRANTS NON ENGLISH
SPEAKERS AND FROM CHANGES THE
COLOR. AND CERTAINLY GIVEN- AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW THE
COMMISSIONER'S BACKGROUND HE
DID ASSEMBLY MEMBERS RELATIVES
INDIVIDUAL THAT THAT IS KNOWN
FOR MANY YEARS. THAT I'VE
WORKED HARD FOR MANY YEARS- IN
THIS PARTICULAR INDUSTRY. AND
SO THIS- THIS PART THIS
SPECIFIC BILL IS VERY.
IMPORTANT TO HIM ON A PERSONAL
AND PROFESSIONAL LEVEL. I
APPRECIATE SENATOR MITCHELL
PROVIDING A FANTASTIC OVERVIEW
OF THE BILL IN THE NEED FOR IT
SO I WILL JUST SAY. THAT AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT IS
NEEDED NOW. TO EXTEND CRITICAL
WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS TO THIS
VULNERABLE SECTOR WORKERS.
BEFORE WE FACE ANY ADDITIONAL
UNDER EXISTING BONFIRES OR
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH
PANDEMIC ORDERS. AND HELP
INSURE DOMESTIC WORKERS IN THE
STATE ARE PROTECTED. WITH CLEAR
STATUTORY PROTECTIONS FROM
EMPLOYER RETALIATION AND FROM.
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE AND THEN JUST A
REAL QUICK ADJUSTMENT YOU
SENATOR- HILL FOR YOUR SERVICES
FOSTER TWELVE YEARS. AND THE
SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU MISTER MARTIN IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE WORKING WITH YOU AFTER
THAT PERIOD OF TIME- WE WILL
NOW- IT'S IN THANK YOU FOR THE
TESTIMONY WILL NOW WORK WE-
LOOK AT. OTHERS WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT WHO WOULD BE HAPPY TO BE
IN FROM FORTY TWO OH THREE. IS
THERE ANYONE FORTY TWO OR THREE
SEEN NO ONE IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE WE WILL NOW GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE IN
ONE TWELVE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHTEEN NO ONE WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ERVAS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPTLY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE ZERO THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS ANDREA RIVERA
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE LINE TWO SEVEN EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ANY RETURNS ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE AND ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES OPEN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND IF THERE ARE ANY
FURTHER LINES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE KNOWN FOR THEIR
QUEUING UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR WE WILL AFTER HEARING
SUPPORT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE IN. THAT WE HAVE NO
LISTED WITNESS FOR IN
OPPOSITION. APPLE I GUESS
THERE'S NO ONE THERE SO NOW WE
WILL MOVE TO FORTY TWO OR THREE
IS OR ANYONE IN. THIS ROOM
SCENE NO ONE GOING TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE IN ONE
TWELVE C. NO ONE AND ONE
TWELVE. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THOSE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION VIA
TELECONFERENCE REVERSAL
MODERATOR PLEASE PROP. THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
JUST AN ADDITIONAL REMINDER ONE
AND ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT. WE HAVE KNOWING
KILLING UP VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MODERATOR APPRECIATE THAT AND
APPRECIATE THE WITNESSES WHO
HAVE TESTIFIED- BRINGING IT
BACK TO DISCUSSION OF MEMBERS I
SEE NO ONE WISHING TO AN- OF
THE BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SHOULD- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SENATOR MITCHELL I JUST FEEL
COMPELLED TO SAY- OFF A BLL TO
PROTECT DOMESTIC WORKERS WHICH
HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN WOMEN OF
COLOR ON THE DAY THAT A WOMAN
OF COLOR WAS JUST NOMINATED TO
BE A- VICE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE THAT'S A BIG DEAL AT
LEAST FOR ME. I ASKED FOR A
VOTE. VERY MUCH SENATOR
MITCHELL ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE AND I MEAN IF WE
ARE LIVING IN EXTRAORDINARY
TIMES SUCH A QUESTION ABOUT IT.
BETWEEN THE PANDEMICS IN THE
WILDFIRES AND NOW WITH THE NEWS
TODAY IT'S WONDERFUL THIS IS A-
THIS BILL COULD NOT BE MORE
TIMELY- AND A AND LONG OVERDUE
SO I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING THAT
SENATOR MITCHELL AND- IT FOR
THE SPONSORS IT TO MEASURED
APPROACH AND- CERTAINLY FOR
UNFAIR. EXCLUSION IN LAW
HISTORICALLY SO THIS IS- I
APPRECIATE THE- TO COVER A LOT
OF FOR A FOR UNITS TO.
SPONSORING THIS SO WHAT WE HAVE
A MOTION FROM SENATOR PAN-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CONSULTANT.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MEMBERS PLEASE
TURN YOUR MICROPHONES IN ORDER
TO CAST A VOTE SENATOR HILL HI.
UNDER HILL HI SENATOR MOREAU.
SENATOR JACKSON. JACKSON I
INNER JACKSON HI SENATOR
MITCHELL MITCHELL LINE UNDER
MITCHELL HI CENTER PANTAI. THE
PAN HI THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES
WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS OF SENATOR
MITCHELL WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT- AB TWENTY NINE NINETY
TWO ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER VERY MUCH SO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRS WOULD BE FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY NINE.
NINETY TWO. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER I'D LIKE
2% AB TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO
THIS BILL SEEKS TO EXPAND
EXISTING PROTECTED LEAVE TO
VICTIMS OF ANY VIOLENT CRIME.
AND IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBERS OF
HOMICIDE VICTIMS. AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY TWO ALLOWS LEAVE
ONLY FOR LIMITED PURPOSES WHICH
IS DIFFERENT FROM THE LEASE
TERMINATION PROTECTION
PROPOSED. IN A NUMBER OF SENATE
BILL SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY
THAT ARE REFERENCED IN TODAY'S
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. SB ELEVEN
NINETY ALLOWS AN ELIGIBLE
SURVIVOR TO BREAK A LEASE
FOLLOWING A CRIME. WHERE IS
THIS BILL AB TWENTY NINE NINETY
TWO WHAT ONLY AUTHORIZED UNPAID
LEAVE FOR ELIGIBLE SURVIVORS.
IF THE LEAVES SPECIFICALLY TO
ACCEPT TO ACCESSIBLE HEALTH
CARE MEDICAL CARE VICTIM
SERVICES SAFETY PLAN OR TO
OBTAIN A PROTECTIVE OR
RESTRAINING ORDER. AS NOTED IN
THE ANALYSIS THE CONTENTS OF
THESE BILLS ARE INDEED
DIFFERENT. THE NARROW SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH
UNPAID LEAVE IS ALLOWABLE IN AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO FURTHER
LIMITS ELIGIBILITY FOR LEAVE
WHICH IS DIFFERENT FROM SB
ELEVEN NINETY AND MAKES
ELIGIBILITY MUCH NARROWER. THAN
FOR TENANT PROTECTIONS THE
OTHER BILL. SB ELEVEN NINETY
ALSO APPLIES TO MEET FAMILY
MEMBERS OF LIVING VICTIMS
WHEREAS THIS BILL AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY TWO DOES NOT.
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE CONDUCTED A STATEWIDE
POLL OF SURVIVORS OF CRIME IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN THE SURVEY
FOUND THAT ONE IN FOUR
CALIFORNIA SURVIVORS HAD TO
MISS WORK FOLLOWING THE CRIME.
AND TWO OUT OF THREE REPORTED
EXPERIENCING ANXIETY STRESS AND
DIFFICULTY WITH SLEEPING.
RELATIONSHIPS OR WORK. STEADY'S
CONSISTENTLY HAVE SHOWN THAT
SURVIVORS OF VIOLENT CRIMES
PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
SURVIVORS OVERWHELMINGLY NEED
SUPPORT MEETING BASIC NEEDS
FOLLOWING THE CRIME INCLUDING
MAINTAINING STABLE EMPLOYMENT.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL SURVIVORS OF
VIOLENCE CAN TAKE LIMITED TIME
OFF TO SECURE THEIR SAFETY AND
HEALING FOLLOWING A CRIME. NO
ONE TOLD ME WHO'S BEEN A VICTIM
OF A VIOLENT CRIME SHOULD HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR
PHYSICAL OR EMOTIONAL SAFETY
AND THE FINANCIAL CONSEQUENCES
OF LOSING LOSING THEIR JOB. AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY TO EXPAND
EXISTING PROTECTED UNPAID LEAVE
TO VICTIMS OF ANY VIOLENT CRIME
AND TO IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBERS
OF HOMICIDE VICTIMS. THIS BILL
WILL ALSO EXPAND ACCEPTABLE
FORMS OF DOCUMENTATION THAT
VICTIM CAN PROVIDE TO TAKE
PROTECTED LEAVE FROM WORK OR
REQUEST REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS TO RECOVER
FOLLOWING A CRIME. AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY TWO DOES NOT MAKE
ANY CHANGES TO THE AMOUNT OF
LEAVE CURRENTLY ALLOWABLE IT
ONLY EXPANDS THIS PROTECTION TO
ADDITIONAL FOR VICTIMS OF
VIOLENT CRIME. WITH ME TODAY
ARE WITNESS FROM THE CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION AND NAKUL
MAJOR AND ELIZABETH MOON YELLS.
AND THE ATTORNEY FOR
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE ANDREA GENTILE IS ON
THE LINE ALTHOUGH I KNOW SHE
HAS A TWO O'CLOCK. MEETING THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AUTHOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS SHE SHOULD
BE AVAILABLE FOR THIS FOR THE
NEXT FEW MINUTES. YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN Q. VERY MUCH OF
SENATOR. MITCHELL THE- WE DO
HAVE THREE LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES- AN ECHO MAJOR. MAJOR
SURVIVOR FROM CRIME SURVIVORS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE
ELIZABETH MOON JOOSS SURVIVOR
FROM CRIME SURVIVORS AND
SAFETIES JUSTICE IN ANDREA
GENTEEL SENIOR STATE POLICY
MANAGER FOR CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE WE HAVE A
TOTAL OF FOUR MINUTES THIRD ONE
IS ONLY HERE FOR TECHNICAL FOR
QUESTION BOTH IT'S A HUNDRED
SHOULD DEAL YES YES SAY THAT
I'M SORRY I APOLOGIZE. FOR THAT
SO WE HAVE THE TWO WITNESSES
YOU HAVE A TOTAL OF FOUR
MINUTES PLEASE APPRECIATE AT
YOUR CONVENIENCE. HI I ALL STAR
AND GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH GOING OUT. AND I AM A
SURVIVOR OF GUN VIOLENCE MY
CHILD MY ONLY CHILD ONE CARLOS
SAINZ JUNIOR. WAS THE VICTIM OF
A HOMICIDE BY GUN VIOLENCE IN
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN. SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA. I THINK
ENVIRONMENT SURVIVOR AND THE
CRIME SURVIVORS IF THEY'D BE
INTERESTED SAN DIEGO CHAPTER
COORDINATOR. I AM A TROOP THE
CORNER OF THE. AB TWO NINE NINE
TWO. I WAS FORCED TO RESIGN
FROM JOB SIX AT SIXTEEN. OF AGE
NURSE RELATING TO NOT BEING
ABLE TO TAKE TIME OFF TO
GRIEVE. SEEK MEDICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH ATTENTION AND OTHER
WORDS UNABLE TO HEAL AND
PROPERTY GRIEVES THAT'S ON THAT
BOX OF FRANKLIN. I HAD RANGING
YEARS DAD WAS LAID OFF FROM
WORK RELATED TO NOT BEING ABLE
TO PERFORM TO THEIR STANDARDS
JUST WEEKS AFTER LOSING IN OUR
AND- A HOMICIDE. HE WAS LEFT
WITHOUT INCOME OR HEALTH
BENEFITS. FIVE MILLION INTO A
SEVERE DEPRESSION. A VICTIM OF
GUN VIOLENCE IS IMPACTED SO
MANY WAYS. AND THAT WE ASKED
FOR WE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN OUR PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL SAFETY AND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF EITHER LOSING
OUR JOB OR HAVING TO- RESIGNED
FROM OUR JOBS. ARE YOU LOSING
YOUR HOMEWORK EVERYTHING ELSE
IN BETWEEN THAT HAPPENS TO US
WE DESERVE TO INCREASE OUR
SAFETY FROM FURTHER HARM. WE
NEED TO TAKE TIME TO GRIEVE TO
RECOVER AND TO HEAR ALL. THREE
DAYS EARLIER TIME IS NOT ENOUGH
TIME. IT'S NOT EVEN ENOUGH TIME
TO PUT OUR LOVE ONE TOMORROW
SERVICES TOGETHER AND BURY
THEM. ON BEHALF OF THE CRIME
SURVIVOR COMMUNITY I SUPPORT AB
TWO NINE NINE TWO. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SHARE OUR
STORY LAST. THANK VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED OUR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE
NO CALL MAJOR AND I AM A
RESIDENT OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AND A PROBLEM MEMBER OF CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. TODAY I'M HERE TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF SURVIVORS OF
VIOLENT CRIME IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. MY SON JESSE WAS
MURDERED WHILE ATTENDING AN OFF
CAMPUS COLLEGE ADVANCE- DURING
THAT TIME- JUST BEFORE THE
INCIDENT I MEAN THE- INCIDENT
MY FANS BUT HOSPITALIZED FOR
TEN DAYS BEFORE PASSING AWAY
AND DURING THAT TIME A COMPACT
ME DURING THOSE TEN DAYS. WE
WERE WE HAD TO EXHAUST ALL OF
OUR SICK AND VACATION TIME NOT
JUST THAT BUT OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS AND FRIENDS OR SUPPORT
THEIR TO SUPPORT AT. WHAT IT IS
SAYING AFTER MY SON PASSED- TEN
DAYS AFTER HIS I'M TAPPING ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAD TO
FACE WHAT THE REALITY OF. IF WE
WERE GOING TO CHOOSE. YOU'RE
PRETTY OVER BEING TERMINATED
AND DURING THAT TIME I'M TRYING
TO PREPARE FOR OUR FANS- BURIAL
AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS THAT
COME WITH LOSING A CHILD- IT
WAS A VERY DIFFICULT SITUATION
BUT A SITUATION THAT WE KNEW WE
HAD TO DO AND DURING THAT TIME
WANTED THE TRAGIC THINGS THAT I
HAD THAT I HAD TO FACE IS THAT
I WAS AN EMERGENCY. RESPONSE
SOCIAL WORKER BUT CHAO WHERE
SPARE AND I HAD TO ALSO DEAL
WITH THE REALITY OF FAMILIES
THAT I HAD WORKED WITH THAT
WERE IMPACTED BY VIOLENCE AND I
HAD EXPECTED THEM TO GO TO
TREATMENT IN ORDER TO HEAL FROM
THEIR TRAGEDY- AND THEN ALSO
EXPECTED THEM TO TAKE OFF THE
TIME WHEN I HAD TO FACE THIS
TRAGEDY THE REALITIES THAT THAT
THERE WAS NO PROTECTION FOR
EITHER ME OR THE CLIENTS THAT I
SERVED. SO AT THIS TIME- I WAS
FACED WITH THE MAIN BARRIERS
THAT FAMILIES THE LOSS THAT
THEY WERE GOING TO HAVE WITH
THE LOSS OF NOT ONLY A CHILD OR
LOVED ONE DYING BUT ALSO. THE
RISK OF LOSING THEIR CHILD TO
THE WHERE FIRST AT THEM BECAUSE
I DID. TWO EIGHT. EIGHT FORMER
TREATMENT TODAY AM. SOME EIGHT.
MAJOR FOR. I'M SURVIVING SAFETY
AND I WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO DO
THE WORK IT WASN'T FOR THE
PROCESS THAT I BE HEALING THAT
I HAVE- WORKED ON ALSO TODAY
I'M NOT HERE JUST TO SPEAK
ABOUT MY FOR NO MORE BUT I AM
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE DRIVERS
COULD FACE THESE BARRIERS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
TESTIMONY- AND- FEATURE BEING
WITH US TODAY WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO THOSE IN SUPPORT IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE ANYONE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY TWO SEEN WAY WE
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE IS
THERE ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISHING TO SPEAK IT'S TO YOU
KNOW WANT THEIR- WE WILL NOW GO
TO OUR TELECONFERENCE. SERVICE
TO FIND THOSE IN TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY TWO- MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE CHECK THE LINE TO SEE
IF- THOSE WILLING WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY TWO PLEASE. THE
GENTLEMAN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
QUEUE UP IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE WILL GO FIRST TO LINE
THREE ZERO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. POLISH GERRY RIVERA ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ONE THREE ONE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. PINE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON CHAIRED
THE MEETING AT THE PARK YOU
KNOW ON BEHALF OF SPONSORED
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY DOCTORS
AND TALK ABOUT THE CRIMES
ALLEGEDLY CONDUCTED WE ARE
PROUD. SPONSORS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WANT SEVEN EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE END OF THE
KARAGANDY HOPPER THE
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE AND ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES OPEN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ONCE AGAIN IF YOU LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE KNOWN FOR THEIR QUEUING
UP WE'RE GOOD THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT- SO WE WILL NOW
GO TO THOSE IN OPPOSITION WE'VE
HEARD FROM THOSE IN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANY LEAD WITNESS. WE
DON'T HAVE ONE LISTED. YOU HAVE
ANYONE ON THE LINE. I BELIEVE
NOT THEN WE WILL GO TO THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY TWO IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE. SEEN NO ONE HERE IS
THERE ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
TO AB TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE THEN WE WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE. LINE IT FOR
THOSE SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO
A MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE.
CHECK THE LINES AND- FOR THOSE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO
PLEASE. THANK YOU IT IS A
GENTLEMAN TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE SHOWING UP
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MODERATOR
AND WE WILL NOT BRING THAT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
COMMENTS OR CONVERSATION.
QUESTIONS SEEING NONE OF THEM.
THEN WHICH WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PUT A QUESTION OR A COMPUTER
BUT PROJECTED CLOSES SENATOR
MITCHELL ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THE MOVE THE BILL VERY
GOOD WEEK WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM- DOCTOR PAN ON AB FOR
TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO TO DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS PLEASE TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO CAST A
VOTE. CENTER HILL HI. CENTER
HILL HI. CENTER MORALE BURNOUT
NO. BINNER MOREAU NO CENTER
JACKSON. JACKSON HI CENTER
JACKSON HI CENTER MITCHELL
MITCHELL LIVE BETTER MITCHELL
HI CENTER PANTAI. CENTER PAN HI
THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES IT IS
OUT WE WILL NOW I SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW IN THE AUDIENCE WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
TERROR AND COLLEAGUES YOU'RE
KIND ENOUGH TO SEE A SIMILAR TO
RATIONS AT THIS BEFORE AND BE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS TIME AROUND
THERE IS SUPPORT FROM BOTH THE
BARE RAPID TRANSIT AS WELL AS-
THE- BORDERS AND HARDER.
WORKING AND DEDICATED EMPLOYEES
OF THE AREA RAPID TRANSIT WOULD
HELP ENSURE THE LAST MUCH LABOR
PEACE AS POSSIBLE. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
BURGER THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE WE THIS IS IN. OF THE TO
READ WITNESS. THE QUICK PRETTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON ARE YOU THERE
HELLO AND SENSORS. I WANT TO GO
FOR GO HEAD BOOK. TWITTER WITH
TERRY AND THE AGAIN- SO TERRY I
BELIEVE IS RIGHT HERE. SO
PLEASE PROCEED PLATE PLEASE GO
AHEAD WITH YOUR- GOOD AFTERNOON
TERRY BROWN BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA- WE BELIEVE THIS
THIS BILL IS NOT WITHOUT
PRECEDENCE THIS IS MIRRORS WHAT
WE'VE DONE FOR THE ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY. IT'S BEEN WORKING
SUCCESSFULLY IN THAT VENUE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW WE BELIEVE
THAT- HELPING PEOPLE RETURN TO
WORK AFTER THIS PANDEMIC.
SAFELY AND EFFICIENTLY IN
PUBLIC TRANSIT IS AN IMPORTANT
CALL AND THIS BILL GOES ON WAY
TO HELP ACHIEVE THAT FOR THAT
REASON WE DRIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND MISTY. THANK
YOU HELLO AND THANK YOU
SENATORS MY NAME IS KERRY AND
STEEL I'M COUNCIL FOR SEIU
LOCAL TEN TO ONE AND THAT'S THE
LARGEST UNION REPRESENTING PART
IN POLICE. NOW SEIU LOCAL TEN
TO ONE AND THE SECOND LARGEST
BARGE UNION WHICH IS CALLED A
TWO YEAR LOCAL FIFTEEN FIFTY
FIVE HELPED DRAFT THIS BILL. WE
WORKED COLLABORATIVELY WITH
PART TO ADDRESS ALL OF THE
PARTS INTERESTS AND CONCERNS. I
ECHO WHAT MISTER BRANDON JUST
SAID THAT AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
WILL PROMOTE LABOR PEACE. WHEN
A GREATER NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS RETURNED TO WORK
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO COUNT ON
BURKE TO PROVIDE SNOWED. ON
INTERRUPTED TRAIN SERVICE AND
CLEAN SAFE FACILITIES. I WISH
TO POINT OUT THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT CHANGE BARDS
SUBSTANTIVE. LEGAL OBLIGATIONS
UNDER THE EXISTING PART ACTS
WHICH IS THE EXISTING
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING LAW THAT
APPLIES TO PART. IT SIMPLY
PROVIDES AN ADMINISTRATIVE
FORUM THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONS BOARD HER. TO RESOLVE
BARGAINING AND OTHER LABOR
DISPUTE. JUST AS PER DOES FOR
OTHER PUBLIC EMPLOYERS AND
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE UNIONS. THE
PURBA ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSES
AT LOW COST IT'S ACCESSIBLE AND
IT'S RELATIVELY EXPEDITIOUS.
THIS MEANS THAT LABOR DISPUTES
WILL NOT FASTER THEY CAN BE
RESOLVED ARE YOU INNER. MORE
EXPEDITIOUSLY. ADDITIONALLY
HERB IS THAT EXPERT AGENCY
HAVING DECADES OF EXPERIENCE
RESOLVING UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE
CLAIMS. IN MANY OTHER PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT CONTACT. CONCLUDING
IN SEVERAL PUBLIC TRANSIT
CONTACT. DO WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE AND I AM
ON THE LINE TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE HAS ABOUT THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
WAS THE- APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE IN YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY WE
WILL NOW LOOK TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY TWO OR THREE IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE HERE TO TESTIFY SEE
NO ONE WE WILL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM
TWELVE ONE TWELVE. WISHING TO
TESTIFY SEEN NO ONE THERE WE
WILL NOW GO TO- THE WITNESSES
WERE WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY. PLEASE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
QUEUE UP IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY PLEASE
PRESS. ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE ONE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS JIM WHITE'S ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT OF
MYSTEEL NOTED WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE SPONSORS FOR ALL OF
THE WORK DONE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL TO ADDRESS THE LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL. PLEASE LISTEN
SUPPORTIF A MAN BUT WITH THE
MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS PART IS
IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
WE URGE YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IF THERE ANY FURTHER LINES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE KNOWN FOR
THE KILLING UP VERY GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR DISCUSSION QUESTIONS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FAIR AND I
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
APPRECIATE THE GOOD JOB TODAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO QUOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUR VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHALL WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR PAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MEMBERS PLEASE
TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES IN
ORDER TO CAST A VOTE. SENATOR
HILL HI. SENATOR HILL. HI
CENTER MOREAU WELL NOW. SENATOR
MORALE NO CENTER JACKSON.
SENATOR MITCHELL. BY SENATOR
MITCHELL HI CENTER PAM BY
SENATOR PAN HI. WE WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBER AND- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
APPRECIATED. VERY MUCH I SEE MR
RODRIGUEZ IN THE AUDIENCE. WE
WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AND THAT IS- A. B. TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. PLEASE REFER AT YOUR
CONVENIENCE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS. MEMBERS OF
YOUR WHERE THERE'S A HUGE
SHORTAGE SHORTAGE OF LICENSED
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND
PRACTITIONERS IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. THIS HAS GONE ON
FOR A LONG TIME AND NOW IT'S
MORE CRITICAL BECAUSE OF COVERT
NINETEEN. AB TWENTY ONE ONE
FOUR SIMPLY PROVIDES MINIMUM
EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS TO CERTAIN
EMPLOYEES TO WORK. FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION EMPLOYER REGARDING
THE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE AND
DENTISTRY. THESE EMPLOYEES TO
WORK IN HIGHER EDUCATION TO GET
THE SKILLS NECESSARY FOR
LICENSEE ARE NOT AFFORDED BASIC
RIGHTS INCLUDING DUE PROCESS
REGARDING TERMINATION OF
EMPLOYMENT OR DISCIPLINE. A
DISCIPLINE OR TERMINATION THAT
COULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT FUTURE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
BECAUSE OF SOMETHING MINR THAT
UNRELATED TO CLINICAL PRACTICE
OR LICENSE ACADEMICS. BECAUSE
ONGOING CROSSES AND HEALTH CARE
TODAY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
MINOR SUBJECTIVE DECISIONS
DON'T HARM THE FUTURE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES ARE
PROFESSIONALS THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED TODAY. THESE
WORKS HAS SPENT MANY YEARS
LEARNING THE PRACTICE OF
MEDICINE AND DENTISTRY AND
SUBJECTIVE DECISIONS ON MINOR
MATTERS CAN MEAN WHETHER THEIR
ENTIRE CAREER IS OVER OR
WHETHER THEY CAN BE LICENSE TO
PRACTICE. TO ME THE TIME OF THE
BILL MAKES GREAT SENSE BECAUSE
I BELIEVE IT'S A LINE WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORT. EARLIER THIS
YEAR TO FAST TRACK THE
HEALTHCARE WORKER DURING
PIPELINE DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY AS
MICHELLE CASH OF SLU. AND TO
REPRESENTS WHO CAN PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND
ANSWER QUESTIONS I BELIEVE HER
AVAILABLE BY PHONE. THANK YOU A
MISS CASTRO YOU HAVE A TOTAL OF
YOUR WITNESSES FOUR MINUTES.
AFTER THAT YEAH UPDATED NEED TO
TREAT IT IT THAT IT NEEDED TO
BE UPDATED OKAY SO I. WANT
OKAY. EVEN IF YOU HAVE A
WITNESSES SUPPORT ON THE LINE I
ON. YOU HAVE THE MODERATOR
FLORIDA YOU HAVE A OF MICHELLE
OKAY ON THE IF YOU COULD MAYBE
IN THE PUBLIC. TELEGRAAF LINE.
WE DO NOT EVER REGISTERED BUT-
IF YOU ARE CONNECTED MISS
CASTER YOU CAN IDENTIFY
YOURSELF BY PRESSING STAR AND
THEN ZERO. AND I BELIEVE WE MAY
HAVE RELIED ON MUTED NOW. THANK
YOU CASTRO PLEASE BEGIN. AND
LOCAL. APOLOGIES ARE LINE IS
WITH AN OPERATOR. THURMOND
CASTER PLEASE GO AHEAD I'M GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS MICHELLE CASTRO
THE REPLACEMENT NATIONAL UNION
WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL- I'D LIKE YOU TO FOR MY
TIME TO DOCTOR ARE YOU MACAULAY
AND DR ANNA YAP HOWEVER AND
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
CAPS THANK YOU. YOU OTHER
WITNESSES WERE FULL OF FOUR
MINUTES REMAINING FOR THREE
MINUTES AND FIFTY. THEY ALSO
DID COMICAL HOST LINE SO WE
HAVE TO FIND THEM ON THE PUBLIC
LIFE. OKAY WITH THE MODERATOR
PLEASE PROMPT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
AND I DID NOT GET THEIR NAMES
BUT- MISTER RICH IF YOU COULD
SHE SAID THEIR NAMES IF A
WARRANT THEY KNOW WHO THEY ARE
THE LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IF THEY COULD PROP WHATEVER
PRODUCT YOU'RE GIVING THEM. THE
MODERATOR PLEASE GIVE THEM A
PROMPT. CERTAINLY IF YOU'VE
BEEN ASKED TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOUR LINE BY
PRESSING STAR AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THESE WOULD BE THE
LEAD WITNESSES GUESTS THANK YOU
MODERATOR. OKAY I DO BELIEVE
WE'VE LOCATED THEM I DO HAVE-
ONE ON THE LINE NOW PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE HAVE THE LINE OF IRONY
MCCAULEY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR LYNHAM HOLY
HI. COMMITTEE ON DISCIPLINE. OR
TERMINATION ARE NOT CRITICAL
ACADEMIC- IN OUR CAREERS.
INSTEAD WE TARGET
PROFESSIONALISM WHICH IS OFTEN
USED TO MEASURE PRESIDENTE
CAPABLE OF BEING A LICENSED
PHYSICIAN. PROFESSIONALISM AND
HARD TO DEFINE MEANS DIFFERENT
THINGS TO DIFFERENT PEOPLE IN
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENTS YET IN
OUR WORLD THE SUBJECT TO TURN
ON COMPLETION. OF THE WOMAN
COLOR I KNOW ABOUT THE WORD
PROFESSIONALISM AND BIAS ALL
TOO WELL IT CAN REFER TO A
DIFFERENT CULTURE ARE IN COLOR
OR THE WAY WE WEAR HAIR OR HOW
WE ADVOCATE. RECENTLY IN THE
JOURNAL OF VASCULAR MEDICINE
THE STUDY HAD THREE WHITE MALES
ADDITIONS MAKING A CULTURE
MEDIA PROFILES READING RESIDENT
CONDITION THAT QUOTE I'M
PROFESSIONAL BASED ON THEIR
SOCIAL MEDIA. WRITING THAT
FEMALE PHYSICIANS WHO ARE
BEATING HE'S ON VACATION
CALLING COSTS IN THE HOW DID IN
THEIR HAND OR ENGAGE IN
POLITICAL ADVOCACY WERE ALL
WAITED COACH AND PROFESSIONAL.
WELL I AM VERY HAPPY AND IN THE
LEADERSHIP OF MY PERSONALITY
WILL. I'M CONCERNED THAT MY
ADVOCACY HERE ACTUALLY BE SEEN
AS UNPROFESSIONAL BY THE LARGER
YOU SEE AND WE CAN'T RELY ON
HOPING WE HAVE BEEN PART AND B.
FAIR TO PROVIDERS WE NEED
PROTECTION FROM LOCAL. GIVE US
THE ABILITY TO SPEAK UP FOR THE
DVD WILL NEED A CO WORKER
ENDEMIC AND SAFELY BECAUSE
DOCTORS. AT THE ONE OF COLOR IN
ADDITION ADVOCATE. I KNOW WILL
BE A RETALIATED AGAINST FOR
DOING SO THERE WILL BE AN
IMPARTIAL VIEW OFFICER TO
CONSIDER ACTION TAKEN AGAINST.
THE PROTECTION IS NEEDED AS
SHOWN BY EMERGENCY POSITIONS ON
THE FEDERAL LEVEL ASKING FOR
LEGISLATION AS WELL ASKING FOR
DUE PROCESS. THE BILL DOES NOT
JEOPARDIZE OUR ABILITY TO
BECOME DOCTORS BUT INSTEAD
PROTECT. I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMAN RODRIGUEZ SO MUCH
FOR CHAMPION THIS BILL AND WE
HOPE THIS COMMITTEE WAS. BUILT
AT THE END. YES THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR CONSIDERING. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT. PLEASE
WAIT. HELLO MISTER KAREN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM DOCTOR
COOLEY LAST MONTH I GRADUATED
FROM UC DAVIS OF FAMILY
MEDICINE RESIDENCY PROGRAM
WHILE AT DAVIS AB HELPED START
A RESIDENT UNION WE ORGANIZED
OURSELVES OF BOYS AND A CULTURE
THAT IMPLEMENTED EXPLOITATIVE
AND BRIDGES WITH THE REGION
HIERARCHY AND A CULTURE OF
BULLYING AND HAZING THAT IS NOT
ONLY COMMONPLACE. THANK ARE
VULNERABLE AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
HIGHER WORKING FOUR FOUR HOURS
IN OUR WEEKS FOR LITTLE PAY
WELL. SHAKESPEARE'S ENGLAND.
YOU MIGHT. WHILE YOU IN THANK
YOU SEE I CAME THE HEART TO SEE
THAT I DID NOT A LOT TERM.
THERE BECAUSE WE WERE TREATED
WITH HOSTILITY AND DISRESPECT
BY HOSPITAL AND ACADEMIC.
LEADERSHIP AND HAD TO FIGHT TO
ACHIEVE THE MOST BASIC RIGHT.
IT'S A BUSINESS RESPECTFUL
TREATMENT OF. PHYSICIANS
VULNERABLE. OF I DECIDED I
COULD NOT TOLERATE IF YOU WERE
FIRE POSED GRADUATE AND
ACTIVELY EMPLOYEE OUTSIDE THE
AND WILL STARTING HAVE CLOSED.
CAREER OUT. STORY UNFORTUNATELY
NOT UNIQUE THIS IS WHY WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT RESIDENT
PHYSICIANS RIGHT TO DUE PROCESS
AS EASY HAS REFUSED TO
NEGOTIATE THEIR ARBITRATION
PROCESS FOR RESIDENTS ACROSS
MULTIPLE EASY THANKS TO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN. DESPITE THE
FACT THAT OVER FIFTY COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS RESIDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
NATION GUARANTEED THE- RIGHT.
NOT LOOK TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
MEETING. WHICH CALIFORNIA BACK
ARE ALL THERE AND AGREE WITH
THE MUSICIAN. EMPLOYMENT TO
PROCESS BUT WOULD NOT HAPPEN WE
ARE NOT LOOKING TO YOU TO MAKE
AN EMPLOYER DO ANYTHING. WE ARE
SIMPLY YOU TO STAND UP FOR
RESIDENT PHYSICIANS IN YOUR
STATE GLOBAL PANDEMIC AND WHICH
WE ARE ON THE FRONT LINES AND
COURT R. RIGHT PRESIDENTIAL
WORKERS. TO HAVE THE COURAGE TO
WORKERS RIGHT. WE THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD THE
URGENT I VOTE ON THE BILL ALL
RESIDENT PHYSICIANS IN THE UC
SYSTEM CAN GET THE DUE PROCESS
AND PROTECTION THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THOSE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE FOUR EIGHTY
TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN SHE NOONE.
IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT THERE IS NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. WE WILL NOW GO TO
THOSE WITNESSES WISHING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE OR
VISIT IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE FOURTEEN MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT THOSE. INDIVIDUALS IF
YOU WOULD. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO KEEP UP IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE WILL
GO TO LINE THREE ONE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS SARA FLOCKS. CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE TWO SIX EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR. CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MATT BROUGHT IN FROM
BEYOND THE TEAM AND THANK THANK
YOU. THE LINE TWO SIX SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TOM LOWER
WITH A CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION OFFERING
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU IF
THERE IS ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
COMING UP WE'RE GOOD THANK YOU
MODERATOR APPRECIATE THAT WE
WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION AND
THERE IS ONE LEAD- OPPOSITION
WITNESS- MICHAEL PETARD. WITH
YOU SEE- I BELIEVE YOU'LL HAVE
TO MISTER MODERATOR. A PROMPT
HIM AND CALLED HIM. UP FROM THE
SUPPORTERS LIST AS WE DID IN
THE SUPPORT. TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU MISTER REGARD TO- LIKE YOUR
LINE COULD YOU PLEASE PRESS
STAR AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER REGARD YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. VIEW GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MICHAEL THE DARK HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
EASY HAS AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON EIGHTY TWO
ONE ONE FOUR- AND I APPRECIATE
THE CHAIR. I UNDERSTAND GAUGE
ON THE BILL. CALAVERAS KRITIS
YOU DID NOT OF THE PROFESSIONAL
SPENT COUNTLESS HOURS IN GOOD
FAITH NEGOTIATIONS BUT A LOT
YOU MONTHS NOW WE OFFER A PATH
TO THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS
ALREADY AND CAN'T THINK
ARBITRATION ON SOME MATTERS. I
THINK DEFINING CLARIFY ACADEMIC.
MATTERS IN THE BILL. THE BILL
SHOULD HE BE OF THE DUAL NAY OF
MEDICAL RESIDENTS AND INTERNS.
THEY'RE BOTH OF VALUE TO WORK
FORCE FOR OUR HOSPITALS AND
CLINICS AROUND TE STATE. I
KNOW ALSO OUR STUDENTS. FAISON
ACADEMIC PROGRAM TYPICALLY THE
FINAL STEP IN A MEDICAL DOCTORS
EDUCATION BEFORE BECOMING LIFE.
AND BOARD CERTIFIED. UNIVERSITY
WOULD REMOVE OPPOSITION WITH AN
AMENDMENT THAT CLARIFIES THE
ADVANCEMENT THROUGH THE JIMMY
OF GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
TRAINING PROGRAM OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS THE RESIDENCY. THIS IS
AN ACADEMIC DECISION NOT
UNEMPLOYMENT MISSION IT'S A
REQUIREMENT OF OUR NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION STANDARDS IN
CRITICAL FOR PATIENT SAFETY. BY
THE WAY YOU FEEL TOWARDS OUR
GRADUATE MEDICAL STUDENT OR
RESIDENT NETWORK AND DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS ALREADY WHICH
HAVE BEEN AFFIRMED BY THE COURT
AND ARE REQUIRED AGAIN BY
ACCREDITATION AND OUR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS WITH- THE RESIDENT
THREE INTERNS. BUT ENGINE HAVE
MULTIPLE OP. TO THE- IN ORDER
AVOID ANY. REACHED THIS IN
MAKING. KNOW ADVERSE DECISIONS
OR SIGNIFICANT- ADMINISTRATIVE
DECISIONS. ARE MADE BY A SINGLE
FACULTY MEMBER ALONG. WITH WHY
THESE ISSUES SHOULD REMAIN AT
THE BARGAINING TABLE. BUT THE
UNIVERSITY ALSO NEED TO ENSURE
OUR ACADEMIC PHYSICIANS IN THE
GRADUATE STUDENT WHEN
NECESSARY. ENSURE THAT THEIR
ADVANCEMENT IS BASED ON A
VALUATION ANY ACADEMIC GRADUATE
EDUCATION PROGRAM. NOT BASED ON
EMPLOYMENT. FOR TO ENSURE SAFE
NOT HOW WORK ENVIRONMENT FOR.
ANOTHER STAFF AND THAT NOT TO
SAY THERE'S NO PLACE ARBITRARY.
BUT WE BELIEVE IT CLEARLY DRAWN
A LINE AROUND ACADEMIC
DECISIONS DO RESOLVE OUR
CONCERNS AND APPRECIATE THAT
THE BILL SIGNALED. BUT IT'S NOT
SUFFICIENT YET. UNIVERSITY THE
STATE'S LEADING MEDICAL
EDUCATION TRAINING INSTITUTION
OPPOSED TO TRYING TO DECISIONS
OVER WITHOUT. A CARD. FROM MY
ACADEMIC ADVANCEMENT TO AVOID
ANOTHER TRADITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE SEE
NO ONE HERE GOING TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN C. NO ONE THERE WE
WILL NOW. GO TO MOVE TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR FEUD PLEASE PROMPT
THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE.
JENNIFER IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO TO QUEUE UP
IN OPPOSITION AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN. WE HAVE NO AYE
QUEUING UP ATTHIS TIME VERY
GOOD THANK YOU MODERATOR VERY
MUCH FOR A GREAT JOB THIS
AFTERNOON- YOU HAVE A QUESTION
OR IF. STE MISTER REPRODUCTIVE
CLOSE. THE PHONE GREATER
QUESTION I'M SORRY SENATOR PAN
I DIDN'T. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AS AMERICA FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND I THINK IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL- I JUST
WANTTO ASK YOU OR THE SPONSORS
TO PERHAPS RESPOND TO WHAT YOU
SEE JUST TESTIFIED TO SO THE
VERY- THAT TESTIFIED NAY VOTE
HOPEFULLY GOT THIS RIGHT HE
SAID THE ONLY. MODIFICATION
THAT THEY'RE SEEKING IS- THAT
YOU SEE WITH THAT I GUESS
ADVANCE WHAT THEY CALLED VANCE
AND MAYBE PERHAPS YOU SEE
CLARIFIES ADVANCEMENT FROM YEAR
TO YEAR OR IS THAT COMPLETION
DECLARATION COMPLETION. WOULD
BE CONSIDERED AN ACADEMIC
MATTER. AND I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER THAT PERHAPS IS IT OKAY
TO. BRING THE UC REPRESENT BACK
ON TO CONFIRM I'VE GOTTEN WHAT
I SAID CORRECTLY SO HE PLEASE
CLARIFY WHAT YOU MEANT BY VANCE
MEANT. AND WITH THE END OF
THOSE CLASSIFIED AS AN ACADEMIC
MATTER WITH THAT REMOVES YOUR
OPPOSITION. MY LINE OPENS WITH
MICHAEL YES WE HEAR YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION-
SIMILAR PAN- WAY OF AGAIN AS A
TRY TO MENTION WE'VE AND
STANDING SHE ATION WITH THE
AUCKLAND. BUT LACKS NUMBER OF
MONTHS WE HAVE COME TO AGREE ON
OF. THE ISSUES THE ADVANCEMENT
IN THE ACADEMIC PROGRAM IS ONE
OF THE OUTSTANDING ISSUES AS
WELL AS- CONVERSATION AROUND A-
MORE YOUR DEFINITION OF ACTED
AND CLINICAL SO. YOU HAVE TO I
JUST WANT TO GET TO ANOTHER OF
WHAT YOU TOLD THE COMMITTEE
AND- AGAIN IF I'M WRONG PLEASE.
SO YOU I HEARD YOU SAY WHAT IS
THAT. IF ADVANCEMENT WAS
CLASSIFIED AS AN ACADEMIC
MATTER WHICH IN THIS BILL WOULD
THEREFORE MAKE IT YOU KNOW NOT
OUTSIDE OF- VIA DUE PROCESS.
THANK THEN YOU WOULD REMOVE
YOUR OPPOSITION IS THAT CORRECT
OR DID I HEAR COULD INCORRECTLY.
JANET RAP WITH THE REMAINDER OF
THE AGREEMENT THAT WE HAVE WITH
A HIGH. THE NEW UNION OFFICER.
OKAY I'M NOT SURE TO SAY YES OR
NO. I THINK THERE'S MORE THAN
ONE HALF AS PART OF A PACKAGE
OF EMPLOYMENT THAT INCLUDES THE
AND OTHER THINGS THAT WE DO
AGREE KAY SO IT'S ALL RIGHT SO
YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT OKAY I
THOUGHT YOU TESTIFIED THAT THAT
WAS THE ONE THING BUT OKAY ALL
RIGHT DOES. WANT A LOT- ITEMS
THAT WE HAVE WE SUBMITTED OUR
LETTER WITH A NUMBER OF- OKAY
JUSTIFYING YEARS NOW WE'VE GONE
THROUGH. ALL DIFFERENT THANK
YOU THANK YOU AYE DIVE AYE
MAYBE AND THIS HEARD AND- AND
ACTUALLY WASN'T SURE IF I'D BE
ALSO HELPFUL TO KNOW WHAT THE
DEFINITION ADVANCEMENT WAS WAS
A YEAR BY YEAR WAS ASSEMBLY
COMPLETION BUT OKAY. RIGHT. SO
I'M JUST GONNA GO BACK SERVE
THE FIRST ALL I JUST WANNA SAY
THAT YOU KNOW I AM. TALKING
ABOUT LIVES OF FOR AN ALLEGED I
WAS OF. FEW SEE FACULTY MEMBER
ENTITLED TO PROGRAM DIRECTOR I
OVERSAW THE RESIDENCY PROGRAMS.
AND PEDIATRICS OF UC DAVIS SELF
I KNOW I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
SIT ON THAT SIDE TO ACTUALLY
HAVE TO SIGN A LETTER SAYING
THAT THE RESIDENTS HAVE
COMPLETED THEIR TRAINING THAT
THEY ARE READY FOR INDEPENDENT
PRACTICE- YOU KNOW THIS IN
THREE YEARS A VERY STRUCTURED
TRAINING INTENSIVE TRAINING. TO
PREPARE THEM FOR PRACTICE AND-
SO CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND- SOME
OF UC'S CONCERNS. BUT THE SAME
TIME I ALSO NOTE THAT- ALL
RESIDENTS ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES- TAKING CARE OF PATIENTS-
THEY ARE. YOU KNOW THE REASON
THEY GET PAID IS BECAUSE
THEY'RE FOR DELIVERING VALUABLE
CLINICAL SERVICES AND CLINICAL
SERVICES THAT. NAY THIS
POSITIONS NOT ONLY THE LIVER
BUT WE ACTUALLY TRAIN THEM TO
BE ADVOCATES THE NEED TO BE
ADVOCATES FOR THE PATIENTS WHEN
YOU SEE A DOCTOR. YOU NEED TO
KNOW THAT DOCTORS CAN BE
ADVOCATING FOR YOU AND THAT'S
PART OF THAT TRAINING AND
SOCIALIZATION HAPPENS DURING
RESIDENCY. AND WE NEED TO ALLOW
THAT TO HAPPEN DURING
RESIDENCY. AND ALSO THEY SHOULD
NOT BE PUNISHED FOR DOING THAT
AND SOMETIMES THAT MAKES THE
INSTITUTION UNCOMFORTABLE.
RIGHT BECAUSE THEY NEED TO NOT
ONLY ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELVES
AND FOR THEIR PATIENTS AND I
KNOW THAT- YEAH I'VE SEEN HOUSE
STAFF- UNIONS AT COLLECTED
WORKS. HAVE HAVE OFTEN. TAKEN
ON THESE ISSUES IS BEING PART
OF NOT JUST ABOUT WELL WHAT OUR
OWN PAY AND SALARY SO FOR THE
TALKED ABOUT THE WORKING
CONDITIONS THAT ACTUALLY AFFECT
PATIENT CARE. AND I THINK THAT
IS IMPORTANT THEY HAVE THOSE
PROTECTIONS. SO WITH THAT I
KNOW SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY SAT
ON THE SB SIX WHAT THE OTHER
SIDE I DON'T LIKE TO THINK OF
TWO SIDES GETTING WE HAVE OUR
VALUES ARE TO. PROVIDE TO
FIGURE HOW TO PROVIDE EXCELLENT
PATIENT CARE. THAT I THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT WE PROVIDE THESE
BASIC PROTECTIONS FOR RESIDENTS
NOW I WOULD ENCOURAGE- THE
AUTHOR AND ALSO YOU MAY BE IF
WE CAN TRY TO CLARIFY. AND BILL
DISAPPOINTED I THOUGHT YOU SEE
HAD SAID THAT WE CAN RESOLVE
THIS ONE LAST THING WHICH I
THINK IS RESOLVABLE IT SOUNDS
LIKE NOW THERE'S A PACKAGE.
THAT SO- SO OF THOSE- BUT- YOU
KNOW THIS BILL DOES CLEARLY SAY
AND I REALIZE THERE MAY BE SOME
INTERPRETATION WISHES THAT
ACADEMIC MATTERS AND I
APPRECIATE THAT- SPONSORS BUT
THE SENATE. ACADEMIC AND
CLINICAL MATTERS. ARE NOT FAR
OUTSIDE. OF THIS SO THEY
RECOGNIZE THIS DUAL ROLE OF THE
RESIDENTS THAT WAS PENSION. AND
I APPRECIATE THAT THIS BILL
DOES. RECOGNISE THIS. YEAH IT'S
NOT THAT CAN BE A LITTLE HARD
TO THE LINE. BUT I DO BUT- THE
IT'S IMPORTANT WE PROVIDE THESE
PROTECT. AND SO CERTAINLY I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
SPELLING BEE HAVING TO MOVE IT
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. AND I
ENCOURAGE THOSE CONTINUING A
DISCUSSION BETWEEN YOU SEE AND
THE- SPONSORS OF THIS BILL- AND
TRYING TO SEE WHERE THEY CAN
TRY TO FINE TUNE- SOME OF THESE
ISSUES BUT- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION CONTINUE MIL FORD.
AND IN THE END PROVIDE. DUE
PROCESS PROTECTIONS FOR
RESIDENTS ESPECIALLY FOR
MATTERS RELATED RELATING TO-
THE WORK. PLACE CONDITIONS. AND
ALSO THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO
ADVOCATE BOTH FOR THEMSELVES
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR THEIR
PATIENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU DR PAN SENATOR
JACKSON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
TO HAVE BEEN. ANGUISHING OVER
THIS BILL AND- I MAY NOT BE
TOTALLY UNDERSTANDING. WHAT THE
ISSUES ARE SO IF MICHAEL YOU'RE
STILL ON THE PHONE IF YOU
COULD. ASSIST FIRST OF ALL WHAT
I HEARD IS THAT IF YOU COULD
RESOLVE THIS ADVANCEMENT ISSUE.
THAT YOU HAVE RESOLVED A NUMBER
OF OTHER ISSUES AS I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S BEEN A SIGNIFICANT TO
GO SHE ATION. SIGNIFICANT
MOVEMENT WHAT I UNDERSTOOD YOU
SAYING IS THOSE ISSUES ARE
RESOLVED. AND THAT HAVE A UPON
BY BOTH PARTIES THAT THIS ISSUE
OF ADVANCEMENT IS THE ONLY
REMAINING- ISSUES IS THAT
CORRECT. YES THAT IS CORRECT
SENATOR OKAY SO SENATOR PAN I
DO I THINK THERE WAS A
CONFUSION THERE THAT IF THIS
ISSUE CAN GET RESOLVED THE
OTHERS HAVE ALREADY RESOLVED
THAT THERE THAT TOSE ARE
ESSENTIALLY IF YOU WILL OFF THE
TABLE NOW IS THAT RIGHT MICHAEL.
YEAH THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
BASED ON CONVERSATION I HAD
WITH MISS CASTRO THIS MORNING.
ALL RIGHT SO THAT THERE'S
AGREEMENT ON EVERYTHING BUT
THIS ONE ISSUE I'M NOT SURE I'M
REALLY CLEAR ON WHAT THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS YEAR'S BUT
PERHAPS I CAN GET TO IT BY
ASKING A COUPLE OTHER QUESTIONS
ONE. IS THE POSITION THE
UNIVERSITY HAD TAKEN IS THAT
THEY NEED TO BE THE FINAL
DECISION MAKER IN ORDER TO
RETAIN. THEIR ACCREDITATION IS
THAT ACCURATE OR IS THAT OF
CONCERN IN OTHER WORDS DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT THIS MAY CREATE A
PROBLEM OR IS IT CLEAR THAT IT
WILL CREATE A PROBLEM IN TERMS
OF THE UNIVERSITY MAINTAINING
ITS NATIONAL ACCREDITATION. HI
YEAH THIS IS MICHAEL AGAIN
THROUGH THE STATE YOU CAN ONLY
GO BASED ON- YOU KNOW WHAT THE
ACCREDITATION COUNCIL AND BURNS
THE MEDICAL EDUCATION. REQUIRES
AGAIN THIS IS A QUORUM
REQUIREMENT FROM ACGME. IT SAYS
THE PROGRAM DIRECTORS OF OUR-
YOU KNOW OUR ACADEMIC POSITION
MUST HAVE RESPONSIBILITY I'M
READING FROM THEIR
REQUIREMENTS. YOU MUST HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY SORRY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR SOME OTHER
THINGS INCLUDING THE EVALUATION
AND PROMOTION OUR RESIDENTS.
AND DISCIPLINARY ACTION. THE
OPRAH MARKERS. WE KNOW AS I
UNDERSTAND FROM TALKING TO OUR
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
DEAN- WE ARE REQUIRED UNDER OUR
ACCREDITATION TO CONTINUE
HAVING THAT DIRECT. DIRECT
FEEDBACK ON THE VALUATION OF
THE PROMOTIONAL DANCED IN A
RESIDENTS GROUP GME PROGRAM IN
OUR FEAR NOW ONE OF THE FEARS
IS THAT THE ONE AB TWO ONE ONE
FOUR COULD RESULT IN AN
ARBITRATOR OVERTURNING OR
NAVIGATION OVERTURNING. AN
ACADEMIC JOHN. AND THAT COULD
LEAD TO ADDRESS OUTCOMES FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE. ALL RIGHT AND
HOW DOES THIS ADVANCEMENT- A
CONCEPT THAT THE SENATOR PAN
WAS TALKING ABOUT IMPACT THAT
SITUATION. SURE WE HAVE SHARED
LANGUAGE WITH COMMITTEE STAFF
WHAT THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR
DOCTORS TO CLARIFY THE ACADEMIC
AND CLINICAL MATTERS WHICH IS
IN THE NOBEL MEANS THOSE
MATTERS THAT RELATE TO AN
EMPLOYEE'S ADVANCEMENT BROUGH.
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE ADDING
LANGUAGE WAY ACQUISITION OF
CORE COMPETENCIES IN A JAMMY
PROGRAM. SO THIS WAY WE CAN.
OUR DATA IS TO PROVIDE OPTION
FOR ARBITRATION NEXT WE ALREADY
HAVE ARBITRATION OPTIONS TO OUR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT. THAT MAKING SURE
THAT A RESIDENT DOESN'T
COMPETING YEAR OR DOESN'T
COMPLETE THEIR PROGRAM THROUGH
ARBITRATION BUT THROUGH MEETING
ACADEMIC REQUIREMENTS OF THE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM. OKAY I
DON'T KNOW IF THE IF THE CENTER
PAN HAS ANY THOUGHTS ON ON THAT
BUT LET ME JUST TELL YOU WHAT
MY OTHER CONCERN. IS THIS
NOTION OF RETALIATION- WHEN IS
SOMETHING A YEAR- AN ACADEMIC
MATTER AND WHEN IS IT NOT SO
LET US SAY THAT WE HAD A
STUDENT YOU HAVE A STUDENT- WHO
IS EXPRESSING SOME CONCERN AND
CONSTERNATION ABOUT THE LACK OF
THE STATE PPVS OR A PROTOCOL
BEING USED WITH COLVIN. AND
CHALLENGED US SOME DECISION-
THERE IS A POSSIBILITY I DON'T
KNOW HOW LIKELY IT WOULD BE BUT
CERTAINLY A POSSIBILITY THAT
THAT PERSON COULD AND SHOP FOR
A RETALIATION. BOB HIS
SUPERVISOR I FELT THAT THEY
WERE ADELINE. THEY SHOULD THE
SAID THAT THAT THAT THAT WASN'T
APPROPRIATE WHAT PROTECTIONS
ARE OFFERED SO THAT IF THERE IS
SUCH A CHALLENGE TO THE POWERS
THAT BE. THAT THERE WOULD BE IN
PLACE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT A
DOCTOR THAT DOCTOR OBJECTING TO
A PROCEDURE OR PROCESS GOING
ON. WOULD BE PROTECTED FROM AN
ACT OF RETALIATION BY THOSE
SUPERVISORS WHO ARE ACTUALLY
THE ONES MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT
ACADEMIC. AND THAT THE
REQUESTED WE HAVE THE
UNIVERSITY HAS THAT EACH OF
OUR- FIVE GMT LAW PROGRAMS-
EXTENSIVE HANDBOOKS AND- RALPH
AND AS I SAID DO YOU PROCESS
THAT IN A- BY THE COURTS AND AS
WE- BY A ACCREDITATION. TO
HANDLE THESE MATTERS AGAIN NO
SINGLE PERSON AND-
SIGNIFICANTLY DISAPPOINTED-
RESIDENTS ARE IN TURN BY
THEMSELVES INCLUDING FOR ALLEGE
RETALIATION. YES MATTERS
AVAILABLE FOR D. OR PANELS OF
THESE AND OTHER- UNDER- NOT.
NOT. CONNECTED PARTY SOMETIMES
ARE YOU READY THAN AND I FEEL
YEAH. I ALSO ISSUES AROUND. AND
RETALIATES OF WORK SAFETY ARE
MATTERS THAT CAN BE PRETTY
COMPANY HANDLED AT OSHA. IF
THAT IF YOU'RE GONNA. SO ARE
YOU SUGGESTING THEN THAT THERE
WOULD BE NO ROLE FOR THE UNION
TO COME IN AND TO REPRESENT
THAT INDIVIDUAL IN ONE OF THESE
APPELLATE ACTIONS OR NOT THIS
IS REALLY TECHNICALLY APPELLATE
BUT IN AN APPEAL PROCEEDING.
WITH THAT WHAT. WHY WOULD THAT
NOT BE APPROPRIATE. WELL I'M
NOT SAYING THAT RETALIATES I
DON'T THINK OPPOSITION THAT LET
YOUR TELEVISION ON THE CONCEPT
OF THIS BILL SHOULDN'T GO TO
ARBITRATION AGAIN WE'RE TRYING
TO OFFER A PATH WHERE WE THINK
ITEMS COULD GO TO ARBITRATION
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE ACADEMIC. DECISION MAKING
IS MORE CLEARLY AND SQUARELY
DEFINED IN THE STATUTE. BUT BUT
WOULD YOU LET MY LAST QUESTION
I APOLOGIZE MISTER CHAIR BUT-
ARE YOU SUGGESTING THEN THAT
SOMEONE WHO CLAIMS THAT THEY
WERE BEING- DENIED. THE ABILITY
TO CAN TO ADVANCE- ON A CLAIM
OF ACADEMIC- INFERIOR- ACTIVITY
OR YOU KNOW. COMPETENCE OR
WHATEVER- THAT IF THEY SAY NO
THIS IS IN RETALIATION FOR
SOMETHING THAT THEY WOULD NOT
HAVE THE RIGHT TO APPEAL THAT
DENIAL OF ADVANCEMENT- IF THE
CLAIM IS MADE THAT IT WAS MADE
OUT FOR MEDICAL REASONS. BUT
THE BUT THE DOCTOR THE- INTERN
OF THE INTERNAL YOU KNOW.
RECIPIENT IS SAYING BUT I'VE
BEEN DIVING COMPANY AND THIS IS
JUST RETALIATION WHAT HAPPENS
TO THAT PERSON. HOW DO THEY GO
AHEAD AND- RESOLVE THAT DISPUTE.
AND BE ABLE TO ASSERT THAT
CLAIM. CURRENTLY YOU ARE UNDER
THE PROPOSAL. WELL WHAT ARE
UNDER THE PROPOSAL- WHAT ARE
YOU WILLING TO DO WITH THAT. IN
THIS IN THIS LEGISLATION OR DO
YOU FEEL THAT CURRENTLY- THE
IT'S PERFECTLY ADEQUATELY TAKEN
CARE OFF. I GUESS I WOULD NOT I
WOULD NOT IS THAT YOU KNOW HE
CONSULTED WITH SOME OF. OUR
PRACTITIONERS IN THE SORRY I
DON'T REALLY. KNOW THE ENTIRETY
OF THE IN THE MOUTH BUT HOW ARE
A DISCIPLINARY PROCEDURES
HANDLE A MATTER LIKE THAT. ONE
THAT RETALIATES. CLAIMS WRITTEN
OF WHAT THE BLOWER PROTECTION
START EXTEND TO A MEDICAL
RESIDENT IN TURN. IN THIS
CONTEXT- THE EVEN AFTER THE
BILL. SO I FEEL CONFIDENT THAT
YOU KNOW AREN'T NEEDED UNDER
CURRENT LAW TO PROTECT AGAINST
RETALIATION AGAINST FOR
WORKPLACE SAFETY AND WHAT THE
BLOWER ISSUES IS THINGS ARE.
PRETTY EXTENSIVELY UNDERSTOOD
AND HANDLED IN CALIFORNIA. YEAH
AND I. FEEL CONFIDENT SAYING
THAT- THE CURRENT MEDICAL
EVIDENCE NATIONALLY COVER.
BOTTLES LIKE. I THANK YOU AND
PERHAPS US PAN YOU MIGHT
ADDRESS OF FOR MY EDIFICATION
BECAUSE I'M AT POINT I'M GONNA
CHIU STAY OFF THE BILL- RESERVE
MY ULTIMATE VOTE- AS THIS GOES
FORWARD- BUT THE ISSUE OF
ADVANCEMENT IT SOUNDS TO ME
LIKE THERE IS A PATH HERE. FOR
SOME AGREEMENT THAT I FRANKLY
I'M NOT TOTALLY. UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THE SIGNIFICANCE OR WHAT
ADVANCEMENT IS AS YOU'RE
DEFINING IT YOU KNOW YOU'RE THE
DOCU BEEN ON BOTH SIDES OF THIS
I'M JUST A CORAL COUNTRY
LAWYER- BUT I'D CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE ANY GUIDANCE.
AND THANK. YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE. THANK YOU YES
SIR CENTER PAN. THANK YOU
THROUGH THE CHAIR- I'D- I
PREACH MY GOOD FRIEND- CENTER
JACKSON'S- SET OF QUESTIONS
AND- I GUESS MY- AND I WOULD
TRY FOR FULL DISCLOSURE I
ACTUALLY AM A PAST MEMBER OF
THE ACCREDITATION BODY I SERVED
ON THE BOARD FOR THE
ACCREDITING COUNCIL GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION WHICH
OVERSEES ALL OF RESIDENCY
EDUCATION AND UNITED STATES- SO
I GUESS I CAN CLAIM SOME
FAMILIARITY WITH THEIR POLICIES
AND- RULES AND- SO. CERTAINLY I
THINK THE- IT IS SOMETHING TO
TALK ABOUT BUT I I'M NOT SURE I
ENTIRELY- AGREE WITH THE
OPPONENTS IN TERMS OF THE RISKS
TO DEGRADATION OF THE UC
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS- BUT AGAIN I
AM A FORMER MEMBER OF THAT
BOARD AND THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THAT
ORGANIZATION AT THIS TIME- YOU
KNOW I DO THINK THAT THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT CONVERSATION
CONTINUES I ONLY HOPED
COMMITTEE I'M MOVES OUT TODAY
BECAUSE OTHERWISE IF WE DON'T
THAT THAT THAT CONVERSATION
CEASES. MMHM AND THE RESIDENTS
ARE ON THE FRONT RIGHT NOW
TODAY SO WE PUT IT OFF THEY'RE
STILL ON THE FRONT LINES STILL
BE TAKEN CARE CO THE PATIENCE
YOU KNOW ON UNTIL WHENEVER WE
CAN RE YOU KNOW RE EXAMINE THIS
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT IT'S
TIMELY THAT WE ADDRESS THIS-
TODAY AND- THIS YEAR- SO I JUST
WANT TO PAY THAT. I GUESS WHAT
I WOULD SAY IS THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S A BALANCE AND I DO
THINK THAT. YOU ARE WORKING
TOWARD THAT BALANCE- PERHAPS I
DON'T KNOW WHETHER YOU ARE
PERHAPS THE SPONSOR MIGHT WANT
TO RESPOND. AND IT SURE YOU CAN
TO IN TERMS OF I DON'T KNOW
WHAT MY TO QUESTION YOUR PLANE
TO ASK IN TERMS OF DISCUSSION
THE COMMITTEE. TO PERHAPS
RESPOND A LITTLE BIT TO WHAT.
HE'S CONCERNS OF ADVANCE TERMS
OF WHAT THE- DISCUSSIONS HAVE
BEEN- IN RELATION TO. WHAT THE-
THERE'S ARE YOU HAVE BEEN
WILLING YES THEY HAVE BEEN
WILLING TO GRANT I KNOW YOU'VE
CARVED OUT ACADEMIC BUT IN
TERMS OF SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSING THE ADVANCEMENT
ISSUE THAT YOU SEE HAS POINTED
OUT AS BEING THEIR MAIN CONCERN
AT THIS POINT. ALSO WITHOUT
SAID YOU KNOW MYSELF ALONG WITH
THE SPONSOR BEEN WORKING QUITE
A BIT WITH OPPOSITION TO
ADDRESS WITH OTHER ISSUES. NO
FORGERY ARE THERE ARE SOME
DISCUSSIONS MAY JUST RECENTLY
REGARDING NEGOTIATIONS BUT WE
DIDN'T GET THAT LANGUAGE IN
TIME TO BE BROUGHT TO TODAY'S
COMMISSION- COMMITTEE. BUT LOOK
FOR HOPEFULLY THIS BILL GETS
OUT THAT WE CAN ADDRESS IT IN
THE NEXT ONE- WITHOUT I THINK
OUR SPONSOR A MICHELLE. STILL
BE ON THE LINE MAYBE CHECK IT
OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE.
REGARDING THE THING BEEN IT OUR
WAY OF THE OPPOSITE TO COME TO
BETTER PLACE WITH SO CASH WITH
YOUR THE LINE IF YOU COULD
BRING ALONG. RESPOND TO THAT.
YES CAN HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
OKAY GREAT- SO YEAH WE'VE BEEN
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE LAST
FEW WEEKS WITH THE UC AND WE
MADE SOME PROGRESS. WE HAD A
FEW THINGS OUTSTANDING
PRIMARILY DEALING WITH
TERMINATION AND NON RENEWAL
BUT- ABOUT A MEDICAL RESIDENT-
AS WELL AS THE BETTER DEFINING
ACADEMIC OR CLINICAL MATTERS
THE NOTION OF ADVANCEMENT
CHESTER ROAD THE PAST WEEKEND-
I WAS LOOKING AT THE AMENDMENTS
ADVANCED. FROM YOU SEE THAT WE
HAD PREVIOUSLY AND THE LAST FEW
WEEKS NOT TALK AT ALL ABOUT
ADVANCEMENT THAT IS A NEW
NOTION THAT WAS INTRODUCED. IN
THE LAST COUPLE DAYS- WE HAVE
BEEN LOOKING OUT THOSE HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED IN THE CHARLIE I
HAVE NOT HAD TIME TO FULLY DIED
THEM TALK WITH YOU ABOUT THE
COMMANDMENT. SO YOU KNOW
WORKING IT TALKING WITH. THEM
BUT- THE NOTION OF ADVANCEMENT.
A NEW CAR TO US THE ONLY BEEN
RATE AND LOCK UP DAYS BUT AGAIN
IF WE ARE HAPPY TO TALKING WITH
YOU SEE. TO SEE WHAT WE CAN.
REPUBLICAN IF I MAY JUST MAKE
ONE LESS MARK AND AT FRAZIER
CAN THOSE THE WHAT OTHER THING
I NOTICED JACKSON AND ASKED
ABOUT WELL WHAT ABOUT OTHER.
WAYS FOR PEOPLE TO SEEK REDRESS
ONE THING TO KEEP IN MIND IS
THAT AS AS POINTED OUT BY THE
TIME AND- THE- RESIDENT IS BOTH
SOMEONE WHO'S DELIVERING
HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND ALSO
SOME OF THE LEARNER WHICH MEANS
THERE ARE. ONLY INSTITUTION FOR
FIXED AMOUNT OF TIME. SOMETIMES
WHAT HAPPENS IS WHEN THEY FILE
A COMPLAINT DO EITHER WAIT THEM
OUT. OR BECAUSE OUR TRAINEE-
THEY'RE PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE
TO BECAUSE LANDS IS WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT STOPPING
SOMEONE'S ADVANCEMENT IT'S NOT
JUST THAT SOMEONE GOT A JOB AND
THEY'RE NOT PROMOTED. THEY EAT
THEY DON'T ADVANCE ESSENTIALLY
ANSWER CAREER. I MEAN THIS IS
CAREER ENDING A POTENTIALLY SO
I THINK WE NEED TO PUT IN
CONTEXT- WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
SOMEONE COULD FILE A COMPLAINT
IF IT TAKES LONGER TO COUPLE
YEARS THEY'RE READY TO EITHER
DON'T THE PROGRAM ORDER DOWN
THE CAREER. I THINK WE HAVE TO
PUT THAT INTO CONTEXT TO WHAT
WE THINK ABOUT WHAT OPTIONS ARE
ACTUALLY AVAILABLE TO RESIDENTS
WHEN THEY DO FILE COMPLAINTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
PENSIONER MITCHELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PLAN FOR
RAISING THAT POINT BECAUSE THE
CAREER ENDING ELEMENT ALSO AS I
UNDERSTOOD IT GIVEN THE FINITE
NUMBER OF RESIDENCES WE HAVE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS
BEEN AN ISSUE WE'VE ATTEMPTED
TO ADDRESS- AS A LEGISLATURE
FOR QUITE SOME TIME- EVEN THAT
IS CHALLENGING TO EVEN BE ABLE
TO IF YOU'RE NOT THERE THEN
FIND ANOTHER RESIDENCY. AND AS
A INSPIRED HAVE RESIDENCIES
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE LIKELIHOOD
OF THEM BEEN STAYING IN
CALIFORNIA GIVEN OUR DEARTH OF
PHONE POSITIONS COMPARED TO
POPULATION WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
LOSE ANYBODY AND SO THAT CAREER
ENDING ELEMENT I THINK IS
CRITICAL AS WELL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
MITCHELL AND I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION DISCUSSION BECAUSE
QUITE HELPFUL FOR GOING SENATOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REPAIRS WOULD
YOU LIKE. YES WITHOUT MUCH. THE
DISCO WILL TAKE A LOT AND TAKE.
WITH US HOPEFULLY WE THIS AND
GET OUT IN A DRAW IT IN THE-
COMMITTEE SO WITH OTHER FOR.
RIVAL THANKS THANK YOU VERY AND
IN I. BEEN IN IN SEARCH WE'VE A
LOT OF DISCUSSION AS A CA. AND
HIS STAFF. AND WITH THE
OPPONENTS AND PROPONENTS OF THE
OF THE LEGISLATION AND WE
CERTAINLY WANT. TO MAKE SURE
THERE IS DE PROCESS. BEFORE
ANYONE IS FIRED DISMISSED OR
DISCIPLINED IN ANY WAY AND-
THESE ROOM FOR PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
THAT. ARE IN A REALLY LOUD
NEUTRAL PROCESS TO APPEAL SOME
OF THE DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS
TODAY BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. WE DO IT AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT I
CAN'T GUARANTEE A VOTE IN THE
FUTURE UNLESS WE CAN. SOLVE
SOME OF THESE ISSUES THAT WERE
RAISED AND I DON'T KNOW IF THEY
WERE REYES TOTAL TO BUT I
THEY'VE BEEN. IN THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
COMMITTEE. THE ARBITRATION
PROCESS YOU KNOW AGENT REALLY
SHOULD BE USED AS A LAST RESORT
AS WE KNOW IT. WILL HOPEFULLY
WE CAN EXHAUST OTHER AVENUES
BEFORE IT TO THAT- AND IT
REALLY MUST BE LIMITED TO THOSE
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS AND YOU
KNOW NON CLINICAL AND- ACADEMIC
BASIS THE- PANEL. BE EXPANDED
TO INCLUDE A UC SELECTED AND AN
EMPLOYEE SELECTED
REPRESENTATIVE AND I DON'T THAT
HASN'T BEEN. THE CASE SO FAR
AND AS WAS MENTIONED. THE ISSUE
RELATED TO DEFINITIONS AROUND
ACADEMIC AND CLINICAL MATTERS-
AND DISCIPLINARY ACTION HOW
THAT'S DEFINED IS- I. IN
STRICTLY DIVINE DEFINED- AND
WHAT ACTIONS CAN BE CHALLENGED
NEEDS TO BE REALLY I THINK
SPECIFIED A LITTLE MORE SO. I
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT AND-
AND HOPEFULLY IN THE NEXT-
WEAKER SO WE CAN GET TO SOME
RESOLUTION ON THIS SHOW THAT
AS- DR PAN MENTION THIS IS
CRITICAL THIS IS IMPORTANT THIS
IS TIMELY AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT WE- HOPEFULLY WILL
BE I'LL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
ONLY GETS TO THE FLOOR SHOW UP.
AND WE HAVE A MORE I BELIEVE BY
SEN PAN. SO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MEMBERS PLEASE
TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES IN
ORDER TO CAST A VOTE SENATOR
HILL HI CENTER HILL HI CENTER
MORALE AROUND NO. CENTER MOREAU
NO SENATE JACKSON. ACTION NOT
VOTING CENTER JACKSON NOT
VOTING CENTER MITCHELL MITCHELL
HI ENTER MITCHELL HI. CENTER
PAN HI. PAN HI THE BILL HAS
WILL. TRIPLE H. PRETTY MUCH OF
ALL AND IT IS OUT THANK YOU. AT
BOTH HEADING FOR SECOND- WHAT
WE SHOULD AND SHOULD NOT. BY
THE BILL IS OUT WITH THREE
VOTES THANK YOU. YEAH THAT'S IT
WILL NOT A MYSTERY KISS YOU
COULD PRESENT TO MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB. TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU
AGAIN MYSTERIES PRISONERS THANK
YOU SB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN WORLD
OUR HOSPITALS PROVIDE ENSURE
EMPLOYEES USE. HE'S OR- FOR.
NOTE THAT YOU'RE CHARGED OUR
OWN OF THE SHOCK LACK OF SUPPLY
AND ALSO. THIS BILL RICK THESE
EMPLOYERS MAINTAIN A SIX MONTH
STOCKPILE OF NEW UNEXPIRED PP
AND PROVIDE AN INVERTER TO CAL
OSHA UPON REQUEST. FROM MY
NURSES AND HEALTH CARE WORKERS
SCREEN PATIENTS WITH INFECTIOUS
DISEASE ARCHBALD TO THE HIGHEST
RISK OF INFECTION BECAUSE OF
THEIR CLOSE FREQUENT CONTACT
WITH PATIENTS. IT'S WATER
PROTECT THESE EMPLOYEES BY
ENSURING THEY HAVE LIFESAVING
EQUIPMENT AVAILABLE TO USE.
TERM DRAWN BY CRITICIZING ON
BEHALF OF THE SPONSOR THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
OUR FORECAST FOR A VOTE. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
RODRIGUEZ WE DO HAVE TO SHOULD
LEAD SUPPORT ACTUALLY OF ONE
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES-
CREDENTIALING LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE ADVOCATE FOR THE-
NURSES. YOU WILL HAVE FOUR
MINUTES. PLEASE PROCEED MR ONE.
THANK YOU CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS SHARE I'M PERCENT
pCALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
PROUD SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN. AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN IS BOTTLE
POLICY THAT WILL PROTECT
WORKERS AT THE PACK LEVEL PAN
REGIONS AND BEYOND THE
PANDEMIC. THIS MEASURE
RECOGNIZES THE NURSES AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE WORKERS WERE ON THE
FRONT LINE NEED PROTECTION YOU
HAVE ACCESS. AND DEVICE HERE TO
PROTECT THEM. ALL OVER EIGHTY
MILLION NINETY FIVE RESPIRATORS
HAVE BEEN DISTRIBUTED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SINCE MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY. NURSES AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE WORKERS HAVE SEEN
IMPACT OF HIS DISTRIBUTION IN
THERE YOU. IN MANY CASES
EMPLOYERS HAVE LOCKED UP. OR
RATIONED IN NINETY BY
RESPIRATORS WE NURSES AND OTHER
HEALTH CARE WORKERS
UNPROTECTED. NURSES AND
HEALTHCARE WORKERS HAVE BEEN
TOLD TO REUSE WE USE SINGLE USE
P. P. ALTHOUGH IN SOME CASES
NURSES HAVE BEEN DISCIPLINED
FOR BRINGING IN THEIR OWN P. P.
OR DISCIPLINE COMMANDING THAT
THE APPROPRIATE. BE PROVIDING
WHEN COPD IN POSITIVE PATIENT.
pINDUSTRY SUBSCRIBE TO WHAT IS
KNOWN AS JUST IN TIME BUSINESS
METHODS INCLUDING JUSTIN TIME
STAFFING AND IN TIME PURCHASING
OF SUPPLIES. THEY TAKING A
CALCULATED RISK BECAUSE WE HAVE
A PROFIT DRIVEN HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. AND CONSEQUENTLY THE
HOSPITALS TO GAMBLE RELATIVE TO
HOW MUCH B. B. TO HAVE HOW MUCH
THEY HAVE IN PREPARATION FOR
THE EVENT SUCH AS THIS
PANDEMIC. NOW THIS IS DESPITE
THE FACT THAT BOTH THE US
DEPARTMENT. OF LABOR. AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES HAVE
ENCOURAGE EMPLOYERS. TO
STOCKPILE PEE PEE IN IT AND THE
BULLPEN. BECAUSE MANUFACTURING
CAPACITY AT THE TIME OF BREAK.
MATTER PANDA. FINALLY AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVEN IN. WE WORKERS IN
THE ARE SECTOR. THE PROVIDE
THAT PROVIDE PROVIDER PATIENT
CARE IN THE HOSPITAL SETTING TO
PROVIDE AND ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYEES USED FOR PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT TO PROTECT
SUCH EMPLOYEES. THIS MEASURE
ALSO REQUIRES THE SAME
EMPLOYERS TO MAINTAIN A
STOCKPILE OF ON EXPIRED AND
UNUSED PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT IN THE AMOUNT EQUAL
TO SIX MONTHS OF NORMAL
CONSUMPTION. ADDITIONALLY
EMPLOYERS ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE AN INVENTORY OF THEIR
STOCKPILE TO CULTURE UPON
REQUEST. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS
HAVE BEEN CALCULATING AND
REPORTING PP SUPPLY AND NEED TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH DALY. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE NOW
REPORTING THIS DATA JUST THREE
TIMES PER WEEK. THIS REPORT
SUBMITTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATE SOCIALLY
ASSOCIATION CONTAINS A DETAILED
LIST OF THE SPECIFIC PP
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS HAVE ON
HAND AND ALSO NEED. TO PROTECT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS FROM THE
SPREAD OF THE NOROVIRUS SUCH AS
CO IN NINETEEN. ADDITIONALLY AB
THERE TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
INSURE THAT AN EMPLOYER WHO
VIOLATES THE STOCKPILE
REQUIREMENT SHALL BE ASSESSED A
CIVIL PENALTY OF UP TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR EACH
VIOLATION TWENTY CURRENT
CALIFORNIA. REGULATORS BETWEEN
THIRTY SEVEN AND A THAT PUTS
FORTH. PROVISION THAT WILL
IMPROVE THE SAFETY OF OUR AND
OTHER HEALTHCARE WORKERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
COLLABORATIVE WORK WITH SENATOR
PAN TO ADDRESS CONCERNS RELATED
TO ENFORCEMENT NPP SUPPLY
CHAINS OR JUST OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF COMMENTS. AND
US AND YOU GET TO THE
DICTIONARY COMMENTS OF THE
ANALYSIS WE THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FOR AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS.
TO SAVE LIVES NOW IF YOU. THANK
YOU AND I AM AVAILABLE ONLINE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
THANK YOU MISTER LANG WILL NOW
LOOK TO THOSE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN C. NO ONE. GOING
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE IS THERE
ANYONE IN ROOM ONE NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE SHOULD NOW WE
WILL MOVE TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY V. THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE UNSERVED
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVEN PLEASE. PLEASE
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO QUEUE
UP IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
WILL GO FIRST TO LINE TWO SIX
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATT BROUGHT
ON THE AFTER THE TEAMSTERS AND
ENGINEERS IN SCIENTIFIC
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. TWO EIGHT THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND MEMBERS DADDY
GRANDMA WITH UFCW WESTERN
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE TWO SEVEN SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO EXPORT THANK YOU. IF THERE
ANY FURTHER INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO QUEUE UP IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE KNOWN FOR THE
COMING UP- THANK YOU MODERATOR
APPRECIATE THE GOOD WORK WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE LEAD
OPPOSITION. FOR AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN AND THAT IS
KATHERINE SCOTT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
SCOTT THE FLOOR IS YOURS. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON MATURE MEMBERS I
CANNOT LOOK OUT WITH THE.
EVERYTHING ACROSS A LITTLE
THERE REALLY ISN'T ANY MORE
THAN THE HEALTH AND SAFETY ALL
AND THE PROVISION OF P. P. FOR
ALL HEALTHCARE WORKERS IS NOT A
MATTER OF DESIRE ON BUDGET BUT
REALLY THE REALITY OF THE
MARKET. WE HAVE WORKED REALLY
HARD TO SECURE PEOPLE FOR
FRONTLINE CAREGIVERS DURING
THIS CRISIS THERE ARE STILL.
GLOBAL SHORTAGE DUE TO A NUMBER
OF FACTORS IF YOU ARE MAYBE
WHERE OVERSEAS NINE. RAMA
CURIAL SHORTAGE MATHIS SPIKE
THE DEMAND AN EXPONENTIALLY
HIGH UTILIZATION RATE SWORDFISH
THE HOSPITAL'S ALLOCATE PP
BASED ON WORK THANK HIGHEST.
RISK ACCORDANCE WITH THE W. H.
O. P. P. E. PH THANK HOW SHOULD
I. WE'RE NOT OVERLOOKED AND
PROTECT OUR WORK. COME BACK
SHORTAGE AND WE'RE DOING OUR
THIRTY CHALLENGE TRYING TO
ENSURE. THAT HIGH RISK
PROCEDURES ARE COVERED. AND
EMPLOYEES ARE UNCOVERED THE PPV.
WE HAVE LEARNED FROM ON THE
COMPLETION OF PP BEING. WE HAVE
LEARNED THAT THE FIGHTING COULD
BE KEY- IT IS. TO BE. CHANGE
FROM REAL TIME INVENTORY ON
HAND I THINK WE CAN AGREE ON
THAT I'M NOT MORE FACTOR- FOR
MANUFACTURING APPROACHES THE
DISTRIBUTION YOUR REAR AXE
WRITTEN PROCUREMENT AND
UTILIZATION OF THE FINAL
COMMITMENTS ARE WORKING TO FIND
WAYS TO MAXIMIZE THE
AVAILABILITY HOWEVER BUT IT'S
NOT SIMPLY A BY MORE- TALK
ABOUT. WE NEED TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY GOING FORWARD ABOUT
HOW TO MAKE SURE ALL HEALTH
CARE WORKERS WHETHER THEY- WORK
IN A HOSPITAL SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY DENTIST OFFICE OR
OTHER WORKPLACE HAVE WHAT THEY
NEED TO BE SPENT. WHILE I'M
THRILLED THAT MANDATE THE
PSYCHOLOGY OF EATING LIKE A
VIABLE SOLUTION IN FACT IT
COULD UNDERMINE THE VERY
PURPOSE. ONE OF THE KEY LESSONS
FROM THE ENDEMIC IS THAT THERE
WILL LIKELY BE HOT SPOT SURE
THERE ARE HOT SPOTS DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND DEMAND. REQUIRED
RAPID FLEXIBILITY TO SHIFT
LIMITED RESOURCES BETWEEN
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS AND BETWEEN
CARE FACILITY. IF THE NURSING
HOME. DESPERATELY NEED TP A
HOSPITAL WOULD NEED TO DENY THE
REQUEST IF THIS BILL WERE TO
MOVE FORWARD- IN FEAR OF
RUNNING AFOUL OF THE LEGAL
MANDATE. WHEN IT COMES TO THE
SHORTAGE OF THE- COMPLEX
STORAGE AND USE THE PP LARGE
STOCKPILES ARE NOT AN EFFICIENT
WAY TO MANAGE THE SLIPPERS. FOR
MANY. CURRENT CONDITIONS. I'M
TESTING IT. BAKER SPELL OF
JANUARY ONE TWO TWENTY ONE
CREATE CONDITIONS WE WILL NOT
BE ON THE OTHER OF THE AND THEN
WE CAN. THE CARD THE STARKEY
DURING THE TIME WITHOUT
CONSIDERATION OF BRUTALIZATION
MUTUAL AID THAT MARKED THE
FINAL PUTTING CRITICAL STRAIN
ON THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND ON THE
MARKET. DOCTORS ANOTHER SOCIAL
WORKERS STRUGGLE TO GET FREAKY
OKAY SHORTNESS AND HIGHER
OPERATING COSTS. VERY GOOD THAT
WILL BE EXASPERATED BY
HOSPITALS ARE REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN SUCH LARGE ARMS. ONLY
THREE FOR THE MAMMOGRAM USES
THE CAN DOWN AND NOW. CURRENTLY
CALL ADDRESS CLOSE THE STORE
YOU CAN COME NOT. AT A LATER
TIME. THE BILL PROHIBITION ON
THE USE YOU CAN HAVE A LOT
CLOSE FOR SOUTH THE- THANK YOU
CAN HAVE A HAVEN'T THEY COULD.
FOR PROPERLY. AS WELL TEACHER
HOW TO MORE WITH THE- OF DOCTOR
THOUGH HE AND HIS STAFF THANK
YOU BELIEVE THAT THERE IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE REAL. TO THE
STOCKPILE. OF THE ONGOING TO-
BUT THE INVENTORY HOSPITAL
PATH. IT'S IMPORTANT BALANCE
BETWEEN HOW WE MANAGE POTENTIAL
INVENTORY- AND WHERE WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE ACADEMIC AND
WE- ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TRIGGER. DATE BY THE- I'M THE
WELL. WE CONTINUE TO FACE FRONT
OF COLD AND MUST WORK WITH THE
COUNTY AND HEALTHCARE TO FILL
AND EMPLOYEES AT LARGE DOUBLES
TRAINING THE TERMINAL BACK PLAN
FOR SHORTAGE KITCHEN FOR THESE
REASONS. THE WORD CURRENTLY
PRINT OF. EIGHTY TWO FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU MISS CUT
WILL NOW GO THOSE IN OFFICE. OF
AB FIVE THIRTIES IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- OH THREE SEEING NO ONE WE
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE IS
THERE ANYONE IN ROOM TWO OH ONE
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. TO NOW WE WILL GO TO
THE- WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
RIVERS- IF YOU WOULD PLEASE.
THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO FIVE
OPPOSITION OF E. D. FIVE THIRTY
SO. PLEASE IT IS AN IMMINENT
LIKE YOU OPEN. TO BE TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
IT'LL GO TO LINE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. PICTURE NUMBERS
CAñADA COTTO ON BEHALF.
HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP FORUM WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ABOUT SELLING A
COMMON. FEATURE OKAY THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS WE ALSO HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION AND
WHEN I WENT OUR COMMENTS WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU. NINE THREE TWO ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURKE THEIR
BREAD ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT ALSO WITH A
CUSTOMER COMMENDED DIVISION WE
WOULD ALIGN OUR COMMITMENT AS A
C. H. I. THANK. YOU ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO KEEP UP IN
OPPOSITION TO. TWO FIVE THERE
SEVEN PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO FOR
THE LIGHT COMING UP. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR AND- BRINGING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AFTER
HEARING ALL THE SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES DR GRANT.
I THANK YOU AND I WILL FOR SO I
THINK A SEPARATE BIGGEST SANDY
CALIFORNIA. ASSOCIATION FOR
WORK. THAT ME AND- MY RESPONSE
OR MY ABILITY ARE YOU. ON. A
ISSUE AND- THE CALL PATIENT
WERE. WE'RE DOING A THINK I ON
THE THAT WE'RE TOGETHER THINK
ADDRESS MANY OF THESE THE OP.
BROUGHT UP YES I AGREE THAT-
HOSPITALS AREN'T THE SOLE-
DEMAND PER PP AND WORK IN
HOSPITALS THAT'S WHY IN MY BILL
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. HE ALSO
STATE POWER. THANK OTHER
FACILITY BUT CERTAINLY START OF
IT AND THAT'S SPRING IN THIS
BILL. I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR. WITH YES WITH MY
OWN AND MY SPONSORS- TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE. THAT THE TRIGGER FOR
ACQUIREMENT SO. THE OPPOSITION
SAY WELL- WE DON'T WANT TO BE
HOLDING PP WHEN THERE'S A
SHORTAGE OUT THERE. I AGREE AND
I THINK DEGREE AS WELL WE HAVE.
NEGOTIATED ABOUT LANGUAGE TO BE
AT. WHEN IF THERE'S A SHORT TWO
PEOPLE WHO ARE THE FRONT LINE
TO WHAT THE PART DID BUT WHAT
IS NEED TO BE ABLE THAT STOCK.
BECAUSE IT'S OUR SUPPLY CHAIN.
GOES DOWN AGAIN WHETHER FOR
THIS ARE FUTURE PAN. WE WILL BE
THAT. STILL THERE. AT TIMES TO
RESET THE SUPPLY CHAIN SO WE-
KEEP PEOPLE PROTECTED. SO I
REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FOR YOUR WORK IN YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE I'M
PROUD TO BE A PARTNER WITH YOU
HOPEFULLY VIEW. THE SERVICE
YEAH. BILLS A WAY REALLY. YOUR
LEADERSHIP I KNOW YOU ARE A
LEADER DOES A- SOMEONE WITH A
DEAL STRUCK BACK ON HEALTHCARE
AND- STRICTLY AND- AND- MONKS.
FIRST RESPONDERS. IN FRONT
LINES AND I THINK THIS IT'S
IMPORTANT AT THIS BILL UP TO
MOVE FORWARD AND A PRIEST THAT
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE- WITH.
WITH NâNG B. BUT WITH A- AS
WELL. AND THAT SO. BUT I DO
THINK THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
DRESS ISSUES THAT I THINK THAT
YOU SHOULD USE THAT SEVEN BY.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS. PART.
LUCIEN TO. DROPPING THIS.
THANKS BUT ASSEMBLY RODRIGUEZ
I'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE BILL THE
PRO. YOU SENATOR PAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROAD WOULD YOU TO CLOSE.
SOMEONE AT THE CHAIRMAN'S FOR A
ALONG TO PRESENT THIS BILL THIS
MORNING OR THIS AFTERNOON JUST
WANTED A QUICK COMMENT NOT SURE
MAYBE ABOUT MY DAUGHTER THE
HEALTH CARE. SHE'S ON THE FRONT
LINES OF OVERHEAD. STILL TO
THIS DAY I SPOKE WITH HER LAST
NIGHT AND SHE JUST FOR STRIP OF.
HER UP IN MY SHOES ARE. AND
YOUR WILL CALL YOU CHIP FROM MY
THE SPEND DOWN ACT AND THEY'RE
STILL ON A- WITH P. IS TO THIS
DAY. BUT A HOSPITAL COUNTY SHE
WORKS WHERE YOU HAVE TO YOU. A
MASK. FOR YOUR ENTIRE SHIFT IN
THE WORKING OF COVERT FLOOR
ABOUT THE PROBLEM. SO HOPEFULLY
WITH BILL COULD MOVE FOR THERE
ARE HEALTH CARE WORKERS. ARE
YOU ARE GIPSON THE PER. FIVE PP
ISN'T NEED TO PROVIDE CARE
TREATMENT THE PEOPLE AT THE AGE.
IN THIS IN THE STATE REGARD
WITH. OR FOR EXTRA DISASTER
THAT MAP PERSON WITHOUT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS I'M BUT SICK DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS MEMBERS
PLEASE TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES
IN ORDER TO CAST A VOTE CENTER
HILL HIGH UNDER HILL HI CENTER
MORALE RIGHT NOW. THE NUMBER
ROW NO SOONER JACKSON. JACKSON
HI SENATOR JACKSON HI CENTER
MITCHELL MITCHELL ALL RIGHT
CENTER MITCHELL HI SAN PAN HI.
THE HI THE HAS FOUR VOTE IT IS
A TO CONGRATULATIONS MISTER
RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO I DO NOT SEE ANOTHER OFFER
AUTHOR SO I WILL PRESENT. I
WILL PRESENT ITEM NUMBER ONE.
AND IF. SENATOR PAN WITCHER A
WHAT IT IS I DO THAT I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT. THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER ONE OF. AB ONE NINETY
SIX. OKAY THANK YOU WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN- SO THIS AGAIN
THIS IS A NUMBER ONE EIGHTY ONE
NINETY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR EIGHT NINETY SIX
WOULD TOUR THE CENTRAL WERE
CONTRACT CALLED. TEEN WHATEVER
TO BECAUSE FOR ASSIST SUCH AS
COVERING MY BILLS OR PICK
PARTIAL RIVER. WELL. TABLE IN
THE CURRENT BUT NINE TEN
PERSONS HOT TRANSMISSION RAGING
FROM PEOPLE WITH VERY MINOR
KNOWS SHOULD BY CONTINUE TO
SHOW UP TO WORK ESSENTIAL
WORKERS FROM GROWTH STORE TO
TRANSIT HAVE THEIR HEALTH AT
RISK BY INTO WITH THE POPE WHO
WERE BROUGHT UP SUFFICIENT TO
PROTECT. OR OTHER PART I'M SAFE.
KEEP THEM SAFE THIS MISSION
WHAT. IN LIGHT OF THIS UNIQUE
OF STANCES CONSERVATION AND
TURNS FOR CALIFORNIA'S LAW
WORKER COMP INSURER VOLUNTARILY
THROUGH THAT ESSENTIAL WORKERS
THEY CUT COVERT ON JOB AND THE
GOVERNOR ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER PROVIDING A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION. WHICH CONTRACTED
WITH NINETEEN AT WORK HELLO
EXECUTIVE ORDER EXPIRES JULY
FIFTH LEAVING WORKERS UNCERTAIN
ABOUT THE FUTURE CASE. CONTINUE
TO INCREASE. NINETY SIX
INTENDED TO ENSURE THE BEST
WORKERS CON OVER NINETEEN OR
NOT SO TO UNREAL BIRD OF PROOF.
TO FOR DELAYS NEXT THING
WORKERS COMP IS BENEFITS
ASSISTED. THE BILL WHICH WILL
BE AMENDED IN SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD PROVIDE IT
VITAL FUNCTION THAT THE NOVEL
CORONAVIRUS WAS CONTRACTED IT
IS CENTRAL. TO FIVE AT WORK FOR
INJURED. AFTER MARCH FIRST
TWENTY TWELVE. ASIAN EXPERIENCE
SYMPTOMS AND TEST WELL I FOR.
MOVIE THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION AMONG VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS AND POINTS OF VIEW
ON HOW TO BEST PROTECT WORKERS
WHO CONTRACT OVER NINETEEN AT
WORK. THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL COLLEAGUES. THANKS SO
MUCH CENTER HELLO- I DO HAVE TO
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS SO YOU DO-
YES ON MY SHEET OKAY HERE SO-
THERE THERE. I HAVE A BIRD A TO
RICO IN THE UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS AND MITCH
STAGGER FROM- BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ARE
THEY ON OKAY OR SO WE WILL
AGAIN- FOUR MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY I'LL GIVE IT TO ME
WALK. EXCEED TWO MINUTES A KNOW
YOU STORE IN TWO THE SINCE. SO
THEM. TRYING TO CO SPONSOR HIS
MEASURE HAS HIGHLIGHTED BY
SENATOR HILL. OBVIOUSLY
STUDENTS TO BE DONE AS MOST OF
THE STATE IN THE COUNTRY IS
REQUIRED TO STAY HOME TO
WORKERS OVER PART OF THE WORK
IS IDENTIFIED BY SEVERAL
INSTANCES SERVICE WORKERS. YOU
KNOW I'M I'M HEARD JUST WANTED
THROUGHOUT THE DAY FROM A
VARIETY OF EMPLOYER AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THE YOU KNOW I
KEEP HEARING IS THAT THEY- THEY
CAN'T DO IT IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE
IT'S COST PROHIBITIVE THERE'S
TOO MANY CHALLENGES. AND I JUST
THINK THAT THAT'S TOUCH OUR
NEWLY UNFAIR AND TO BE HONEST
NOT NOT ACCURATE- IF YOU LOOK
AT THE NUMBER OF CLAIMS
WOULDN'T FILED OVER THE LAST
YOU KNOW SIX MONTHS COMPARED TO
LAST YEAR. DILLON AT 30%
DECREASE IN OVERALL WORKERS
COMP CLAIMS ON THE STREETS
BECAUSE WORKERS HAVE BEEN
WORKING THERE I'M CALLING. FROM
AIRPORT TO JUNE THERE'S BEEN A
50% REDUCTION IN THE FILING OF
CLAIMS SO CLAIMS ARE
SIGNIFICANT THAT. RATE IS NOT
GOING UP SO THE PROFIT MARGIN
FOR INSURANCE COMPANIES
CONTINUES TO GROW BUT RECENT
STUDY BY EMPLOYERS GROUP. HE
SAID YOU KNOW IT SURE AND ONE
OF THE- SPONSORS ONES THAT.
NINETY SEVENTY. RANGE BECAUSE-
I WANT SO I REALLY BELIEVE THE
CALL YOUR CONCERN ARE ARE VERY
OLDER ARE. AND TRY TO CREATE A
NEW ME THAT JUMPED UP REPORTER
PRESUMPTION FOR THE LIVE NUMBER
ONE THAT ARE. THEMSELVES COPE
WITH THE ENTIRELY UP ON THE
LISTEN. WITH I WATERMELON US MY
TIME AND STRUCTURE. OKAY THANK
YOU LET'S NOW ON TO THE STEIGER
WITH THE CAL LABOR FEDERATION.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE WOULD
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS WITNESS AND THE CHAIR
AND- IT ALSO JUST WANNA MENTION
THAT WHILE WE DO BELIEVE A
CONCLUSIVE PRESUMPTION ITS
CONSTITUTION. REBUTTABLE WANNA
START STREAMING HELPFUL FOR
WORKERS AND WE'RE STILL VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. OF
THE ONE SYSTEM I ALWAYS REALLY
STRUGGLED WITH. PATIENT
WELLNESS ESPECIALLY CONTAGIOUS
DISEASES CONSTRUCTORS ARE
CONTRACTED AT WORK- IT REALLY
DOES PUT A LOT OF BURDEN ON
WORKERS TO. PROVE SOMETHING
THAT OFTEN CAN'T BE PROVEN THAT
MOST WORKERS ARE LEFT WITHOUT
THE CARE THAT THEY DESERVE
UNDER THE LAW THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BUT NOT JUST BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
IT SHOULD BE BETTER FOR WORKERS
BECAUSE- WE REALLY DO THINK
THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE-
TEMPORALITY OF ALL THE COULD
NOT. CLOSE IMAGE WORKERS FIND
THEMSELVES THEY'LL REALLY POINT
TO A PRODUCTION LIKE THAT THOSE
BUT WONDER POLICY TO PUT IN
PLACE SACRAMENTO COUNTY FOR
EXAMPLE THEY'VE HAD A SHELTER
IN PLACE ORDER SINCE JULY
FOURTEENTH MOST OF THE COUNTY
FROM SOME VERSION OF THE SAME
THING WHICH BASICALLY MEANS
THAT. WE ARE BEING ORDERED TO
NOT GO OUT. EXPOSE OURSELVES TO
THE BUYER FROM ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY. AND IF YOU LOOK AT
THE CDPH COUNTY MONITORING
LESS. OFTEN DETAILS WHAT'S
DRIVING ELEVATED TRANSMISSION
IN EACH COUNTY WHEN THEY DO GET
INTO THE CAUSES OF THE SPIKE
WHAT PLACE TRANSMISSION IS OFF
ASKED OR NEAR THE TOP.
SOMETIMES IT'S AN INDIVIDUAL
EMPLOYER SOMETIMES IT'S AN
ENTIRE INDUSTRY BUT- ACTUALLY
GOES THAT WORKPLACE EXPOSURE IN
MANY CASES REALLY WHAT'S
DRIVING THIS PANDEMIC. OF THE
ART THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE NOW
PARTIALLY REOPENED. THAT MEANS
THAT A PRESUMPTION DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE IN A. WORK RELATED. YOUR
COMPLEX WITH A RISK. AND THE
BLACK ON THE CLERK NOW THE BILL
IS OVER FOR. IT DOESN'T GIVE
OFFER FOR THOSE K. WHERE YOU
KNOW THE HYPOTHETICAL SHOULD
ENSURE THE- IS TO UP WHEN AN
EMPLOYER HAS A LOT OF EVIDENCE
THAT AGAIN WORKER. HAS SAFE
OUTSIDE OF WORK MAYBE DOESN'T
HAVE THAT MUCH OF. OUT WORK WE
CAN ACCOUNT FOR THOSE CASES
WHERE THEY DO MAKE SENSE WITH
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION BUT- THE
PRESUMPTION PLACED UP. FOR WHAT
MOST WORKERS ARE DOING WHAT
MOST OF GOING THROUGH AND
THAT'S WHY WE SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WOULD WILL TAKE UP. THIS IS
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE PLEASE.
REFERENCE MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
THE BILL WE HAVE A K. FOURTEEN
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTER AND
CIVIL. BY THANK YOU. SEEN
ADDITIONAL. AND ROOM FOR TWO
THREE MOVE TO ROOM TWELVE. CENA
ROOM TWELVE FOR THAT'S MOVED ON
TO DART. LINES MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANY
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR A ONE NINETY
SIX THANK YOU. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO QUEUE
UP IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE NINE
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE WILL FIRST GO
TO LINE THREE TWO ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MEMBERS NOW
BROUGHT ON THE AFTER THE
TEAMSTERS AMALGAMATED TRANSIT
UNION MACHINISTS- ENGINEER
CONTRACT. THE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS
THANKS WE HAVE LINE TWO EIGHT
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
ARE NAY BY ORDER WITH YOU ARE
YOU CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
THREE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
REMEMBER BEING WITH THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS CAPITAL PORT- PROVIDING
COVERT NINETEEN WORKERS
COMPENSATION COVERAGE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS ESPECIALLY THE MANY
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS LACK
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE. THE
BILL WITHOUT RESERVATION THAT
GREAT. BUT THE BURDEN OF ANY
KEEP PINA INCREASES ALL COUNCIL
JUST. THANK YOU WOULD TAKING OR
BECAUSE THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
NINE THREE TWO THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THINK HE'S LOOKING AT
IT STILL WORKERS DISTRICT
TWELVE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE THREE TWO EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
NANCY VARIANTS WITH SEIU LOCAL
ONE REPRESENTING NINETY
THOUSAND STATE EMPLOYEES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK THANK
YOU. IF THERE ANY PLANS TO KEEP
OPEN SUPPORT OF AB ONE NINE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE AT LEAST
ONE ADDITIONAL LINE QUEUING UP
ONE MOMENT. THANK YOU WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO THE LINE. NINE
TWO SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
INTERBOROUGH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION INTO COURT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND IF WE HAVE
ANY FURTHER LIVES IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'VE KNOWN
FOR THE KEEPING UP. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NOW WILL MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION WE HAVE- THE LEAD
OPPOSITIONS AS- PLAIN PORTIS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES IN THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA AND BEEN. HAVE NECK
WITH THE CAL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE SO LET'S BEGIN WITH. A
PLANE BORDERS- AND AGAIN IT'S A
TOTAL FOUR MINUTES. FOR BOTH
TESTIFIED ERRORS AND I'LL GIVE
YOU A TWO MINUTE WARNING IF YOU
SEE TWO SETS. THANK YOU AND
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS EIGHT FORGET ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DELEGATION OF
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES. IN
THE FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB ONE NINETY SIX POINT
TWO UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE TO ADD.
ANYTHING BUSINESSES ARE TO
GREAT EMPLOYMENT AND- CANTERED
PERTAINING IT BECAUSE THEIR-
AND THE PUBLIC THING ARE
EMPLOYER ARE COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFITS FOR WORK HARD TO KEEP
IT THAT COULD BE NINETEEN BUT
IT IS UNFAIR TO FORCE
STRUGGLING EMPLOYERS TO WITHIN
THE BURDEN OF NON NETWORK DID I
TELL. OKAY WHAT PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS TO HELP ALL IN
WORKERS ECEIVE A- CARE UNIT
POSSIBLE WE RECOGNIZE THAT HERE
IN THE BIG STORY JERRY TIME IS
MORE URGENT THAN EVER. DESPITE
THE COMMENTS MADE BY. EIGHT AND
TELL THEM THAT PUBLIC AND
EITHER CAN. TO IMPROVE
POLITICALLY UNDER THE EXISTING
FRAMEWORK AT THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND CREATING AT. THE
NILES ARE IN THE APPROPRIATE
INTENT OF NEGATIVE TEN OR KNOWN
IT NON INDUSTRIAL CAUSATION FOR
WHICH THERE COULD NOT
REASONABLY BE AGHAST. AT
TAXPAYER DOLLARS PROVIDED.
EIGHTY ONE NINETY WOULD BE IN A
CAN FOR NON INDUSTRY CLOTHING
HE SAID WHAT WILL IDENTIFY
COSTS ON STRUGGLING SMALL
BUSINESSES AND PUBLIC AGENCIES.
MANY OF HIMSELF ON THEIR
WORKERS COMP CLAIM. WHEN
CONSIDERING WHERE. TO MANDATE
PUBLIC DOLLARS CLEVELAND THAT
EACH YOU CUT. IN THE CAR H. HI
HI L. IF THEM IS NOT DESIGNED
OR TO PAY FOR ALL IN AND
INJURIES THAT ARE TO WORK OKAY
LEAVE EVERY OF A PRESUMPTION
THAT THAT C. I. R. D. AT THE BY
DID AND BUYING THAT COULD BE A
PRESUMPTION WILL COST TAXPAYERS
AND EMPLOYERS BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS SH IN ADDITION TO THE
GOLD CHALLENGES THERE ARE
SEVERAL IMPLEMENTED CHALLENGES
WITH EIGHTY ONE THANK. OUTLINED
SECTION ALLEN SAID SHE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE IS WORKING
THE CHAIR AND CAN THANK YOU FOR
IN APPROACH THAT BEING CAN.
MISTER ALI AND HER THE POTHOLE.
I'M THAT SB THAT NINE. BALANCE
IS WORKPLACE SAFETY AND
RECOVERY IN A WAY DOES NOT
THREATEN THE DALY OF SMALL
BUSINESS. JOBS AND PUBLIC
SERVICES. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE ON GOING EFFORTS BUT REMAIN
WITH. OPPOSED EIGHTY NINETY AT
TIME. THANK YOU SO NEXT UP IS
AN AETNA THE CAL CHAMBER HAVE A
MINUTE FORTY SO. EVEN CHAIRMAN
SENATORS BUT BECOME CALIFORNIA
CAME OF COMMERCE AND WE ARE A
WERE OPPOSE AB ONE NINETY SIX
WINTER STATED THIS IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS AND
LEGISLATIVE ACTIVITY AROUND
THIS ISSUE WOULD LIKELY WE'VE
TRIED TO BE A PRODUCTIVE PART
OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS THIS
YEAR TO FIND A NARAL.
APPROPRIATE SOLUTION TO THE
ISSUE. BUDGET UNFORTUNATELY
CONCERNED THAT THE BROAD SCOPE
OF THIS PROPONENTS PRESUMPTION
MAY NOT HAVE A RATIONAL NEXUS
TO ACTUAL ELEVATED RISK WE WERE
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
AFTER THE ISSUANCE OF THE WAR
WELL NOT EVERYONE WILL AGREE
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S DECISION
ISSUED THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
WORDS LAW TO IT WOULD VIRTUALLY
THE ENTIRE STATE WHICH I DOWN
ONLY. PRESS WORK THERE. THA
WAS INDIVIDUAL AT A LIKELY CALL
LINK TO THE- AT THE STATE HAS
BEGUN TO RE OPEN OF THE
PREVIOUS WEEKS OF MY EVEN WITH
SOME. OUR STATE IS LARGELY OPEN
PEOPLE ARE COMING INTO WITH
OTHER TO NORMAL SO INNER AND
OTHER OF CONTACT THEREFORE WE
CAN BELIEVE THE SAME APPLIES
EXISTED DURING STATEWIDE
SHUTDOWN TO PRESUPPOSE AN
ELEVATED RISK FOR A WIDE SWATH
OF WORKERS. SUCH AS THOSE
COVERED BY THIS LEGISLATION THE
COUNTRY TO WE THERE'S OF
EVIDENCE AND DATA FROM PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS TALKING ABOUT
FAMILY GATHERINGS OTHER
EXPOSURES WE APPRECIATE ALL THE
CONCLUSIVE PRESUMPTION HOWEVER
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THREE
OTHER FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS
ABOUT. THIS BILL WHAT ABOUT
WORK. WHAT IS A DEFINITE OF AN
ESSENTIAL WORKER OF THE- OF THE-
THESE ARE FUNDAMENTAL IS SO OUT
IN CERTAIN. LIVING COSTS TO THE
SYSTEM. SENATOR HOW WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH YOUR STAFF
AND OTHERS REGARDING SOME OF
THE OTHER PROPOSALS ON THIS
ISSUE MOST NOTABLY ON AT ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO AND WE
KNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS A UNIQUE
AND UNPRECEDENTED SITUATIONS
THAT MAY WARRANT A TO GET INTO
A PLACE WELL BEYOND WHERE WE
GENERALLY FALL WHEN IT COMES TO
PRESUMPTION IS USUALLY.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS FALL. THIS
BILL IS TOO BROAD IN SCOPE AND
DURATION AND OTHER FUNDAMENTAL
FLAWS. FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB ONE
NINETY SIX. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THREE ALL RIGHT SO HEARD
TESTIMONY ON OPPOSITION NOW
WILL- FOR OTHER PEOPLE WHICH
EXPRESSED OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
ONE NINETY SIX WILL FIRST BEGIN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE SEEN OR
THE MICROPHONE LETS GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE. C. NINE LET'S GO TO
THE TELEPHONIC LINE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
PEOPLE WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY ONE NINETY
SIX AND AGAIN IT'S NAME. AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU'RE
AFFILIATED ONE THE ONE AND YOUR
POSITION. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO KEEP UP IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE NINE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE TWO FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT DON'T
GIVE THEM SOME BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION. AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. FIVE
THREE ONE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MODERATE HOP ON BEHALF
OF ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. NINE THREE TWO ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURKE BEVERAGE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
IN OPPOSITION. YEAH. NINE THREE
TWO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CARE MEMBERS
KATHY VAN AUSTIN ON BEHALF OF
UNITED AIRLINES AND AIRLINES
FOR AMERICA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. NINE THREE THREE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK RICHARD
SCHICKEL SHELTER HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION ON
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND PRISM
THE PUBLIC RISK- INNOVATION
SOLUTIONS IN MANAGEMENT- IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE TWO SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS YOUR
MEMBERS ABOUT THE AMERICAN
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURANCE
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. NINE THREE ONE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BEACH AND
MERRY ARE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NINE
THREE TWO NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GARCIA WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
NINE THREE THREE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE
HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE TWO
NINE FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE GOING
TO GO HERE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL POSITION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NINE
THREE THREE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH BACK
THEN THE ONLY HALF OF THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN FARMERS OF
CALIFORNIA CAL APPLE CALIFORNIA
BLUEBERRY. COMMISSION
CALIFORNIANS WITH CAL JUST ME
CALIFORNIA FRUSTRATED SO
CALIFORNIA CONGENER IN GARDENS
HM ARE WHAT THE CLINTON DEALERS
NEED THE FARMERS LEAGUE
CALIFORNIA RIGHTS COMMISSION
LECTERN AGRICULTURAL PROFIT
THERE'S A CONFUSION. IN WESTERN
PLANT HEALTH. PUBLICATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IF THERE IS ANYONE ELSE THAT
WOULD WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AB ONE NINE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE KNOWN FOR
THE KILLING UP. THANK YOU SO
MUCH HAVE A HEAVY HERE
TESTIMONY OF TWO QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CENTER
MITCHELL. THANK YOU I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE I MUST HAVE
MISSED SOMETHING IN OUR OFFICE
IN THE BILL THAT I READ
PREPARING FOR TODAY- CREATED A
CONCLUSIVE PRESUMPTION. THAT
WE'VE TAKEN AMENDMENTS TO THE
YES THE MEMBER MAKING A LOT OF
PROCREATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY
SEEING NONE THE OPPONENTS OF
THE- THERE JACKSON JUST
CHECKING YOUR YOUR GOOD. OKAY
YOU CAN FAX US SEEN NONE CENTER
HOTEL AT THE CLINIC YOU VERY
MUCH WELL I JUST APPRECIATE
THE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
IN THE HARD WORK THAT SHE HAS
PLATE PUT INTO THIS ISSUE AND
AS YOU KNOW THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF BILLS RELATED TO THE SAME
CONCERN AND- THE ISSUE OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND
BASICALLY PROTECTING THE RIGHTS
AND THE END OF OUR WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IS ONE. AND THE
GOAL IS TO KEEP THEM MOVING SO
THAT WE CAN FIND THAT SPOT OVER
THE NEXT TWO WEEKS WORKING WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
OPPOSITION CHOI RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL ON BEHALF OF-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ OKAY
THANK YOU IS THERE A MOTION THE
BILL THE BILL OKAY SO THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED- SO AGAIN-
THIS IS EIGHTY ONE NINETY SIX.
IT'S BEEN BY MITCHELL THE
MOTION IS TASKED TO PROBE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS PLEASE ON YOUR
MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO CAST A
VOTE. CENTER HILL HI. CENTER
HILL HI CENTER MORALE NO.
BETTER MORALE NO SOONER JACKSON.
JACKSON HI SENATOR JACKSON HI
SENATOR MITCHELL MITCHELL ON
THE MITCHELL HI CENTER PAN.
OKAY THAT BILL IS ABOUT THREE
ONE. THANK YOU AND IN THAT
INTERPRETING THE NEXT WANTED
LIKE A PRESENTER OKAY TWENTY
NINE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE SO THE
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
SEVEN- TO BE PRESENTED BY
CENTER HELEN BEHALF OF SOME OF
OUR O'DONNELL SENATE BILL WHICH
ELECT AGAIN THANK YOU I'M I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT THE AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DONALD WHICH CLARIFIES THAT A
PUBLIC AGENCY MAY NOT. AMEND
ITS CONTRACT WITH CALPERS TO
EXCLUDE GROUPS OF EMPLOYEES
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY INCLUDED
UNDER THAT CONTRACT. CIVIL
SERVANTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
CONTRIBUTE A PORTION OF THEIR
EARNINGS TO THEIR CALPERS
PENSIONS. TRUSTING THEIR
INVESTMENT WILL PROVIDE A
SECURE RETIREMENT. MANY OF
THOSE EMPLOYEES INCLUDING
FIREFIGHTERS PERFORM DANGEROUS
AND DEMANDING JOBS. CONFIDENT
THAT THEIR PENSION BENEFITS
WILL ENSURE A SECURE FUTURE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES HOWEVER SOME
LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE DECIDED. TO
GAMBLE ON A RISKY MODEL THAT
DEPRIVES PUBLIC EMPLOYEES OF A
SECURE RETIREMENT BY AMENDING
THEIR CONTRACT. TO EXCLUDE
CERTAIN GROUPS OF EMPLOYEES
FROM CALPERS BENEFITS. LIMITED
ACCESS TO CALPERS ROB CRITICAL
PUBLIC SAFETY WORKERS OF THE
PENSION BENEFITS AND FINANCIAL
SECURITY. THEY DESERVE.
ADDITIONALLY IF A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF AGENCIES ADOPT THIS
MODEL. THE LOSS OF
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CALPERS COULD
TO STATE DESTABILIZE THE FUND.
IN IN DANGER THE RETIREMENT
BENEFITS OF ALL PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES. AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
SEVEN OF A NARROWLY TAILORED
BILL. TO ENSURE PUBLIC AGENCIES
USUALLY CALPERS AMENDMENT
PROCESS AS INTENDED. NOT TO CUT
OURS OUT SELECT GROUPS OF
EMPLOYEES FROM A SECURE
RETIREMENT. TEST ABOUT
TESTIFYING ON THE BILL IS
CHRISTY BALL. REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS REFUSED IN THE
HEARING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR AND I SEE OR WITNESS IS
PRESENT IN THE ROOM SO- MISS-
MISS BALA PLEASE. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MA'AM OF COMMITTEE
KRISTIE BELL MY HERE BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. THIS JUST TO BE
CLEAR THIS MEASURE DOES NOT
DICTATE THE TERMS OR LEVEL OF
BENEFITS TO BE PROVIDED UNDER
THAT CONTRACT- BUT DOES ENSURE
PARITY SO THAT ALL EMPLOYEE
CLASSES MAY EARNED A SECURE
RETIREMENT. THIS MEASURE DOES
ALSO NOT IMPOSE REQUIREMENTS
WITH RESPECT TO WOOD
CLASSIFICATION PLOYS ARE
COVERED UNDER INITIAL CONTRACT
WITH CALPERS. AND THE MEASURE
DOES NOT LIMIT AN AGENCY'S
ABILIY TO FURTHER CLARIFY ANY
EXISTING EXCLUSIONS IT JUST
SIMPLY MAKES CLEAR THAT THE
CONTRACT AMENDMENT PROCESS
CAN'T BE USED TO UNFAIRLY
EXCLUDED ENTIRE CLASS OF
WORKERS FROM CALPERS
MEMBERSHIP. THIS IS NOT
ALLOWABLE UNDER THE THIRTY
SEVEN X. SYSTEM AND THEREFORE
WE VIEW THIS AS A MEASURE OF
PARITY. THIS DOES NOT REMEDY
THE INJUSTICE THAT HAPPENED IN
THE CITY OF PLACENTIA BUT FOR
CLOTHES IS THAT IN THE FUTURE
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR. ALL THE
OFFERINGS FOR THE CHAIRMAN FOR
PRESENTING AND THE COST TO SHIP
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN. OUR
FIREFIGHTERS AND IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES EVERY DAY
INCLUDING. CALLS RISKING THEIR
LIVES FIGHTING THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC PROTECT THEM
AND THEIR RETIREMENT SECURITY.
AS THEY ARE PROTECTING YOUR
COMMUNITIES WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
SEVEN. THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WITH THAT WILL MOVE ON TO OTHER
WITNESSES SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF AB. TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN.
FIRST WILL BEGIN AND- FORTY TWO
OR THREE NO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE LET'S MOVE TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. C. NINE OF ONE TWELVE
ATAU MOVE ONTO OUR TELEPHONIC
SYSTEM. MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR PEOPLE WISHING TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN AND
AGAIN IT'S NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ACTED LIKE HE KILLED
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE WILL
GO TO LINE THREE THREE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS SERRA FLOCKS CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE DO
HAVE A FEW MORE LINES JUST
GIVING UP NOW ONE MOMENT. NINE
THREE THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MAKING SURE MEMBERS PAT
MORAN WITH THEIR AND REDUCE
SAYS HE IS REPRESENTING THE
ORANGE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE TWO SEVEN THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
AND YOUR WIFE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND IF THERE'S
ANYONE FOR THAT THAT WOULD LIKE
TO QUEUE UP IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE KNOWN FOR THE QUEUING
UP. THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION WE
HAVE- THE- LEAD OPPOSITION FOR
TESTIMONY AS DYLAN GIVENS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION. TO BRING
ON- TELLING GIVENS AND AGAIN
YOU HAVE A MAX OF FOUR MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY. YOU DO NOT. NEED
TO REQUIRE YOU'RE NOT REQUIRED
TO USE ALL OF THE TIME. THANK
YOU RICHARD CAN YOU HEAR ME
CLEARLY I YES I CAN PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU THANK YOU- YES
IF YOU DON'T GIVE THEM THAT I'M
WITH YOU CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION CALLING
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
SEVEN. I'D LIKE TO BY THAT MY
DUTIES IN THE LONG RECORD OF
SUPPORTING DEFINED BENEFIT
CONTRIBUTIONS AS A WAY TO
ATTRACT AND RETAIN EMPLOYEES.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO.
MY OPPOSITION AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY SEVEN IS BASED ON AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT PUBLIC
AGENCIES HAVE A DUTY TO
RESPONSIBLY MANAGE PUBLIC
FINANCES. END OF THE PUBLIC
AGENCY DETERMINES THAT DEFINED
BENEFIT PENSIONS OR SOMETHING
THEY CANNOT AFFORD. THESE
RETAIN THE OPTION TO WORK WITH
CALPERS TO MANAGE THOSE. COSTS
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS. THE
PUBLIC ISN'T DETERMINES THEY
CAN NO AFFORD OFFERED FIND
BETTER COUNTRY. I WOULD LIKE TO
INSTEAD OFFER A FOUR ONE K.
TILE PLANT. THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO EITHER LEAVE THE
SYSTEM ENTIRELY OR AMEND THEIR
CON- CONTRACTED CALPERS TO.
WITH CALPERS APPROVAL. REMOVES
CERTAIN CLASSIFICATIONS OF
EMPLOYEES FROM THEIR PENSION
CONTRACT WITH CALPERS. BOARD
INDICATED PLACENTIA. REMVE THE
CLASSIFICATION OF EMPLOYEES
WITH NO ACTIVE EMPLOYEES. FROM
THE CONTRACT THEN HIRE
EMPLOYEES AND OF THE
CLASSIFICATION. UNDER DIFFERENT
BENEFITS POINT. WHILE WE'VE
BEEN AT THE CORE DIGITAL TO
DRAW OUR PENSION COSTS THIS
BILL TAKES A TOOL AWAY BY SAY
IT'S ALL OR NOTHING WE ARE THE
PROVIDER TO FIND. PENSION TO
ALL EMPLOYEES OR NOT. ACTUALLY
WITH THE DRAMATIC INCREASE IN
PENN BECAUSE THAT WE BEEN THAT
MAY RESULT IN MORE EMPLOYEES
WITHOUT DEFINED BENEFIT
PENSIONS RATHER THAN LET THIS
BILL SEEKS. NO TO PUBLIC
AGENCIES ARE EXACTLY THE SAME
GET THIS BILL TAKES A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH BY
ELIMINATING THIS ROOM RARELY
RARELY USED TO. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF OUR
POSITION AND I ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE ON AB TWENTY NINETY SEVEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER GIVENS
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN WILL
FIRST START IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE SAY NOT AT THE
MICROPHONE LET'S REMOVE TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE. SAY NO ONE AT THE
MICROPHONE ROOM ONE TWELVE
LET'S MOVE TO OUR TELEPHONIC
LINE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE TO WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY SEVEN AGAIN ITS NAME OR
ITS ASIAN AND POSITION. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
KEEP UP IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NINE THREE ONE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TERM MEMBERS
YOU CAN MERRIER WITH THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE KNOWN FOR THE KILLING
UP. OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH WITH
THAT LET'S MOVE IT TO THE
COMMITTEE OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY I DON'T
SEE ANY- A CENTER WHO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL CULT OKAY I WOULD LIKE TO
IS ANIMOTION MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY ACTUALLY WELL YOU JUST
PRESENTED ITSELF MADE THAT THAT
TAKE THAT THEIR MITCHELL THAT'S
ALRIGHT AND THAT'S FINE WITH ME
THAT'S A GOOD. OKAY RIGHT OKAY
SO THIS IS NOW A TWENTY NINE
SIX SEVEN IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR MITCHELL THE MOTIONS
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS
PLEASE TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES
IN ORDER TO CAST A VOTE CENTER
HILL HIGH. CENTER HILL BY
CENTER MORALE. NO TOMORROW NO
CENTER JACKSON. JACKSON ALRIGHT
THEN- JACKSON BY SENATOR
MITCHELL. THE CHILL ON CENTER
MITCHELL BY CENTER PAN BY.
UNDER PAN BY. FOUR ONE THE BILL
IS OUT FOR ONE THANK YOU I'LL
PASS THE GAVEL BACK TO CENTER
HELP YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR PAN
FOR ALL OF YOUR HELP AND
ASSISTANCE TODAY IT'S MUCH
APPRECIATED. THAT WAS OUR FINAL
BILL ON ORIGIN WE WILL NOW GO
BACK THROUGH THE AGENDA TO CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THOSE
BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL SO I
BELIEVE I WILL GO THROUGH
PLEASE CORRECT ME MISTER
CONSULTANT TO WIN- I MAKE AN
ERROR IN TERMS OF THE BILL
NUMBER BUT I THINK IT THIS ITEM
NUMBER TWO. AB THREE TWO THREE
THREE IS ON CALL PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR HILL HI. SENATOR HILL
BY. THE BILL IS OUT. FOUR FIVE
pZERO THE CARD NUMBER THREE AB
SIX SIXTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CENTER MOREAU.
CENTER MORALE NOT VOTING
SENATOR PAM. THE BILL HAS THREE
VOTE IT IS OUT. WE NOW TO ITEM
NUMBER. TEN AB. TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BIRTH PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS CENTER
MURROW. MORALE KNELT CENTER
MOREAU NO THE BILL HAS FOUR
VOTE IT IS OUT THE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DONALD
PLEASE CALL THE OPTION NUMBER.
THE MOTION IS TO BE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MORALE HEALTH CENTER
MOREAU NO. BILL HAS FOR VOTE
AND IT IS OUT ITEM NUMBER.
TWELVE AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW PLEASE CALL
THE OPTION NUMBER. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR
JACKSON. NOT VOTING CENTER
JACKSON NOT VOTING TO AUTOS
THREE VOTE IT IS OUT. MOVING TO
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB THIRTY
ONE SEVENTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE PLEASE CALL AFTER
MEMBERS. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CENTER HILL HI
CENTER HILL HI CENTER MOREAU.
BUT BUILDING THEIR MORALE NOT
VOTING. I FOR VOTE IN IT IS OUT
pTHIRTY TWO SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA PLEASE CALL IT
MEMBERS. MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CENTER MORALE.
MORRELL NO CENTER MORALE NO THE
BILL HAS THREE VOTES IT IS OUT
I REMEMBER SEVENTEEN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SB THIRTY
THREE SIXTY NINE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MOTIONS TO
PASS TO CORPORATION CENTER HILL
HI. CENTER HILL HI. THE BILL
HAS FIVE VOTES AND IT IS A
COUCH THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE-
LABOR COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORD. THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION AND
THANK YOU TO THIS WONDERFUL
STAFF THAT HAS DONE SUCH A
TREMENDOUS JOB OF PROVIDING THE
ASSISTANCE THAT WE NEEDED USED
AND- MUCH MUCH APPRECIATED
TODAY DIDN'T YOU MADE THIS
QUITE A SUCCESS- THE SENATOR
MITCHELL. ON BEHALF OF THE
SITTING COMMITTEE MEMBER
SENATOR HERE LET US YOU FOR
STEWARDSHIP AND LEADERSHIP OF
THIS COMMITTEE I'M GOING TO
ASSUME A LOT OF THINGS COULD
HAPPEN THREE WEEKS OF THIS WILL
BE THE LAST CONVENING OF THE
LABOR COMMITTEE BUT ON BEHALF
OF ALL OF US ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE WE TIP OUR HAT TO
YOUR LEADERSHIP WE THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU THIS IS A
HEARING IS ADJOURNED